okay good morning uh to those of you who
are uh joining us thank you for uh doing
so it's N9 o'clock I'm going to open up
the subcommittee work session for House
Bill 1504 relative to architectural
paint recycling and with that I'm going
to sort of just give an overview of
where we were we heard this bill come
before us um in committee and we
obviously know that the intent of the
bill was to stand up in architectural
paint recycling program and a
stewardship organization perhaps to
oversee that
um and the bill it uh as it looks to me
initially would establish some new
subsections within 149 M which is our
Solid Waste
statute um I have taken the liberty and
and uh Kristen grant our researcher is
going to send out links to you all uh
regarding a side bys side comparison of
two pre previous iterations of um this
bill that came before house environment
and agriculture in 2014 one in
2020 um as well as obviously we have uh
the current language in
1504 um she also was kind enough to pull
up some statistics about architectural
paint recycling across the country and
gave some statistics there um as well
and I believe she'll send that out um to
folks to pull that up uh I don't Kristen
did you were you able to send that to
members yet
or
great
yeah no no no that's perfect thank you
so much um so with that I'm going to
open it up to the to the members here on
the subcommittee to um talk about I've
sent you um links to the the previous
pieces of legislation I've also sent you
a link to what I'm going to call a
guiding sort of organ ization with paint
care would be a potential model for this
type of program to be stood up in New
Hampshire so that is also in your email
inbox and with that I will um just look
to the members to hear some thoughts and
feedback from you all on first of all
the hearing and and where you think
we're headed um on
1504 representative
gerna thank you madam chair U so I I
think that one of the benefit that we
have in this case as we look at what is
effectively a kind of extended producer
responsibility is that you already have
industry Buy in there is already as as
we've seen we talked about and then as
as the chair sent out uh some
information for us so I think that this
should be um relatively easy I say that
advisedly but uh because we have
industry buyin uh and support and I
think Brad bipartisan support I think it
it makes makes it a lot easier for us to
move forward we have a couple of
relatively recent attempts to do this
that that we can kind of learn from so
in any event I'm I I'm optimistic given
all of that that we can find a way to
work through the industry sponsored
efforts to get to a point that you know
we can make a real um real steps forward
here in New Hampshire great thank
you representative RAR thank you uh I I
would just wondering who who in the
industry uh was receptive uh to this
bill who who are
the um the manufacturers I guess the
ones that that agreeing with um this Pro
this type of
program is that a question for the
chair e either one I may have missed
those discussions and those talks I just
want to know what who's um agreeing to
this sure I I think that the overall
intent that we have seen historically
there are currently um so so that you're
aware
11 states and districts so 10 states in
in the District of Columbia who have
already implemented um a version of this
program where um major paint
manufacturers are participating in this
program as a way to keep the um
architectural paint out of landfills and
in that um document there are a myriad
of ranges of sizes of States from
California to small states like Rhode
Island in Vermont that are participating
with industry um buyin for um
stakeholders and the way it seems to be
structured from what I can see is that
an um an entity such as paint care which
I sent you is is sort of
the organization if you will that helps
run it within the state so it is like a
PPP sort of like a public private
partnership with an outside entity um to
do that work on on behalf of the the
recapturing
program thank you representative Kon uh
yeah thanks for the opportunity to speak
and to join you this morning um I'm just
curious do we have any kind of ideas
within the group on how we could execute
a program like this to be more in line
or how to do it in a New Hampshire way
like do we have any ideas of
like how we can structure it or the fee
schedule is the industry going to help
with uh the the general you know layout
of the
program um thank thank you to the member
for the question I I also did have uh a
couple of thoughts around that and
questions myself so um thank you for
bringing that up I would like to I'm
curious to know whether not setting up a
dedicated fund would make sense to
ensure that the program was self-
sustaining
um and so that those funds I know that
in previous iterations of the bill as
I've gone through the research have
required sort of an independent auditor
to come in and make sure that the funds
are available and maintained and it is a
self-sustaining program um I am
not um I do believe that it does
reference some of that in the current
piece of legislation 1504 but I think
there needs to be a little bit more
detail around that subject and around
that concept so I'd like to see a little
bit more of your thought followup uh
yeah thanks for the followup um so I
think I correct me if I'm wrong I think
I heard you bring up in previous
conversation the idea of maybe a pilot
program for something like this so maybe
if the group agrees we could uh support
a pilot program to show proof of concept
of how something like this would work in
New Hampshire and leave it open to uh
different municipalities or transfer
stations to see if this sort of program
would work for
them thank you to to the member for the
question I yes I did mention that um I
am curious to see how that might work on
a smaller scale um there's a million
different iterations of how something
like that could work on you know one per
County a few you know municipalities uh
by popul ation I don't know so we'll
we'll have to see how um something like
that might might shape up but I'm not
opposed to to looking at something like
that in the second year where we're um
it's it's pretty clear from the research
um depending on the various states there
are collection sites that range from for
example in the uh state of Vermont
there's 81 collection sites that have
saved about 1.1 million gallons of paint
out of a landfill and uh that's not
withstanding potential you know
if people are in fact dumping kitty
litter and adding weight to the disposal
fee um it's that is not enumerated in
the data that I have but I imagine that
even that portion would be a significant
um exclusion from our current
landfilling
so representative
Penza thank you um so going through the
paint care website which is fantastic by
the way because it kind of describes
sces a lot for it seems like for it to
be effective I understand like you could
do a pilot but for it to be really
effective um you want to be you want to
have these locations within you know 20
25 mile radius um where people could
drop off their paint um you know I
didn't realize that this was such an
issue until I started researching it um
people hide those materials a lot uh and
they and they're going in you know in
with the regular landfill stuff so um
and it creates an issue looking at the
fee
structure so it's it's not a tax it goes
on the cost of the paint right okay and
then that's my understanding in the way
that this current bill is is is
structured the same way correct and we
heard in testimony I believe that it
could range anywhere from I think 95
cents to a195 se charge yeah it says
here like you know you've got um let's
look at Connecticut or Colorado they've
got um larger than half a pint um
smaller than a gallon 35 cents you know
what I mean but one to two gallons 75
cents that that's they have a fee
structure in here so it's not a tax it
doesn't go to the state and then um it's
also of course not a deposit because you
don't get it back it's used for this
whole program here
um yeah they don't manage this is like
you can be part of that part of paint
care right but they don't manage it we'd
still have to you know incorporate or or
develop this program here through this
bill correct I think that there would
need to be a structure enumerated in
statute for the program to be able to
exist at my understanding and I um I
have the ability to communicate with
some folks at paint care um and advanced
codings there are there is the
opportunity rather for them to submit
data to the state to help facilitate the
proc process of what's being collected
and how much and those types of things
so I think it would be a Cooperative
Endeavor representative gerana thank you
madam chair so uh yeah I think that one
of the really nice things about this is
is that it can be done looking at the
Pain Care website it can be done through
retailers right so we're not talking
actually about adding to uh the work
that's being done at our landfills or
our transfer stations uh and it is o
minimizing significant amount of weight
as M referred to you know the weight
that is accumulated when you add
materials to the paint to try to dry it
out so uh and as the current bill refers
to
um of course I've lost my place in it
now well basically you would when you go
into buy paint if if the retailer
participates in the program you go into
buy paint you would get with that paint
educational or instructional materials
right so that when you are finished with
this paint there's a little bit left
whatever you can return it here and
explain the process to people so to me
that's an incredibly easy both for the
the stewards of this program which are
the industry and for consumers because
when you buy the paint as I said at
those participating retailers you would
also be given Specific Instructions
about how to return that paint right and
so then you're paying a little bit extra
for that gallon or half gallon of paint
you get that information and then you
return it that seems to me the kind of
thing that is working in a lot of States
right now and as I said it doesn't add
on to the work being done at transfer
stations or landfills uh and in fact
will reduce some of the work they're
doing because it's diverting um that
material thank you for that I also um
with regard to that that concept I I
wanted to talk with the subcommittee a
little bit about um whether or not we
believe that this bill um enumerates
whether or not the informational
materials is provided by the program
like paint care or if it is provided by
the retailer that was a little bit
unclear to me and okay and so my my
understanding and other iterations um
there were requests that the paint Care
Program provide some of that educational
material as part of that so that's just
something that was curious to hear your
thoughts on representative penda
yeah so this is the section where I you
know I've got a couple little red flags
on so
um so under uh
five uh five effective six months after
the effective date of the section A
wholesaler shall not sell an
architectural paint in the state unless
the wholesaler acts as a collection site
for architectural paint a wholesaler may
meet the requirements of this paragraph
by participating as a collect C site in
a manufacturer collection program deci
side in paragraph one and then it goes
into you know a wholesaler shall distri
point of sale instructions education
materials and signage and
such my only issue with this is I would
love to make sure that we
have the buyin
from you know 80% 90% of the the folks
that are selling this paint in the state
like I don't want to force something on
I don't I I mean I know that there's
I've read and I know that there's a many
manufacturers that are all on board with
this um and some of the largest paint
distributors but I just want to make
sure that um we have that buying through
the PE through our businesses here these
private businesses in the state I think
that's key before we slam down a mandate
I I think that's important that you know
we hear from them as well
so yeah I appreciate that uh feedback
thank
you represent I just wanted to say I
agree with those sentiments as well
thank you thank
you so I guess um with that I was I was
curious to know if
um under the current bill when we were
we were looking at um I guess it's under
subsection seven where it talks about
the program coordinating with an
existing solid waste collection program
to me this this could insinuate that we
are also looking at um transportations
other waste areas and I did look at um
the paint CARE program they did mention
in there that they do also work with
disposal
uh um political subdiv divisions to some
entities so we would have to make a
decision I think as a as a with regard
to this bill whether or not we were
interested in it applying only to
wholesalers or if there were political
subdivisions that would be involved in
the collection site Matrix if you
will representative n NAB sorry thank
you madam chair I just wouldn't want to
exclude them you know I want would want
it to be allowed it's not forcing them
to do it but if it municipality decides
that they want to do it then why should
we stand in the way of
that
yeah representative kulan yeah no I
think it should be optional for the
transfer stations if they want to do it
I do I I will say too I like the
manufacturer um route probably a little
bit more but you know if the transfer
stations are open to it like he had
talked about I remember the how they
sorted in like three different kind of
holding tanks or whatever so like if
they want to do something like that I
don't see why we should stop them from
doing that but I do like the uh
manufacturer buyback thing it seems to
be be more in line with just
responsibility
so thank
you representative Penta would you speak
to um if you know if you can would you
speak to the process of kind of in a in
like a um a high-end overview of like
what happens after the collection like
with what they're do you know what I'm
saying with what they're doing with the
paint so so it's my understanding based
on what I could see on the instructional
videos through uh Pain Care even just
just just at that is that the paints
would come in and depending on how it is
structured I think we heard about
testimony in Arizona where there were
three colors that were sort of collected
Vermont seems to have more colors that
it's almost like for like
takebackspace
item recapturing of very like specific
types um and it looked like those were
then um collected mixed together and
then
um re sort
of clarified or repurposed then into new
containers for discounted purchase I
believe of those items then into the
public
again so pretty much the only the color
that you get is pretty much
Brown no no no I I think it to answer
your question I think there were it
could be a varying different thing I
think we heard tan white and gray in
Arizona and then in Vermont it was
almost like for light colors um so they
had oranges and reds and Browns and um
so it depends on I guess how that was
structured thank you Kristen she is um
delivering all of the same things that I
have so that you have those for
consideration for today and perhaps even
in future convers
so um in 1504 and sub
paragraph
4 um we had sort of talked about the
fact that all paint manufacturers it
seems to me that this language states
that all paint manufacturers must
participate um
and I'm curious to know whether or not I
think that that is something that
perhaps we have seen through paint care
I do have some questions that I need to
get some clarity from those entities on
um but it seems like that's not an
uncommon request um for the program if
they are stood up in wholesaler or
retail establishments that anybody who
is selling within that retail
establishment is part of that
program
um and then I was curious to know
whether or not we
thought
six there were varying dates of I think
three months and six months mentioned in
1504 as far as effective
um date and yeah and it looks like the
it should take an effect uh 60 days two
months after passage I'm wondering if we
had any thoughts about whether or not
something of this whether it's a pilot
program or a Statewide enactment uh if
60 days was sufficient to kind of get
something out the door and rolling for
the department and I guess I would defer
to the department if you wouldn't mind
uh speaking and uh sharing any thoughts
or insights you might have with regard
to the architectural paint and if for
the record if you'll just introduce
yourselves
again uh Todd pisit with New Hampshire
Dees hazardous waste management Bureau
and Michael Nor with the solid waste
management Bureau of
Dees um the bill does require a Dees or
does require uh rules administrative
rules to be written um we don't have the
staff to to handle that right now so it
would likely require require hiring a
staff which isn't in the budget
necessarily um but if we did hire staff
that's a month two-month process and
then that H that staff would have to get
trained in writing rules and then the
rule making process so I think six
months is is very short for all of that
to
happen I think under normal
circumstances Ru making process probably
takes anywhere from at least six months
to maybe 12 months if you're if you're
talking about establishing a whole new
rule set more like 12 months
probably and so that would be over and
above the time required for establishing
the position hiring the position
training the person so you're talking
about a year at least maybe a year and a
half and may I first and then I'll I'll
look to anybody else who has questions
for the Department do you see there I
mean would you agree I guess the
question is that the way the current
bill is structured it would enumerate
new sections of the solid waste
management uh
statute uh yeah I believe I believe
that's true it says at the uh very start
of the Bill Amend RSA 149 M by inserting
after section 63 the following new
section or new subdivision so this is an
amendment to the existing Solid Waste
Management act and and and one more
followup if I may I did have a question
with regard to Extended producer
responsibility as well because we
already do have a section regarding
extended producer
responsibility um in
statute um so I was wondering whether or
not any of this could fall under that
area or do you feel like it should in
fact be enumerated as a separate entity
alog together could you clarify which
section of this because so I'm aware of
a section about Mercury reduction and
there's also a section about toxics and
packaging but the only thing that's
really epr I think is the Mercury
reduction thank you for the
thank you I appreciate that I was
actually looking at I thought it was 149
M col 62 but I could be
wrong
um that might be the solid waste working
group I don't I don't have it memorized
off the top of my head it it was under
so I I'm looking here sort of it's It's
conversations about Advanced Recycling
and what that is or isn't and so I was
curious to know whether whether or
not something like this would fall under
that or would you it seems to me that
you would think a whole separate statute
is
required I believe so there's nothing in
the in the statute currently that really
fits this kind of structure great so I
believe it would probably be its own
kind
of it it would need its own language
okay yeah thank you and representative
ger and then representative nav thank
you madam chair and so wondering if you
know the bill is is currently written I
need to flip back to it
requires
uh the department shall set goals this
is in section 5e the department shall
set goals for the collection of
architectural paint within four months
of the date of the first annual report
of the manufacturers program but if we
were looking at a program that started
as a pilot program where we had
retailers themselves uh who would
collect this paint uh and then provide
reports to to Dees on kind of six or 12
month basis in terms of how much they
have taken back in right as part of a
pilot program uh is that something that
that Dees could do if if this again was
a uh retailer based program and all
we're asking Dees to do is to receive
semiannual or annual reports on the
amount of paint that is being uh
returned I I think if if you're asking
Dees to review a couple of semiannual
reports or something like that that's
seems feasible but the question I I
guess for a pilot test would it require
administrative rules would it require
any any other type of oversight by Dees
because then you're talking about a
position that may or may not last the
pilot test doesn't seem to work out and
they they cancel it then you've hired
somebody for a year two years and then
and then eliminate that
position potentially can I can I just
add I think the other thing to consider
here is that we're talking about
collection of paint which includes latex
paint which currently is not regulated
as a hazardous waste but oilbased paint
and stains and varnishes typically are a
hazardous waste so if you're talking
about a retailer collecting those items
they may trigger and Todd can speak a
little bit more about this they may
trigger certain regulatory requirements
um yeah so most of the Home Depot and
lows in the state are already notified
as hazardous waste generators but places
like Ace and Benjamin Moore and Sherwin
Williams are not so if they started
taking in oilbased paints and stains and
varnishes they may have to become a
hazardous waste generator so back to
representative penza's question about
whether the retail ERS are are on board
I don't know I don't but that's
something that they would need to
consider thank
you representative n thank you madam
chair um is it possible that that
position could be a contract position I
mean it seems to hire someone to set
rules is not an indefinite
need unless they can be transferred to
other I was talking to um director whims
about this on Friday and his thought is
that when Bill bills like this come up
it's generally if there's a new position
it's generally uh funded from the
general fund um because there's a lot of
effort up front and the fees is not
going to have been collected yet but
then maybe there's a transfer to that
fee being part of or part of that fee
being paying that that position and
maybe after two years that can become a
a part-time position maybe work on other
things as well keep it a full-time
position that
is half paint care and half some
something else related um but we didn't
really talk about whether or not it
would be could be a contracted position
I don't know that Dees has a lot of
those not in Waste Management
anyway thank you uh representative
Penza since we have neighboring states
that are that that have are already
participating in this so for example
let's use Maine and uh they have 129
sites they've collected 1.1 million
gallons and so I guess they started this
in in looks like
2015 wouldn't it make the most sense to
talk to a neighbor and see how it how it
all started how it was implemented I
know I don't want to have to hire
another staff to implement this I think
that we have lots of sections in Statute
in reduction in recycling and all of
that um but for the people that have
been doing this the states that have
been doing this um wouldn't it make
sense to see how it's been operating and
how we could implement it without
putting any burden on the
department I yeah I can talk I could
talk to um I have a relationships with
the Hazardous Waste departments uh
divisions in Maine and Vermont who both
have paint care I could talk to them I
don't know if they are doing it without
any additional burden on the department
but it's it's a conversation we could
have thank you representative Penza
additionally yes um the state of Vermont
also only they have a much smaller sort
of site pool of 81 participants that was
established in 2014 and they similarly
were able to um keep out uh 1.1 million
gallons of paint um out of uh you know
the sort of waste stream if you will um
so I do think that uh perhaps if the
department an appetite for contacting uh
those neighboring states and and I too
can certainly reach out and and hear
some input on how those were structured
I also have statute that I can go back
and take a look at um I think that that
would be useful to our discussion
okay and I'll just add to
um
um the uh about the the the the number
of gallons of paint that have been taken
I I I would imagine I don't know I
haven't talked to any municipalities but
I would imagine that municipalities and
and County Planning commissions would
would support such a bill because they
Whenever there are household hazardous
waste collection events everyone I've
talked to says that the number one thing
they get is
pain representative brewyard and then
representative
Penza a couple of things uh I just
wanted to
also um make sure manufacturers are on
board with potentially becoming
hazardous waste generators whether it's
uh you know vsqg sqg squeegee full
quantity generator and and everything
that comes with it the permitting the
reporting you're now subject to
inspections uh I think that's key in
making sure manufacturers are going to
be on board with that uh Second thing
can we just get into the household
hazardous waste um days where typically
it's it's available throughout the
state um now is it all paint that
they're taking is are they not allowing
a latex or acrylic as far as I know at
least at least um the ones I've talked
to they don't take latex because latex
is not a hazardous waste so that's when
if if somebody brings latex paint to a
household hazardous waste event they'll
tell them put kitty litter in it or sand
or whatever dry it out and throw it away
they're they're only taking oilbased and
and stains and and that that sort of
thing okay thank
you representative Penza so when when I
lived in a a smaller town versus I'm in
Rochester in a city um I just have to
say that they were not enough those
those hazardous waste days sometimes
they're once a year and some of these
people are keeping you know these cans
in their you know in their garages in
their basements for a really long time
so um I I think there's an appetite for
it uh I just I hope that the process is
working and effective that we could
Implement something here in New
Hampshire without you know taxing
resources um
but
if let's say for example you had said
that Home Depot those types of places
already you know the bigger box stores
yes correct so we don't have to worry
about those so if it's a smaller one
like a Benjamin Mo or something like
that um an Ace Hardware you mentioned
that sells paint could they be a
um they wouldn't necessarily they could
participate in the program but they
wouldn't have to necessarily be a place
that is um a drop off location either so
we wouldn't have to worry about what
representative um brard is talking about
in a sense with permitting and all those
types of things that they would have to
be
correct I'm not sure what participate
means if particip to me I thought
participate meant you if you sell paint
you have to be a drop off location maybe
that's not the way it's actually I don't
believe that's the case so you can you
can sell the paint and it has like the
expanded fee on it but it's not
necessarily that you're taking it in
okay so participate could just mean
collect the fee correct okay that then
goes to the entity that's working on
where people can bring their um bring
their unused paint
so so I did have a question about um I
know that we have looked at other fee
structures and other programs obviously
the Mercury um and then we're we're also
looking at I like broader batteries
perhaps um and we know that those uh
programs are already out there like our
best buys again bigger box stores are
already taking some of those things back
we're looking to perhaps expand some of
that within the legislature this year um
but let's just focus on the the
traditional batteries that are already
being reclaimed um those seem to be
functioning without a whole lot of
oversight through the Departments would
I am I correct currently in that line of
thought or
thinking do have any knowledge on that I
guess well the the items that we're
talking about that are currently be
being collected at like a Home Depot
where they're taking in like Mercury
bulbs like those things are Universal
waste so they have a different set of
rules and again Todd can they're they're
under the Hazardous Waste rules but the
um hazardous waste rules are uh
administrative rules
enbw 100 through
1300 chapter 1100 is universal waste so
that's those things like batteries
antifreeze aerosol cans uh light bulbs
fluoresent bulbs those are all sort of
they're still regulated under the hazard
hazardous waste rules but they're exempt
from the generator a lot of the
generator requirements and um other
requirements in the rules so they they
are handled very
differently I know you had your hand and
then I'll go uh representative NAB and
was it representative pulon did you have
your hand up oh yeah okay so that's sort
of the order the way this bill is
written it sounds like the manufacturer
is taking ownership for the program so
even if you have a third party that the
manufacturer you know employs to have
collection they're still taking
ownership of it so they're the ones that
would be liable they're the ones that
would still have
to again assume be uh classified as the
generator um I mean this also gets in
line with uh training your employees to
handle hazardous waste uh it gets into a
whole uh you know plethora of other
requirements is set forth in uh the
um DS DS rules right generator rules
yeah uh generator rules are under 500 he
ENB hw500 thank
you NAB and then kulan and then
J um thank you madam chair I just wanted
to say big picture you know I do think
it's important to have manufacturer
support and buy in in this um but this
is also a huge service to our residents
and our municipalities you know it's a
big diversion of a very heavy weight
from the waist stream um and to
representative Po's point I think we all
have cans of paint in our basements that
we we don't know what to do with I know
my husband spends a lot of time asking
me when hazardous waste day is so um you
know I think it's a huge benefit so I
think it is important to have that buy
in but it's also important to recognize
that there are several stakeholders here
and it's not just the manufacturers
thank
you you and then I think we went
representative kulan and then
representative
gerna yeah I think
I the the pilot program I did kind of
just stuck in my mind when I heard about
this and the more
kind of details I'm hearing now that
need to be sused out I think that the
pilot program thing still sounds like a
good idea to me just to see if how it
would work out potentially you know we
can figure out who wants to be involved
where the sites are going to be and
things like that I think it's a good
idea to have at least a couple places in
New Hampshire where this paint can be uh
collected
so
ger thank you madam chair I think that
we're going down we're going too far
down a road that's not productive uh we
don't need to reinvent the wheel uh this
exists it exists very successfully in a
number of other states uh and and I
appreciate uh our friends from Dees
coming in to to answer our questions
today but I think the the people we need
to talk to are for example the paint
care people because they're doing this
right now I think a lot of good
questions have been asked but I'm pretty
sure that the paint care people who
represent the manufacturers could answer
those questions uh very quickly uh there
I am quite certain that we are not
thinking of questions that these folks
haven't already thought of uh in great
detail so with respect to our friends
from Dees and I think we're going too
far in the direction of Reinventing a
wheel that uh already exists and works
very well in lots of other places so uh
I would like to see us move in that
direction thank you madam chair thank
you uh representative gerna um and to
that to that point I think it would be
useful if maybe um we could get together
a list of questions I do have a contact
UM at the codings uh textile and codings
um as well as for paint care and I'm
happy to um get those to them a list of
questions so if if we are open to that
I'm happy to uh receive those from each
individual member um um and and we can
pait some questions to those folks as
well um I think the discussion has
generated some additional questions that
I had not um considered but I I agree I
think having uh their input is is
crucial representative
Penza oh and then I I'll definitely
recognize the department did you have
something on based on what I was just
based on thank you for the opportunity
just based on representative J's
comments uh we did receive an email from
Heidi mcalli at the Americans codings
Association over the weekend um saying
that she regretted not being able to be
here today um but that I think that that
organization is definitely willing to
participate in further discussions um I
think they were they had some concerns
about how the the current language in
the bill would uh not necessarily give
control to uh some of the manufacturers
and the way that they've made it work in
other states so I I think is definitely
willing to participate in the discussion
I think they were also hoping that there
might be an opportunity for interim
study or something like that to really
craft a language that might work for New
Hampshire so I just wanted to add that
no thank you I I too received that email
so I appreciate um uh the representative
from the American codings Association
and and so I to that point I I think we
can definitely reach back out to them it
was unfortunate they weren't able to be
here today um but I'm happy to uh take
the Department's insights um the codings
association's insights as well and and
have a future discussion on that this
bill is not so that we are all aware not
due out until the 21st so we do have
some time of
March um so we do have some time to work
on this concept and if we need future
meetings to sort of hash those things
out I'm happy to um get those things
sort of established in together I think
given where we are for today today I
wanted to you know hear the last few
moments of thoughts and kind of from the
subcommittee and get some general
direction of where where we should go
next but um we do have a 10: a start
time and I want to be respectful of that
for the hearings um for the rest of the
day
so representative Penza I can start off
um I just wanted to you know kind of
ditto on what representative ger said uh
I don't think we have to um reinvent
anything I think this is is uh it's
something that's successful and ongoing
and I would love to talk to our
neighbors and see how it wasle
implemented what they what they put
together for legislation all of that
kind of stuff um having manufacturers
that are already on board with this
having the codings um those folks not
you know so Dees doesn't have to have
their hands in it it's it's a it's a
well-run and if we start off with a
pilot because that's the way to do it
then that's fine with me too I just I
think this is something that we could we
can definitely make happen if however we
need to tighten up legislation remove
lines add lines or whatever so it it
matches exactly what programs are
currently successful and how they um
took off then I think that is something
that we can all Undertake and I'd be
happy to you know uh be a contact with
pain care and Maine whatever we need
so okay so with that I you know I I
think what I'd like to do is maybe
schedule another subcommittee work
session to sort of once I have the
opportunity to reach back out to some of
the other stakeholders ensure that they
can all be here for the the day and also
pait any questions that we have going
forward from today's meeting that we
would like answered from the ACA then I
think that we should do that and um if
there's anything else that I
haven't omitted or or not addressed
I don't know if any of the other members
have any other final thoughts um again I
just want to make sure that we we can
get some of those um answers to some of
the hard questions we had uh which with
how it works in other states um and how
their are you know their rules are
written thank
you I think seeing no other questions
I'd like to you know close out the
subcommittee work session and I think
the department for their time and their
insight and being here and I will um get
something noticed as soon as I discuss
with the members their availability in a
future date but um we will let you know
and um we'll also reach out to the other
stakeholders so I thank you for your
time thank you madam chair you're
welcome okay and with that we will close
out the subcommittee work
session
good morning everybody and welcome to
environment and
agriculture
um so this morning uh first I'd like to
start off with the Pledge of Allegiance
and would like representative smart to
lead us in
that
aliance to the flag of the United States
of America and to the Republic for which
it stands one nation under God
indivisible with liberty and justice
for thank
you and before we get underway I would
also like to recognize some special
guests in our audience this
morning um The Honorable haris sad and
The Honorable Rob Hafner both previous
chairs to this committee and both who
work with Council of state governments
East and Council of St state governments
uh they are here today and if we have
some time later we'll we'll uh invite
you up and have a uh give have you give
us an update of uh
CSG oh I'm sure you
are yeah we're always seem to be talking
trash
here okay um as we have on our um on our
docket this morning starting off uh with
HB I'm going to open up our executive
session for HB 1386 relative to
prohibiting the disposal of lithium ion
batteries um in Solid Waste landfill
facilities composting facilities or
incinerators and and I will uh be making
a motion for uh on OTP on the amendment
for that which is we need to adopt the
amendment oh to adopt the
amendment of um
97h submitted by representative Karen
evil
evil uh so I move uh to adopt that
Amendment do I hear a second I will
second that thank you representative
Bixby so um I will speak to this uh
motion I believe it's uh very important
that um this bill go forward we have
seen lithium ion batteries and heard
through testimony um they are can be
very dangerous at our uh facilities
causing fires and damage uh it makes
sense to uh leave them out of our
landfills and and uh composting
facilities and incinerators
um the what the amendment does is also
um um it makes it so that if somebody
tosses one of those
into um in landfills uh landfill
facility or composting facility or
incinerator by accident that they won't
be held liable for it um this bill also
expands a little bit and clarifies um
the definition of electronic waste and I
believe it's a good bill so I support it
do we hear any discussion for this
bill represent Bixby um so I think that
the the bill as amended makes a lot of
sense we heard we there was a question
about whether we should include lithium
as well as lithium ions and uh there was
we heard uh information that suggested
that that probably wasn't the the best
because it could uh create more
confusion and the lithium uh not in
ionic form is not as uh problematic uh
so that um having this uh just targeted
the lithium ion is
better okay any other discussion on this
bill seeing none I would like the um
clerk to call the role for this uh
adoption of this amendment thank you m
mam chair this is to adopt Amendment 202
44978 Madam chair yes represent Melvin
yes represent coma yes representative
Phillips yes representative Davis yes
represent Brad yes represent kulan y
representative
Kenny representative Penza yes
representative smart yes representative
Bixby
yes represent dut
yes represent Murray yes represent Jama
yes representative H Haskins hi
represent Howard yes represent NAB yes
represent moris
yes
180 motion
carries okay with that I'd like to um
move otpa for HP
1386 uh with the adopted Amendment do I
hear a second I will second that thank
you representative Bixby um and I yield
um speaking anything else on this bill
because I've already said everything so
any other discussion on
it seeing none I would like the uh clerk
to call the role please thank you madam
chair we're voting on Bill HB 1386 as
amended rep Madam chair yes represent
Melvin I represent ktoa yes repres
represent Phillips yes represent Davis
yes represent bruad yes represent kulan
y represent Kenny represent Penza yes
represent smart yes represent Bixby yes
represent dutsi yes represent Murray yes
represent Jam yes represent H Haskins I
represent Howard represent NAB yes
represent moris yes the vote is 180 do
we want this on consent we hear any
objection for being on consent no so yay
consent okay I will close out uh the
exec on HB 1386 and open up the exec for
HB
1376 um which is relative to prohibiting
certain packaging from carrying the
recycling logo do I hear a
motion uh I would like to move itl on
this bill do I hear a second yes I
second that motion Mr
Bixby so thank you representative kulan
would you like to speak to your motion
representative Bixby I would like to
speak to um so uh what this bill
proposed doing was um Banning the use of
the uh chasing arrows recycling label
for uh packaging that didn't meet
certain uh thresholds of recyc of
actually being recycled the notion was
that uh having the packaging saying it
could be
recycled that it was recyclable but it
not actually getting recycled was
deceptive and that uh that this would uh
remove that deception from the
marketplace uh and there are a couple of
problems with this one is that if you
don't have the numbers on the uh
packaging then even less will get
recycled uh and so because you need
those numbers to be able to do Source
separation of of the packaging uh the
other issue is that uh we in New
Hampshire don't actually have control
over the printing of those labels on the
packages and uh it would be uh pretty
much impossible to enforce so uh for
those reasons I suggesting we want an
itl okay representative Murray thank you
and I'd like to you know though though
the member um presenting the bill um was
well intended and I and I definitely
understand the frustration around um
recycling um and the complexities of it
we currently only in the state recycle
about 26% of our recyclables and I I too
share the same concerns that
representative bxs we had that perhaps
this would increase um or decrease our
Recycling and and in addition to um the
sort of um Federal sort of oversight
around recycling there's also an
international sort sort of recognition
of the chasing arrows and whether or not
um we were to REM remove that um I think
could also further complicate
things thank you I concur with what's
been
said is there any other discussion
representative German thank you madam
chair uh and I understand and the and
agree with the criticisms of the bill
the one thing I did want to say that I
think is UN that I think that the bill
would do and it's unfortunate that we
don't have another mechanism for it is
as representative Kaplan points out it
would provide the Attorney General with
another tool in the toolbox we worry
about enforcement and I agree with that
concern representative kaplan's argument
was that this is not something that the
attorney general has to act on right if
it exists in statute but it is uh a tool
uh that could be used and and uh
given the fact that this is I think a a
problem that needs in some way to be
addressed I regret that that isn't the
case that the Attorney General doesn't
have this kind of tool in order to try
to uh make sure the manufacturers are
actually being honest with consumers but
I also recognize the limitations of the
bill as uh as my colleagues have pointed
out thank you thank you for that any
other comments on this seeing none I
would ask the uh clerk to call the RO
for itl motion on hb1 137 six thank you
madam
chair Madam chair yes represent Melvin
yes represent coma yes represent
Phillips yes represent Davis yes
represent Brad yes represent kulan yes
represent Kenny yes represent Penza yes
represent smart represent Bixby yes
represent Duty yes represent Murray yes
represent Jama yes represent H Haskins I
represent Howard yes represent NAB yes
represent moris yes 180 do we want this
on consent do I hear any okay yeah
consent it is thank you and I will close
out uh the exec for HB
1376 um and then we can move along now
open up exec session for HB
1681 um which is uh relative to sell of
products labeled as biodegradable or
compostable do I hear motion represent
Bixby yes uh I'd like to move itl and
speak to my motion uh do I hear a second
I second that motion thank you
representative kulan go ahead
representative Bixby let's Okay so the
idea behind this bill is that uh there
are there there is packaging that is
sold uh primarily to restaurants that is
labeled as being compostable and uh not
all of it necessarily meets the
standards that would make it actually
compostable uh and uh but there are in
fact standards uh by uh put for for
forth bym which is a a standards um
promulgating uh body that uh that
actually do say these items with these
characteristics are uh are in fact
compostable and uh what this bill would
have done is require that uh anything
that was labeled as compostable be uh
have that third party um uh that third
party certification and that the initial
bill uh as written would have put it
into a uh a part of the solid waste
rules having to do with disposal but the
department pointed out that in fact the
correct place for that would would have
been in uh another set of in Commerce
statutes and uh so the prime sponsor
came into the committee with uh a
proposed amendment that would have put
it into the um into the Commerce
statutes and we looked into what it
would take in order for this committee
to uh amend the bill uh and we were told
by the clerk that uh any com any uh
amendment that we made that put the bill
into statutes over which our committee
doesn't have purview would be judged
non- gerain and uh so we were in fact
not able to make the necessary Amendment
to the bill uh and we have suggested to
the prime sponsor that uh he might be
able to find a uh someone on the
Commerce Committee who would be able to
append it to a bill there or perhaps do
that in the Senate uh we would have I I
personally would have really liked this
bill to go for forward uh I so I hope
that he's able to find uh a sponsor to
put it into the correct uh committee to
have it looked at but uh sadly we can't
do that in this committee so we have to
Ideal the
bill any further
discussion seeing none please clerk call
the role thank you madam chair it's an
itl motion on House Bill 1681 Madam
chair yes represent Melvin yes represent
coma yes representative Phillips yes
representative Davis represent bruad yes
represent kulan y represent Kenny
represent Penza yes represent smart
represent Bixby yes represent datsi yes
represent Murray yes represent Jama yes
represent H Haskins I represent Howard
yes represent NAB yes represent Morse
yes 180 shall this go on consent do I
see any okay consent it is then and I
will close out uh HB
1681 and I now open up the exec session
for HB
1687 do I hear a motion for that
representative Murray uh thank you madam
chair I'd like to bring forward an
amendment if I may you sure May okay I'd
like to present the committee with
Amendment
2024-25 n and
um so that's the motion I'm making does
everyone have a copy all
righty um and I would second that motion
thank you would you like to speak to
your motion I would Madam chair thank
you um so with respect to the amendment
the amendment seeks to just simply
enumerate um statutes under um RSA 147 B
Colin 2 uh sections uh seven and8 to
further enumerate um just so that we're
clear that hazardous waste is clearly
defined Ed and hazardous material is
clearly defined um going forward and the
rest of the the underlying Bill remains
uh
unaddressed thank
you okay any other comments regarding
this
amendment question representative
Penza just a question um during the
hearing these were the relevant statutes
that were missing out of there that we
wanted to make sure that they were in
correct so we're kind of covering our
bases now okay
yes and uh what we had heard from
um Department of administrative Services
is that this by doing this we will uh
improve um the RSA compliance for this
as we um require that it be included in
contracts so I think this is this is
really good legislation represent Murray
and thank you madam chair and just it is
State contract tracks so yep yep okay
thank you including the university
system as was pointed out okay any other
comment on this
amendment seeing none I'd like the clerk
to call the role this is to adopt
Amendment 2024
0759 Madam chair yes represent Melvin
yes represent ktoa yes represent
Phillips yes represent Davis represent
bruad yes represent kulan y represent
Kenny represent Penza yes represent
smart represent Bixby yes represent
dutsi yes representative Murray yes
represent Jam yes represent H Haskins I
represent Howard yes represent NAB yes
represent Morse yes 180 shall this go on
consent
oh I I'm rushing things do I hear do I
hear an otpa motion representative
Murray uh yes yes Madam chair I'd like
to make a motion of otpa with Amendment
2024-25 n and I gladly second would you
like to speak to your
Amendment no Madam chair I think we've
said everything okay anybody else have
anything to
add okay with uh that I would uh uh
request the clerk to call the role then
thank you madam chair this is an otpa on
hb1 1687 Madam chair yes represent
Melvin yes represent Toma yes represent
Phillips yes represent Davis represent
bruad yes represent kulan represent
Kenny represent
Penza yes represent smart represent
Bixby yes represent dsy yes represent
Murray yes represent Jam yes represent H
Haskins I represent Howard represent NAB
yes represent mois yes 180 would you
like this on consent yes any
okay yeah we're
good I'll close that out uh uh closing
out hb1 1687 and I will open up our
exact session on HB
1132 relative to permits for the
sighting of new landfills do I hear a
motion I like to make a motion Madam
chair representative rad go right ahead
uh motion
itl okay do I hear a second
representative Bixby seconds I will
second that oops representive brard
would you like to speak to your motion
yes so what this bill um was looking at
it was existing Brownfield sites in New
Hampshire and um trying to use those for
new
landfills while it does make sense you
know these sites are already
contaminated so let's let's use them
from landfills due to the proximity
location number of other factors
including new ruling uh it doesn't make
sense to do it right now and so uh
therefore
IO okay any other discussion on this
bill representative H Haskins thank you
madam chair I just wanted to say that I
thought it was very educational the
conversation that we had about
brownfields um I think that landfill
sighting is such an important issue for
us that we need to think long and hard
before we okay anything that's going in
say land and gravel for instance if the
brown fields are not acceptable there
are certainly other types of environment
that are not acceptable as well thank
you thank you representative H Haskins
and I I would like to add to that that I
agree even though there are you know 313
Brownfield sites in New Hampshire they
do seem in in looking at the list uh
very limited in their ability to be
repurposed as as landfill sites um but I
I I would hope that we someone on the
committee or someone else uh in our in
our
legislature um would come up with some
legislation that might uh
help point us to policy that would allow
us to promote brownfields to be used for
some other kind of useful purposes such
as recycling centers place to put solar
arrays or um you know that those kinds
of things so um I I I would hope to see
some kind of Bill come forward in the
future with that any other represent
Penza yeah I just wanted to you know
second what you said I I I think it was
um I think it was a great it was it was
a great hearing there was a lot of
things that were brought up and uh I'd
love to be able to use these sites I
don't think it's and there's probably
not many or even one that would be for
landfills but I think there's tons of
opportunities to be able to use these
properties for yeah transfer station
recycling station there's a lot of
different opportunities that I think
that we can use these and um and I'm
hoping that I can grab someone hey Nick
um to maybe put some legislation in next
time around all right then
representative Bixby yeah I I think a
lot of what I was going to touch on has
been said but I just wanted one of the
things that became clear in the hearing
was that uh the what the things that end
up making a Brownfield site a Brownfield
site are things that had to do with
industry in the past a lot of which was
industry which was in appropriately
placed close to waterways uh and one of
the things that we really need to focus
on when we're citing landfills is uh
making sure that the hydrogeology and
the geology uh of the site really
minimize the possibility of uh any uh
any leate material from the site uh
leaving uh and that site and it sounds
it sounded like uh few if any of the
Brownfield sites would have met that
criteria so we need to I think with
Landfield sighting we really need to say
what kind of a site do we need for a
landfill thank you
uh representative ger thank you madam
chair and one of the the questions that
I had during the hearing that I continue
to have um
is whether or not putting a landfill
even aside from some of the other
obvious problems with the current
Brownfield sites that we have one of my
concerns is related to what we're seeing
right now in Bethlehem and questions
about the existing landfill on top of an
old landfill you know what kind of
chemicals are we seeing going into the
amusic river is this the possibility of
a leak or is this because of material
that continues to degrade in the old
online landfill that was there and so
one of my concerns is that if we put uh
a landfill on top of a questionable site
how that potentially complicates
monitoring in the future and as I said
the current situation in Bethlehem seems
to be a good example of how it might
complicate our ability to discern the
difference between a leak and
uh some of the other chemicals that
remain in the surface from previous
use good thank you any other
discussion uh I see none so I would ask
the clerk to call the role thank you
madam chair this is an itl motion on
House Bill 1132 Madam chair yes
represent Melvin yes represent ktoa yes
represent Phillips yes represent Davis
yes represent Brad yes represent kou y
represent Kenny represent Penza yes
represent smart yes represent Bixby yes
represent Duty yes represent Murray yes
represent Jama yes represent H Haskins I
represent Howard yes represent NAB yes
represent mois yes 180 shall we put it
on consent seeing no objection um sure
put it on consent and I will close out
the exec session for HB
1132 I open up the exec session for HB
1170 which is requiring public benefit
and Community impact assessments from
the Department of Environmental Services
do I hear a motion representative Murray
uh thank you madam chair I'd like to
move interim study um to house bills 7
uh 1170 FN and I would second that would
you like to speak to your motion I would
Madam chair I think the uh the public uh
benefit conversation that we have um
that the uh sponsor had spoken to um
around uh host communities and abing
communities um is a worthy one that is
worthy of of further discussion and I
think there are some members within the
committee who seek to look at the the
conversation in a fuller manner around
Net public benefit as well as um how
this um how public benefit is actually
determined so I'd love to see that
further work
yes I concur with that I um I certainly
think you know we ought to be talking
about a more risk benefit analysis on
these things um my problem with the bill
as it was written was that the there
were mention of many different areas
that I find difficult to quantify or at
least they were not quantifiable in the
way they were written in this bill um
and and I I'm not sure what the
assessment would actually look like for
those particular things I mean I know
you can quantify Noise by decibel you
can quantify odor you can quantify how
many trucks or traffic is is in or out
but there are other kinds of um there
are other kinds of things about you know
what is potentially harmful impacts um
how would it affect tourism
that kind of thing there there's sort of
some
nebulous U measurements and and I think
it Bears some discussion further
discussion on those particular
items representative
Howard thank you um there also I think
that when you have public meetings you
um you tend to get repetitive um
messages from sort of the same people
attending all the time and I think it's
hard to quantify the broader Community
when um when you have just one segment
of it showing up at
meetings representative ger thank you
madam chair and as uh one of
the authors of the Amendments uh two
proposed amendments that we shared with
the committee from 1170 I certainly
support uh inter room study and I hope
the committee will too I I I would like
to draw to most of our discussions Have
Been Around the Net public benefit uh
which I think is would be a big step
forward but I just want to point out
that there are two other things that are
addressed in the Amendments that I hope
the study the uh pardon me the interim
study will also address one is uh the
idea that when addressing the issue of
net benefit a someone who's applying for
an applicant for a permit cannot offset
the benefits of one project against
another that that we are evaluating
individual projects and not saying well
you can actually discount things that
are happening in one Case by making a
case that something 60 mil or 100 miles
away offsets some of those some of those
issues so uh that is one issue and the
other is that we do have a very recent
Supreme Court ruling from December
regarding the question of capacity need
and uh one of the Amendments deals
specifically with that issue and says
that if you were going to apply for a
permit for one of these facilities you
need to be able to demonstrate that for
at least half of the lifetime of that
facility there is actual need um that as
I said addresses an issue which comes
out of that Supreme Court ruling so uh
and also uh along those same lines that
that when we permit new landfill
facilities it should be to meet need and
we should not be opening new facilities
uh before there is a demonstrated need
so I just uh wanted to to uh say that I
hope those are also issues that the
inter room study committee will take uh
the time to consider as part of future
legislation okay thank
you representative H Haskins thank you
madam chair rookie question so what time
frame does the interim study
get well in some committees an interim
study is a polite way of just killing a
bill but in this committee I do believe
that when we interim study something
that we it is a promise that we will
look at it and study it and so um I
would suspect that our um Solid Waste
subcommittee would um convene some time
in the
fall um and look at this bill and have
some discussions about it and perhaps
come up with um some kind of
future uh
legislative solution for the issue
representative Bixby so um we're
somewhat const strained by uh what this
what the well what the speaker uh wants
when the speaker is willing to let us
start working on it uh so if we have
finished all of our work uh by say the
beginning of May in this committee is
conceivable we could start working on an
interim study at that point if we get
permission from the speaker uh in some
years we have been able to work on
interim study bills in August uh that
was not the case last year that will
that's a question for the speaker we
have to have the report out I Believe by
November 1st so uh so uh if we don't
start working on it in uh May or June
then we would need to be working on it
in September and October and uh in
September and October thank you for that
clarification okay any other discussion
on uh the motion of interim study for
this bill seeing none I ask the clerk to
call the rooll thank you madam chair
this is an i interim study motion on
House Bill 1170 Madam chair yes
represent Melvin yes represent coma yes
represent Phillips yes represent Davis
yes represent Brad yes represent kulon
yes represent Kenny represent Penza yes
represent smart represent Bixby yes
represent Duty represent Murray yes
represent Jama yes represent hkin
hi repr Howard yes represent NAB yes
represent Mor moris 180 CH want consent
any um excuse me uh anybody disagree
with it going on consent seeing none
make it so and I will close out HP
1170 and I will open up HB
1620 relative to suspending the issuance
of new landfill permits until
2031 do I hear a
motion go ahead represent I didn't I
didn't hear myself recognized so I was
waiting to be um I recognize you okay
thank you very much Madam chair uh I
would like to present a motion to the a
uh a motion to adopt an amendment thank
you
to the committee and I'll circulate
it here uh this is based on discussions
which we had uh in committee during the
work session this amendment would have
the uh the pause on landfill permits go
to 2028 as opposed to 2031 which was in
the original Bill and i' I'd be happy to
speak to
the
amendment
representative vix be
second um representative ger would you
like to speak to your motion yes thank
you madam chair so uh this is a
compromise 2028 is a compromise 20131
was in the original Bill there was some
discussion about whether or not 2031 was
an arbitrary date it was not as the as
the prime sponsor pointed out the first
potential uh capacity need that we would
have is 2034 so 2031 was chosen to give
us three years ahead of the uh of that
time where we might actually potentially
have some capacity issues uh if it takes
us six to 10 years potentially to permit
right six years puts us out at at
2030 uh which is a date that that also
makes sense to me but given where we
were 2031 some folks mentioned 2027 I
think that 2028 is a good compromise
I've spoken with the the prime sponsor
this is a bill that he submitted
specifically to address the concerns of
his
constituents uh and he is is willing to
uh to compromise as as we have been he's
really concerned if we compromise even
further and go to
2027 so I would like to see us
recognizing the needs of the
representatives constituents on whose
behalf he brought that bill um I would
like to see us go with 2028 as a
compromise on the date when the
moratorium would end okay thank
you well um I appreciate that um
Amendment
um I gave it some thought over the
weekend and I know we battered around
2028 2027 I feel more comfortable with a
2027 date simply because
you know I know we're
making um some policy changes and Dees
is working through um rule updates and I
think with also some of the other policy
changes there will be some some new rule
updates that will be um implemented too
and I think that you know giving it
until 2027 for for all the dust to
settle
um is is more I don't know I feel more
comfortable with that date as opposed to
waiting yet one more year for um for
this pause I do believe we should have a
pause but I don't know that I want to um
to wait a full four years I I would be
more comfortable with uh 2027 as being
the date representative Bixby yeah so
um one of the one of the uh pieces of
commentary we got in our email was a uh
a letter from the
Society for protection of New Hampshire
forests and they were strongly in
support of this bill actually with the
original 3030 2031 uh date uh and I
think that uh what they uh talked about
was the importance of making sure that
we don't site a landfill where uh
basically any any landfill sighting is
going to be a permanent sighting uh so
uh they uh felt that an abundance of
caution was really necessary in terms of
making those sighting decisions and felt
that uh by uh pushing it out 20 to 2031
it would in fact uh provide us the
capacity to really uh establish the
criteria as as well as possible and um I
recognize that there are that it could
be problematic to push it all the way
out to 2021 I think that 2028 is the
best uh uh date to to uh so 2028 is the
best date to uh meet what uh we we are
hearing from the our constituents in the
North country and also from the for
society repr presum Howard thank you
madam chair um two things I you know
2027 is like two and a half years from
now or by the time the bill goes into
effect it'll be only two and a half
years and I think that's insufficient
especially given that um when our bill
that had a moratorium attached um failed
there a permit was was an application
went in for a permit in between that's
now in the direct the doj because we
don't know if it'll go under the old
rules or the new rules and I think we
need sufficient time to to make these
criteria
sound representative H Haskins thank you
madam chair I've thought a lot about
this I am more comfortable with 31 I
can't support 27 I can't support 28
there are um Maneuvers going on right
now as we sit here and I am thinking
about our
constituents who need to be apprised of
what's going on and need time to respond
to both Dees and the applicant so um
reluctantly I'm afraid I can't support
either 27 or 28 okay representative K
thank you Madam chair um I too support
uh
2027 and the reasons for this is
because Dees is coming out with a whole
set of rules this year this
summer we're going to get to look at
them we're going to get to examine
them the people that are applying for
permits will get to understand what the
new guidelines
are we'll get to a assess things that
we've been talking about in this
committee over the next legislative
cycle and the thing is is in
2026 if we feel that things aren't going
the way they should there can always be
another bill put
in so I believe the
2027 would be the best year to put in
knowing that there are a lot of changes
happening and the rules are
changing immensely from what I
understand and how sightings are going
to be
done and I think we need to give Dees a
chance also to look at
this and understand and other people but
if we keep put because now with the new
rules we don't know if sighting is going
to happen in three years or four years
or five years it could take longer we
don't know what's going to happen to
when the rules come out so I support
2027 representative
Howard um when we again that bill that
failed we um kic we sort of kicked a can
down the road with this idea that that
DS was Dees was making new rules um and
and in the interim between when when we
the bill failed and the new rules come
out a permit has been put in and I just
think that kicking it down the road is
is is danger because because there is a
very
aggressive um pursuit of of
sites uh thank you for that and you know
I I am also uh wanting to see what
happens with this permit that's already
being considered because apparently you
know we're still waiting to hear from
the doj about how any of these new rules
or policies are going to affect that
permit at all and um I I think we need
to have a
pause uh to see how that um how that's
going to work out so um representative
NAB thank you madam chair um I would
tend to agree with representative
Hoskins you know I like things to be
based on fact the fact is we've been
told through numerous studies and
research that we will not need a new
landfill until uh
2034 um so I think 2031 was already a
compromise at the same time I respect
this committee's um desire to be to work
together and to compromise and so I'm
willing to support the 2028
Amendment uh thank you okay representa
dsy thank you madam chair uh yeah for
every action there's an opposite and
equal reaction which I understand is a
law of physics so if we put pressure on
um uh not putting in new landfills that
provides Ides pressure on us for Source
reduction and even though we've
considered more bills this year for for
epr I sense that there's a lot of
resistance um on the part of industry
and on the part of politicians uh to
really move forward with Source
reduction which is where we need to be
so uh like representative NAB I would
like to see um uh 20 uh 31 but in the um
uh preference for uh coming to a
consensus I could agree to
[Music]
2028 representative H Haskins thank you
madam chair I hope I respect
collegiality as well as anyone at the
table and I would agree with
representative Conta if the applicant
didn't have a permit that's currently
being reviewed at the same time as Dees
is writing the rule it never made sense
to me I've said this before so the
longer we can have this pause Dees can
attend itself to the ru making and after
that time we can consider whether we
need a landfill at
all representative Murray um thank you
madam chair um I am um also eager to
support uh 2028 for actually for the
reason that um representative H Haskins
actually mentioned it's quite possible
that the doj ruling could take some time
and um to that end uh you know I want to
make sure that we are you know providing
a compromise between 2031 and 20 you
know 27 I think is is too early I so I
would I would prefer to see 2028 in the
interest of um you know not being really
sure when we would receive an answer
okay represent ger thank you madam chair
and I also want to be clear that the the
original bill was in a sense a
compromise because it was 2031 again the
three years before we might need
capacity it was also a compromise in the
sense that it doesn't put a hold on the
current permitting process frankly I I
think that a moratorium should have a
hold on the current permitting process
uh precisely because of points that
representative has Haskins made uh there
is an inherent problem with Dees uh just
the process of writing rules while they
are currently considering a permit um so
so uh the bill is also a compromise in
that respect and I would like to
personally see it strengthened but again
in the spirit of compromise that's not
something I'm going to to um to try to
introduce into the process at this
point it's important when we think about
where we might be going with the current
draft one of the other things that I'm
cognizant of is having only a three days
or so to kind of very briefly look at
the most recent draft of the dees
landfill sightings there's further
weakening of Standards based upon even
the draft that we had in January which
had weakening of Standards from October
that does not give me a lot of
confidence that we're headed in the
right direction um so uh I would
actually like to see this stronger I
think 2028 is already a real compromise
on the part of people who would like a
much more robust Bill uh and for those
reasons uh I willing to accept 2028 but
I will not vote for
2027 thank you representative
Penza so I agree with everything that
representative ger just said um I think
what bothers me the most is on the
current permit application that is at
Dees it says the earliest that they can
open is
2028 and there's not a new landfill
needed in 2034 let's be clear about all
that that is maybe when there could
could be a capacity issue which in
Rochester they haven't even put a permit
in to expand 50 acres so with all of
these things I'm all for 2031 I'll I
thought we all as a committee decided
that we were going to do 2028 um I think
something that also bothers me a lot is
there's been no action for like 19
years and and I thought you know I would
have been fine with what it was which
was like a six and a half year pause uh
because that's what it is and so you
know in getting this three and a half
year if it's better it's better than
nothing I'll I'll go for that but I I I
think it should be 2028 and don't look
at any don't look at any permits at all
focus on you know focus on rewriting the
rules and let's and let's make up some
for some L time because there's been a
there's been a lot of failing that's
gone on and uh that's where I'm
at okay thank you for that any other
comment so in in listening to all this
really good um reasoning going
on I will in fact be supporting 2028 as
the date so um with no other discussion
I would have the clerk call the role
thank you madam chair where the motion
is to adopt Amendment 202
4738 Madam chair yes represent Melvin
yes represent coma no representative
Phillips yes represent Davis yes
represent bruad no represent kulon yes
represent Kenny yes represent Penza yes
represent smart yes represent Bixby yes
represent Duty yes represent Murray yes
represent jamana yes represent H Haskins
yes represent Howard yes represent NAB
yes repres M mois yes 162 the motion
passes can it go on consent any
objection for it to go on
consent oh oh that's the adoption oh of
the amendment I'm sorry oh yeah forget
forget where I
am my my apologies okay so that's for
the amendment 162 um do I hear a motion
for
otpa representative ger uh thank you
madam chair I will move o TPA on hb1
1620 okay representative Bixby second
that representative ger would you like
to speak to your motion no thank you
madam chair I think we've exhausted the
issue any any other discussion seeing
none I'll have the uh clerk call the
rooll thank you madam chair uh otpa
motion on hp1 1620 Madam chair yes
representative Melvin yes representative
comtois yes yes representative Phillips
yes representative Davis yes represent
bruad yes represent kulan yes represent
Kenny represent Penza yes represent
smart represent Bixby yes represent Duty
yes represent Murray yes represent Jama
yes represent H Haskins yes represent
Howard represent NAB yes represent mois
yes 180 shall It Go on consent
yes okay okay great uh it goes on
consent thank you everybody I'm going to
close this out uh HB
1620 and I want to thank um this
committee for all this great work um
thank you and being able to listen to
one another and being able to work
together um I close out the exec uh
session for this morning and since we
have a good 10 minutes before we have
our um
work session I would invite um The
Honorable Tera sad and honorable Bob
Hafner up and to speak to us about uh
council state governments and give us an
update and let us
know how you guys are doing and how
we're
doing well after what we just saw you're
doing pretty well congratulations
everyone you're upholding the um
um Legacy of the environment and
agriculture committee and and thank you
very much um I think all of you know us
we were here last year um we sat in
these
seats eight years ago eight years ago we
were we started in 2006 yep yeah we
started at the same time um he's a
republican I'm a Democrat and so when
the Democrats were in the majority I was
chair and he was ranking member M and
then the next year when the Republicans
became in the majority we just switched
seats and we've been working together
ever since we're sharing a job at
Council of state governments Eastern
region um does everyone know what
council of state governments is it's a
greater organization and we are here to
serve you you are our members the state
pays dues to us in exchange for which we
give you research we give you
introductions to your compatriots and
colleagues in other states in the 11
state region in the Northeast so if you
need to know what Vermont is doing on a
landfill bill we can put you in touch
with the chair of the committee over
there and he can um tell you what's
going on there so it it's a valuable
resource it it is one of the most
important things I think we do
is the
network uh often you will come up with a
an issue here that you have to work and
you'll say you know I remember down in
Connecticut they had that same problem
let me call Kevin and see what they did
exactly so that's the main thing and
that's what we love so much about it we
have conferences we have policy Summits
we have webinars we have meetings we
have state house visits and we introduce
people to to their friends and hopefully
friends um when Bob and I used to go to
the conferences back when we sat in your
seat and we met so many people who are
still our dear friends and you know it's
a it's
wonderful so um we have annual meeting
coming up in Baltimore Maryland it's
going to be July 28 through the
31st sounds is that yeah sounds yeah and
this time we're going to be talking
about rural areas rural towns what makes
some of them vibrant and what makes some
fail the brain drain the young people
leaving towns and not coming back um and
how to stop it so we have some wonderful
wonderful speakers talking about what
towns can do to stop the drain and um
it's going to be
exciting and um this April at the end of
April we're going to be having a policy
Summit with the energy and environment
Committee of CSG on
past um especially we're involved as the
AG people because of the biosolids of
course and the amount of interest in
this subject is incredible last summer
at our annual meeting we had a whole
session on that and it was standing room
only and they all insisted on having
this policy Summit so it's going to be
really interesting if anybody is
interested let us know this is going to
be in Providence Rhode Island and it's
going to be the last Thursday and Friday
in April yes um it's going to be really
good so let us know how we can help you
get there which we can um what else is
going on have a dinner tonight dinner
tonight yes exactly Common Man six
o'clock yeah right did you all get the
invitation I think it was invitation
only but there's room okay yes there
there is room but the initial one out
to people that were appointed or who had
been to our educational
seminar now the annual meeting I know
when we went because we all make made
$100 a year which you still do because
it's in the Constitution um anyway um
that doesn't leave much for actually
going to conferences and paying
registration fees and transportation and
all that stuff um so let us know if you
need assistance with that right so get
in touch with us I'm gonna pass out my
business card so that you see it and and
the speaker and Senate President do in
fact budget money for people to go to
conferences they never tell you about
that they they don't tell you and if
there's a lot of demand they'll run out
of money at some point but uh I only had
one time that I was going to a
conference and it didn't get paid for
right so it's it's a valuable valuable
tool that you have to actually get some
education out there and it makes a
complete difference to your attitude
about your work in the house if you see
it from a broader perspective it really
is quite good and our annual meeting uh
although we're going to do a a couple of
different workshops for
environment for agriculture and um uh
rural Affairs uh you are welcome to go
to any committee that you would like if
you want to go to Military and Veterans
Affairs we have a new housing Comm
committee which is fascinating we have a
energy and environment Committee of
course health education so any of your
interests are going to be touched upon
there and this one will be in
Baltimore uh
Maryland seven or eight years ago also
hosted the annual meeting and they did a
fabulous job it was so wonderful
fireworks and crabs
yes yeah yeah huge crab dinner for you
know 400 people attending it was
wonderful it was wonderful anyway so
we're planning on doing that but the one
thing about Ena I mean our um
Agriculture and Rural Affairs committee
I still call it D is that we do the best
um visits um offside tour during the
annual meeting so we travel all over and
we have fun and um we go to see Wineries
and farms and labs and things like that
so it's it's always great get on the bus
and talk to people and and we've got the
May marn secretary of agriculture
picking out the tour for this year yeah
and he's going to be on the bus talking
to us too so it'll be fun well wonderful
well thank you so much for coming and
visiting us and
uh uh and filling Us in on some CSG
updates appreciate it if you we're going
to be here tomorrow also just because we
can't stay away and we're here on our
state house visit but um we're going to
be treating everybody to lunch tomorrow
so we'll you be getting a card for the
cafeteria to go down well thank you very
much we appreciate that good and you're
going to pass out your cards I'm going
to get it right now okay yeah thank you
wonderful thank
you okay
um let's
see so now uh we've got one minute if
anybody needs to use restroom before we
start our work
session yes I never say no to that
question no you
don't yeah sure
absolutely yeah well I didn't know
either absolutely and I want to thank uh
representative
Phillips and um representative Melvin
for joining us and filling in and U
being our our substitutes we appreciate
it no but we'll be let know you have to
you don't you can if you'd like but it's
not
necess I
know no we are we're here
from
I'd like everybody to take their seats
please I'm the clerk
yeah
okay um what are we
doing 21 is first
yeah
okay okay
everybody is ready and settled we have a
full committee work session on we're
going to discuss three bills that we
heard last time we convened and the
first one um we will talk about HB 1221
I want kind of want to get a sense of
where everybody is on these bills
representative Bixby I need you to get
your get to your seat thank you no it's
okay um
hp1 1221 relative to including Solid
Waste landfills in the definition of
development of regional
impact and I know we had um quite a lot
of good discussion and testimony on this
um there were some concerns about
um um the parts of the bill that talk
about um who should be noticed or who
should be included in uh discussions of
regional
impact um there was the discussion about
20 miles that was an arbitrary number um
was it a radius did it include
Downstream there were a whole lot of
questions about this um this bill um we
we all understand though that
notification um with the goal of
transparency in mind um people who live
within a
certain
area where uh a significant project uh
specifically Solid Waste landfill is
going to be cited or
permitted is something that um we feel
that there should be many voices
included in the
discussions
and um I'll just leave it at that and
see uh how how people feel about this
representative
NAB um thank you madam chair
um so a couple of things I do think we
needed an amendment to clarify what um
what sorry I'm blanking on the word not
the groundwater subdivisions but the
um there was a map reference that Dees
has as to the
word I'm totally blanking on the word
water shs the water sheds thank you um
and I and I agree with thinking a little
bit about the 20 M radius um I just
wanted to say as someone who sits on a
select board and has done Regional
notifications that it is something
that's really helpful to a town to make
something a regional study and to get
input from other towns so I just want
people to recognize it's not an onerous
thing for a town to have to declare
something um a development of regional
significance because it's very helpful
as a town to start getting input from
other towns as to the impacts that
they're going to see so I I do support
this bill um I do think that we could
clarify a little bit of the language
around what qualifies as a notifying
area thanks I do know that in uh line
six of this
bill there was an incorrect RSA number
that was referenced it references 33
colon
56 and as I understand from testimony
but I think I need to verify it should
be 36 colon
55 um and that I that's still something
I think we need to look look at and
um yeah I mean you know I I agree we we
I know folks from Dees had mentioned
that we need to Define more clearly the
extent of the Watershed that we would be
talking about and um yeah we did see the
map The Watershed map um but some of the
watersheds are pretty extensive and I
don't know if we want to
include that extensive of amount of area
in terms of notifications I think that
bears some discussion representative
kma thank you madam chair um one of the
other things was is that the way the
bill is written we would have to notify
people in other states um and I think
that would be honorous on us um I
understand there may be an impact to
them however what we need to be
concerned about when we're doing things
is our New Hampshire citizens and I
think uh the focus should be on New
Hampshire and not the other
states okay any other comment
representative
viby yeah I think that um this is this
would be very valuable to get into place
um and I but I agree in terms of needing
to put in uh a clearer definition of
what the Watershed is uh and I think
that that map that was presented uh
provides us with a if we can find out
what um what RSA that map or or uh is
located in or is referenced by then uh
have that having that as as part of the
um as as part of the definition in the
bill I think would be um would be
important I also think that you know 20
miles is probably excessive I mean from
going from TurnKey to Candy I mean my
thought I think that's a my my just my
geographical sense well is that really
only 20 miles but uh at the same time
you know it may be as the crow flies
because you know you can't drive
straight from can't get there from here
from Rochester to Candy so um so I I
think perhaps uh reducing that to
somewhere in the the 10 to 15 mile range
might make sense agree uh and uh and I C
we can certainly you know make sure that
the reference in in paragraph 2 is is
correct but uh I think that this is a
bill that would not be terribly
challenging to uh to amend in time to uh
to to execute fairly
soon well I know um I guess I also
wanted to uh touch on representative K's
point about uh do we really need to be
notice noticing uh U people in other
states and I think that because the
issue is that we
are looking at uh making you know policy
that we're making in the state of New
Hampshire that what's really important
is the no notification within New
Hampshire I agree with those points and
I just want to make it um clear that um
we would not probably be executing this
bill until March 5th because we have
school vacation week next week um so we
have plenty of time to work on any kind
of amendments for bills that we're
hearing um that we've already
heard um and possibly bills that we're
going to hear today or tomorrow so um I
just wanted to bring that to everybody's
attention that we do have some time um
in working on some of these uh bills
that are coming before US Representative
ger uh thank you madam chair and I just
wanted to say as one of the co-sponsors
and I worked with the prime sponsor or
discussed this with the prime sponsor
the point was to kind of get some some
basic principles in place uh and I think
a lot of the feedback from the committee
is makes perfect sense I'd be happy to
work on an an amendment uh to help us
more closely Define uh our terms and and
get a handle on what the appropriate
distance would be and how that distance
is uh measured but uh I'm I'm glad to to
see that there is Broad support for the
B basic principles which is what the
bill was designed to do so thank
you well we always like volunteers to
work on
amendments anybody else have any
comments representative Howard thank you
um I I remember I I I'm not sure if I'm
remembering correctly but um that when
the when Dees was shown that Watershed
map they they had some question it was
sort of they didn't seem to approve of
it or think that it was entirely would
serve our purpose is exactly so um I I
hope that when we do that if that's not
the map that we do track down one that
they agree
with representative Bixby you had
mentioned
um the uh Watershed map do you know if
it is referenced anywhere in
rsas I I don't actually know that you
don't know I was just kind of hoping I
wonder if our committee researcher can
check and see whether the um the that
map that Watershed map that Dees
provided with us is referenced anywhere
in our
rsas okay representative Murray um thank
you madam chair um to that end I I would
uh also note that on de's website there
are several Watershed maps and not just
um so there are many Watershed districts
so I just wanted to also make folks
aware of like there there may be a whole
state one but there is also there are
also ones that are broken out into
regions ah
okay uh do we need any kind of
clarification from Dees about um those
particular maps and how they're used
represent Bixby yeah I I think that that
would be probably an appropriate job for
whoever volunteers to take this on
okay all right
um now I do know that there was some
testimony that
said
um there they would be happy if we
grandfathered existing and
expansions into whatever notification
procedures or
transparency procedures that we kind of
land on um how what are what are our
thoughts on
that anyone representative Howard I
wonder if expansion isn't the equivalent
of a new um a new application kind of
thing so that it would require that same
sort of alerting the community the the
the impact and
stuff well I guess you know we
already I think I guess the thought is
that we already have that
those sites in place and in operation
and the impacts are already known for
those so that I mean that was the
argument is that we wouldn't necessarily
need to have them um put out any kind of
big notification about that I I don't
know thoughts represent duy you look
like you want to say
[Laughter]
something no I I I I was just thinking
about the land sight the the land uh
fill sites that we have now um I believe
I I mean I would agree with you that
maybe grandfathering them in because
they already are a a site and they are
my understanding I mean of course we
have a municipal one but I mean you know
there is oversight on it in terms of the
expansion um I think with with the local
boards and and with uh Dees I know they
went through a long uh permitting
process to open up another part of the
of the landfill um so I would be
comfortable with grandfathering it in
okay good to
know
um yeah representative Bixby yeah I
actually um I'm not sure that it makes
sense to grandfathering expansions
because uh essentially this is this is
about any permit that is going to have
some effect on the surrounding
communities and uh and I I think that as
as a you know as a resident of do I
happen to already be in the notification
zone for TurnKey but I I I do want to be
in you know if there's an expansion
going on uh or if there's a uh at
TurnKey I would like uh my constituents
to be notified that that's that that's
happening and I think that would be also
appropriate for and notification does
not give anything like veto power it is
simply here's this this meting meting is
going to happen and so please be aware
of it and if you want to come and and
comment then please do and that's that's
what that's the level of discussion
we're talking about right right
representative
ktoa thank you madam
chair so when we were listening to this
apparently and maybe I'm wrong but I
understood that notifications are
already going out into the major
newspapers and in the local papers also
so the notification process is already
being done um unless we're requiring
them to send certified letters to every
single residents within that radius I
believe that the not notification
process is already being
met okay representative NAB I think they
were just speaking to notifying the a
Butters not is that that's what they
were talking about as notifying a
Butters that's done in the newspaper
represent have
com thank you madam chair but I believe
when they are notifying about hearings
and maybe Dees could uh answer this
question for us um is that they have to
put something in the papers uh regarding
any of the meetings um could someone
from yeah I invite someone from
um Michael
L yeah hold on one
second so could you describe more
clearly what exactly is required in
terms of notification for uh seeking um
new permit for landfill or expansion
sure uh thank you for the opportunity my
name is Michael norc with the New
Hampshire Dees Solid Waste Management
Bureau
um basically uh there's the state
process which is governs the permit that
the state would issue through Dees and
and for that process there is a
notification requirement um the
applicant would have to notify uh a
Butters so property owners that are
abutting the uh proposed landfill parcel
how did I do that with certified letter
do they yeah yeah so using certified
letters they need to have a return
receipt uh confirming that the uh
abutter had received the notification
and they include that in their
application to
Dees um they also have to to uh put uh
notification in a in a public newspaper
of General
circulation um that would uh you know
kind of cover folks that aren't
necessarily abutters but uh are in the
general area that might be interested to
to learn of the application and the
opportunity for public hearing because
as Dees uh as part of our process for
issuing a permit for a landfill hearings
are a requirement um so so there is an
opportunity for the general public to
attend those hearings and and offer
input
um I think those are the two main
requirements governing the state
permitting process but just to clarify
again I think I mentioned this in the
hearing this bill is governing the local
approval uh and the so the the local
land use board or planning board uh
would have a hearing for an application
that they Reed potentially for the same
project but it again would be for that
local uh approval process um so I think
the the the uh intention here was to
allow for input into that local planning
process from broader communities that
might be affected to allow them to
participate in the hearing that the
local land use board might
have yeah representative kto thank you
madam chair um now if they're already
putting
in the the notice and they're notifying
the abuts so anyone from any of the
towns could already come to those
hearings or those local boards and
express their concerns is that correct
I'm sorry I'm not sure if I'm following
what you're asking are you asking about
the state permitting process no um you
said that the permittee had to also put
something about hearings and their
intent to do something in the paper and
hold a public hearing is that correct
that that when I was describing the the
new the newspaper notification that was
uh a requirement of our rules relative
to the permitting process so an
applicant for State permit for a
landfill has to publish a notification
in the in the general you know
circulation so it could be the union
leader could be uh SE Coast uh whatever
the paper might be but that would be
notification of the hearing for d d
basically Dees the that the hearing that
we host for a permit application for the
state permit I don't I don't know if
that ansers your question but I'm trying
to just clarify there's a dichotomy here
represent muray thank you madam chair I
also um to representative bixby's Point
um just something I've been chewing on
is around um vertical expansion within a
footprint versus horizontal or
circumferential expansion and so that's
just something I've been thinking about
um and to to representative bi spe Point
whether or not that should be um
grandfathered or not so I just want to
make that
mention that's something we should
consider you know representative H
Haskins thank you madam chair um and
thank you for taking my question I'm
trying to follow what happens when the
public comes to comment so you host a
meeting you
said correct we host a meeting uh or a
hearing rather
for input onto the state permitting
process which is different than what
this bill is about just because you
brought that up I'm curious what happens
to that public
comment is it part of the permanent
record does
it yes factor into your consideration of
the permit yeah we are required to take
comments at a public hearing um those
comments do become part of the public
record and they are kind
of part of the record that we retain
relative to the application process for
that permit um typically Dees will also
take written comments after the public
hearing so we'll have a certain period
of time where we allow interested
parties to write their comments and
submit them to Dees um and we usually
compile all of those written comments
into one kind of repository or or a
record uh and then we issue usually we
issue a response to the comments that we
received notifying folks of and we we
won't respond to each individual comment
but we'll usually try to group them
together just for efficiency to cover
the main themes of folks concerns and if
there are concerns that were raised that
aren't necessarily within our purview we
will note that um but if there are
concerns that are within our prview we
will um definitely consider that in the
decision- making and the uh issuance of
a permit or denial of a permit thank you
okay representing Bixby and then I'll
get to you yeah so um so just to to make
it a little bit clearer what we're doing
with this bill and what we hope to do
with the bill um so this is let I'm just
going to use an example let's say that
there is uh some project that is
happening at the turnkey landfill in
Rochester that uh the uh land use board
in Rochester wants to have some uh
control over because TurnKey is in land
is in Rochester
currently uh I I believe that uh that
people that uh a notice would go out to
uh public notice would go out in
Rochester the way that they publicly
noticed their meetings for uh Rochester
residents and I believe that they would
also
because uh Dober and barington are right
next door that the uh that that notice
would be sent to the um do Dover City
management and to the barington town
management who who would then be able to
notice it to their um to their residents
but that notice would not go to Madbury
because it is not right next to
Rochester uh but it is in the Watershed
so um so under this bill uh the notice
would also go to the town of Madbury and
to the town of of um uh and and to other
other towns that are in that water in
the Watershed and I I don't have a
watershed map in my head and probably
the town of R the town of Rollinsford uh
so that uh and then those towns would
then uh provide notice to their
residents so it wouldn't be it wouldn't
be like you know TurnKey would have to
give a certified male you know return
mail re uh to to every resident of every
town in in in the in the surrounding
area it would be that the town
governments would be notified and then
they would notify their their cons their
residents in the way that they usually
notify about
meetings representative
Penza so in Rochester with TurnKey um
most people they they really don't know
what's going on it's just like that so
you know this is a total separate thing
than what the state does with permit and
all that
um I like this bill for a lot of reasons
just because better communication is
better than no communication and so
right now in Rochester you have you have
one paper which is The Fosters but you
have to pay and most people don't pay
for that it's an online paper and so um
and it's it's cutting out a whole
percentage of people that don't read
their newspaper online and then the
other one is Rochester voice which
doesn't have a lot of visibility so I
would love there to be um you know
public notice that could be put to um
Boards of Selectmen and and city
councilors in in their town halls in our
city Halls you get do and summersworth
and in Rochester of course um you've got
very close about Butters Bearington that
are right there so you know I think the
more people that um are able to kind of
know what's going on I was at a meeting
for example uh last Saturday and uh we
spent 20 minutes and uh they started
talking about the landfill well I'm like
lo and behold I'm on environment and
agriculture so I know some stuff about
this but if I wasn't they you know and
and of course there's P people that are
very close to where the landfill is
asking about what's going on with the
smell and all that kind of stuff it
would be so wonderful cuz Waste
Management's been really good I mean
they're working very hard on a on a
really huge problem that we're facing
but because people don't have the
information they're pretty angry they're
like what's going on what's going on so
you know even if it was like the union
leader you know that's not necessarily
something that going through a paper
that they're going to get so I don't
know what the best possible way to to
get information out to um folks you know
more than just a Butters but it's I
don't know this this this is just
another another way we can try to to
handle it but I'm sure you hear this
stuff all the time right don't you about
notifications and people not getting
that kind of information no no I didn't
know there was a public
hearing um yeah I mean there's there's
always we could always you know do other
things try to reach people in fact thees
goes over and above and tries to post it
on our social media we try to post it on
our website so there are things that we
do that are over and above our
requirements just to try to cover the
situations you're talking about where
folks may not be reading the newspaper
or uh really paying attention to some of
these other venues where information is
being circulated so um yeah we do we do
try to to get the information out as
best we can and we thank you for
that y representative H Haskins just a
quick question is the applicant required
to come to these
meetings yes
um I because I was that wasn't always
the
case Okay um I I can't say for certain
that there's a requirement in our rules
uh that's not again this is not my area
of specialty but in terms of the
permitting of a facility um and the
process thereof but as far as I know
every permitted uh landfill in the state
that we've had re you know issues
expansions or or permits for the permit
or uh somebody representing the permit
has been there to present at those
public
hearings okay representa Murray thank
you madam chair I think um going back to
my point I I wonder if it is fruitful
for whoever is working on an amendment
to consider perhaps working with the
department and identifying first how
many um Watershed districts there are
and if you know how many there are off
hand right now that's helpful but if not
um aligning that sort of notification
like representative Bixby was suggesting
perhaps to New Hampshire Watershed
districts not necessarily uh I'm I'm
wondering if that's a
fruitful discussion represent vix yeah
um I'm noticing the clock and we've been
talking about this one for about half an
hour and we have a couple more to go Y
and I believe that repres representative
gerana said he would be willing to work
on an amendment okay so I think maybe we
should hand this over to his capable
hands now uh I
concur thank you thank you Mr norc
appreciate your
time okay um so then we can move along
to HB 1145 prohibiting the private
ownership of
landfills and I think that kind of goes
in hand inand with hb1 1632 relative to
out ofate solid waste one seeks to um
well they both seek to um reduce the
amount of outstate
trash uh being deposited into our
landfills
um and they're kind of both seeking a
way around the Commerce Clause of the
Constitution US
Constitution um so I'd like to invite
discussion about um 11 45 and see maybe
that will kind of dovetail into hp1 1632
as well representative
ger thank you madam chair I I support in
in the end I don't think these bills
have to conflict uh with each other I
think they as The Madam chair points out
we're there are two different ways of
trying to get at the underlying problem
um I think we can all agree there's been
a lot of of press coverage of of the
fact that we take about you know 50% of
what's it's a little less than that in
the last report but between 45 and 50%
of what we put in our landfills comes
from out of state and I think that our
constituents across the state have made
it very clear that that's not acceptable
so then the question is what's the best
remedy for that
1145 uh I see the particular virtue of
public owned
landfills uh and I understand there were
a lot of really good questions that came
up in the in the hearing is that allows
us to do three things simultaneously
right one is to cap the amount of out
ofate waste that we take but the other
two things it allows us to do which I
think are important number one it allows
us to discriminate with regard to the
kinds of waste we take from out of state
if it's a privately owned landfill uh
the uh
1632 doesn't address that right we could
take 15% out of state waste but we are
still taking mattresses and rugs and
other past Laden uh materials now
fortunately we would be taking less of
it because we're capping it but uh if
it's a publicly owned landfill then we
can say there are certain things that
we're simply not going to take uh and
then the other virtue I think of
1145 is that it allows us to charge
differential rates between trash we take
from out of state and uh and and um what
people pay in in New Hampshire to
dispose of their waste and I think
that's important because I understand as
as some members brought up that you are
the reality is that uh folks who are in
this business are going to be making
less profits because of less outof State
waste coming in the ability to charge
more for outof State waste is going to
offset some of that uh there's no way to
get around the fact that if we reduce
the amount of outstate waste that we are
bringing in that that is going to have
an impact on the folks that are that are
in that business but the the companies
who work in this field work in lots of
different states with lots of different
conditions some of which actually almost
all of which are more are stricter than
ours so these are not conditions that
they're unfamiliar with these are not
conditions that their business models
are not designed to uh to work with and
our first priority is to our
constituents and that is to reduce that
waste but allowing for a different rate
to be charged to out ofate waste there
is at least the opportunity to offset
some of the revenue that they are law
that they are losing if we cap out of
state waste so I mean I'd be fine in the
end if we if we did
1632 uh but I I think that 1145 actually
gives us more bang for our buck uh and
is more uh does more for the people of
the
state thank
you represent
Bixby so so um a couple of things uh
about um 1145 one one is that uh the
topic in the came up in the hearing of
would it be possible to use eminent do
domain to uh for the state to purchase
land uh and I'm not sure what the
current eminent domain restrictions are
I know that they are tighter than they
used to be because I voted for a bill
that tightened them but I don't remember
the details but I I would be happy to
put an amendment on this bill saying
that uh eminent domain shall not be used
to acquire land for a state-owned
landfill uh and the other thing is that
um one of the things we don't know is
how these bills are going to be received
by the Senate and which one it's
possible the Senate might prefer one to
the other uh we can't uh make that uh
determination in advance I think we want
to give them uh both of the both options
so that uh they can uh continue our work
on trying to reduce out ofate waste I
think that and I what I care most about
is reducing out ofate waste I want to
make sure that we have as many Avenues
to to make that happen as
possible okay uh you know for me with
this first of all I'm just I'm just so
um it's such an anathema to me to
prohibit private ownership of anything I
just just off the top of my head but and
I get it um you know being able to
control better what is being put into
our landfills and so that's that's a
positive for
me um I but I also wonder if we're
creating a conflict of
interest that that we still have to
permit the state still has to
permit this land to be used as a
landfill and go through the whole um
permitting process I would imagine and
so it just seems weird to me a possible
conflict of interest that the state is
permitting itself to use this land so
what do you what's your thoughts on that
we have other examples of things that
the state owns and hires a company to
operate yeah so uh for instance Mount
sunap I there are Opera there are in law
uh a number of things that constrain the
way that a ski resort can be operated
and they there are certain safety
requirements Etc that are state laws and
it doesn't matter whether it is Cannon
Mountain or uh Mount sopy or uh or
Gunstock or uh for for the publicly
owned ones or uh you cran Moore or Lon
or um they all have to follow laws
having to do with how ski resorts are
run
and just begs the question though does
the state do a good job doing
it I don't
know U representative
kulan H yeah thank you madam chair like
I can respect what you guys are trying
to do I think I understand the intent
but I believe when you publicize costs
and then privatize profits that's the
definition of corporate welfare actually
and so I agree with the cutting down on
the out ofate waste part but I just
think this kind of I get the idea but I
think it is actually just corporate
welfare so represent
Penza sorry that perplexes me I have to
I want you to explain that more because
I want to understand the corporate
welfare piece but I think this is just
as simple as the state having skin in
the game I believe that they've needed
skin in the game for a long time we just
got an email I think this morning that
is on a
report from a current active
landfill company that says any such life
liability is likely to be uninsurable
with no coverage likely under our
pollution or product liability policies
this is for in regards with like P and
they they just
said such liability is likely to be
uninsurable so once that landfill closes
we are on the hook for that I just I
don't understand right now in in we've
got super fun sites all over over New
Hampshire so I think this public private
partnership is I think it's I just think
it's the way um it gives us it gives us
that piece of of involvement that we
need um and and as well as just handing
it off to someone else everything's
handed off right now all of the
reporting comes directly from the
industry they hired the you know they
hired the contractors to do it they have
all of that and we're not and it's
wonderful in a sense but we've got to
trust but verify and I I just I think
that uh I think this is a great bill and
if it you know if it needs a little bit
of work cleaning up and stuff like that
then you know it's understandable but I
think it's time for the state to to
truly be involved in this process and
not just handed it off representative
smart
okay um I don't have the bill in front
of me but I know the bill we're talking
about and I also don't have emails in
front of
me I have a problem with the state
owning property um taking having our
landfills be state-owned I know from
experience that if there's a problem
your so you can't do anything about it
because they're bigger than we are and I
don't know how they got bigger than we
are because we're the people we have a
voice but the government I mean the
state has more power and and they're
telling us they don't have money to fund
other projects but they have money to
buy this buy land and make it into a
landfill how come I don't I don't get it
I I guess I'm not getting a lot of it
but it's not sitting well represent H
Haskins thank you madam chair we have a
trash
problem and local control is very
important to a lot of people at this
table the um issues that I have learned
about since sitting on this committee
suggest to me that the vermont-based
company doesn't care what we put in our
landfill doesn't care you know they need
to make a profit I get that um
I think skin in the game is absolutely
what this is about I think that we have
heard
testimony that our
constituents want a voice and they don't
feel like they're being
heard um so I think this gives us
another opportunity to have some
oversight and the company's going to
make plenty of money um that's not a
problem um um I'm reminded that
representative Duty takes us back to the
idea
that overall we want to reduce the stuff
that's going into the landfills so I
think these bills are getting closer to
being able to do that and provide an
incentive and I like this bill and I
hope we'll support
it uh yeah representative Howard thank
you and then ger um so when the Bia was
the representative was talking to us she
she said that um Bill elf um
1145 represented a lost business
opportunity but I what I wanted what I
wish I had asked her is are all business
opportunities equal so I think that that
we should factor that
in well I'll you know I'll tell you that
I I don't necessarily feel that it is
um
it that it that it would harm business
because business would still be running
the landfill but I I'm I'm not so sure
I'm I'm I want the state to get into the
trash business I don't know but anyway I
I I still have to really think about a
lot of what's what's been put before us
I mean I do like um HP
1632 in that it puts
a a percent
of uh Solid Waste transported from out
of state and that has a measure of
control without having the state
actually purchase land and get involved
with with uh having a contractor run it
and do whatever it's it's a more
simple uh solution to the issue of um of
of limiting the amount of at ofate Solid
Waste coming to us um anyway
representative gerana I'm rambling on no
no no I think it's important
to for us to think through these things
together because that's what we're all
doing so I appreciate that what Madam
chair was just saying I want to point
out two things one is when we talk about
this in in terms of the business of of
kind a landfilling it's important to
recognize that this is not a business
like other businesses right the very
nature of it legally is different from
other businesses they are required to
serve a public need they are required to
demonstrate that there is both that need
and and a public benefit uh and there
are reasons for that because even if a
private company owns that land obviously
you're talking about the air you're
talking about water that may be affected
because of the operation of that
business so it is unique or or unlike
most other businesses because by its
very nature it has to be a public
private Enterprise because of the the
resources that belong to all of us that
are involved by its very nature in this
business and as I'm willing to go out
out kind of on a limb and say I don't
think it's much of a limb but um I
thought about this during the hearing
there is the cost how much would this
cost we we're talking about several
years down the road capacity need is
something we're going to see coming it's
not going to catch us by surprise right
we're not going to all of a sudden
decide this has to be done tomorrow
we'll have time to see this coming uh I
am willing to absolutely bet that if we
asked our
constituents this is how much it's going
to cost for the state to buy the
landfill and to make sure that it's
suitable for placing a landfill and this
is how much it is going to basically
distri be distributed across the state
I'm willing to bet the vast majority of
our constituents would say absolutely
for us not to be The Dumping Ground of
solid waste for New England I would
absolutely Pony up my share of the taxes
that it would take for the state to do
that for the larger good of making sure
that we're protecting both the
environment and the public health I
don't think our constituents uh see this
being nearly as complicated as we tend
to make it thank you okay represent
Bixby yeah so I'd like to point out that
currently we have six operating
landfills in the state four of those are
publicly owned uh so Mount carbury the
one in uh Conway or North Conway Nashua
and Lebanon are all publicly owned
landfills
and uh they are not uh
they are not damaging the business
environment uh and they have more
control over what goes into them than
the uh than the two private landfills uh
so uh I I think that we have examples of
public landfills working already the
other thing is that this bill not only
authorizes
um or it it says that it can be uh a
state owned or owned by a subdivision
thereof so uh it could be that we you
know the state doesn't choose to uh
purchase land a landfill a a spot for
landfill but one of our counties might
and that would be entirely within the
scope of this bill uh the idea is that
if
we uh have that public owner the the
public ownership basically provides
public public oversight and public
control and that's what we're and what
we're seeing in
uh in the case of one of the privately
owned land uh landfills in the state is
that the people who live around it are
really concerned about the lack of
public control of what's going into it
and that they feel that their their
livelihoods are threatened because they
depend on tourism they depend on
businesses that have that are involved
with the natural resources that that
landfill might be impinging on and there
is a proposed landfill that might
further impinge on their
livelihoods uh and I think that by
putting it in the public domain we can
be more careful of the broader uh
environmental and business environment
than uh by saying okay well we'll we'll
just let a large company put a l
somewhere but don't we already have
public oversight and public control
through our regulator through our
department of environmental services for
all intents and purposes the state is
controlling the
landfill are they
not to some extent yes the permitting
process the permitting process does
allow them a degree of control but they
don't have the level of control to say
no we can't take mattres from
Massachusetts they don't have the level
of control to uh say we can't have more
than a certain amount of out ofate waste
uh that something that Dees just does
not have the legal capacity to do and by
putting into PRI into State owner into
public ownership we would uh get that
level of control which is what we need
in order to stop out of state waste
representative K thank you madam chair
um couple of points but I have a
question for representative Bixby of the
publicly owned landfills is there
anything in statute that prohibits
publicly owned landfills and of those
publicly owned landfills how is their
ownership uh so there is nothing that
prohibits uh there there's nothing that
prohibits a public loan landfill at the
moment uh there is uh so and in terms of
the owner ership the city of nasba owns
their landfill uh I believe that it's
the city of Berlin Berlin or uh Berlin
and Berlin and some of the other
surrounding towns that owns Mount
carbury uh I believe that I I'm it's I'm
not sure whether it's Conway or North
Conway but that that municipality owns
that landfill Lebanon owns uh the the
landfill in Lebanon uh they make choices
about where they get their their trash
from so Lebanon is willing to take trash
from a few towns in Vermont that are
right across the river but uh not from
every town in New Hampshire because it's
a town Landfield they can choose
representative kto followup right so and
I believe that these publicly owned
landfills also have to go through have
Dees as their oversight also I'm
assuming would that be correct that is
correct they have to meet all the
permitting requirements that a private
land would landfill would have to meet
okay
so right
now if the
public with we just put a more we just
voted for moratorium and on all
landfills for four
years or three and a half whatever um
and the thing
is is that
when I look I mean so right now Dees is
like the oversight board
right but now we want them to do
both from I work in
manufacturing and I had an incident
where I had a production person said oh
the QC person's out don't worry I'll
take care of
QC and to me that's the fox watching the
hen house
so I'm not saying that's what's going to
happen but that's the analogy I'm going
to
use
because we can already have publicly
owned
landfills and the towns in their
zoning can have hearings and with these
other bills that we're doing with impact
studies and public
benefit why do we need the state to own
a uh be the ones owning the landfill I
understand the intent is to reduce waste
coming in I understand that I think
that's already going to be partly
accomplished through the moratorium
because these landfills already have to
make sure that they take New Hampshire
waste before they take out of state
waste so by putting a moratorium on that
that means right now there is no more
expansions I mean I well we can expand
but still that takes time but but there
can be no landfill cited so there's no
more we're at a finite amount of space
right now and we know one of the
landfills is
closing I I'd like to offer just kind of
a thought instead of prohibiting private
ownership of landfills why wouldn't we
say right into statute that um 50% of
the landfills that are in New Hampshire
or that would be permitted in New
Hampshire would be publicly owned and
50% privately
owned what what are people think
thoughts of that representative
ger uh I think my my initial reaction to
that would be that that would be
difficult
to enforce and maintain right I mean how
do we determine what it
is if we have an uneven number in and of
itself right are we talking talking
about capacity so here I understand I I
I think where you're going but I think
actually being able to determine what
constitutes 50% would be somewhat
difficult and then I think it can be
easily kind of thrown off and then what
happens if we are out of balance and
it's 640 or 55 65 again if it's just the
number or we talk about the acreage or
we talk about number the number of
operating
facilities that I because again I'm I'm
just
so just so don't like the idea of of
prohibiting private ownership of
anything that um and I know it's done
you know we do have things that are
publicly owned and that's okay but um
we're still not Banning people from uh
having a private ownership of a of a ski
resort you know
um I I just think you're just in matter
of of
control uh you know if we're looking
to reduce the amount of solid waste
coming in from out of states and we see
that having
publicly publicly owned ones would sort
of move us into that direction that if
we could um you know not ban it but
limit the the amount of private
ownership um you know limit the amount
of ownership of landfills that just
seems to be sort of a compromise there
okay can I also can I clarify something
to just uh something has come up several
times in previous discussions the the
private landfills in particular in the
state do not put New Hampshire Solid
Waste ahead of out of state solid waste
our capacity is determined by New
Hampshire produced Solid Waste but we
don't measure uh per se right so that we
would stop taking out of state waste at
a certain point right so I just wanted
to to clarify there is no requirement
for the state to or or pardon me any of
our private landfills to put New
Hampshire Solid Waste ahead of out ofate
Solid Waste right but don't they
represent thank you but don't they have
to make sure that under their existing
landfills that they have to be able to
make sure they be it fulfills New
Hampshire waste so that you know if if
they're right now they're good until say
2030 so they have six years don't they
have to make sure they can take New
Hampshire waste for the next 6 years and
fulfill that
I respond you may respond just want to
make sure I was in order thank you no
what they're deter when they determine
capacity they determine it based on
their projection of what new instate
Solid Waste production is going to be so
that theoretically like if if this
hopefully won't happen but if if we
started taking in 55 60% of outof State
waste our capacity would drop
dramatically because the capacity was
determined based on out of state waste
so it's not a requirement that is simply
the metric they Ed to determine capacity
when they permit so representative com
thank you so maybe one of the things
that we need to put in there is that
they have to take in consideration in
their metric New Hampshire waste
first represent
dsy thank you madam chair um yesterday I
had a doctor's appointment down in L and
when I came back okay so I think maybe
we're talking about 18 miles I noticed
four four garbage trucks on the road
okay cassella Waste Management Shaws and
Harvey's okay that was in a matter of
like 25 minutes being on the highway
four garbage trucks there's got to be
money in garbage okay so you know what
I'm concerned about is that I support
both of these bills uh I like the fact
that there is um not just skin in the
game but but more government oversight I
like the fact that if it's owned if the
land is owned by the state and operated
by a private company that we don't have
to um that we don't have to accept waste
from out of state that we have control
over that because to be honest with you
every Tom Dick and Harry can I mean the
the barriers to entry to get into the
garbage business to me seem to be very
low I mean maybe it's a truck
$250,000 okay you buy a truck and you
you finance it and voila you're in the
garbage business the other thing that I
like about um Municipal owned or this
the state-owned land and having more
regulation is that you know we can't
create more land and it's not just the
amount that's going in it's what's going
in okay and under private control
private ownership we really have very
very limited ability to oversee that and
to say that we that Dees oversees it
I've been on this committee this is my
sixth year and how many times how many
letters have we seen that we cannot
Implement AB C or D because we do not
have the resources to fund another
position so for us to sit here and think
that Dees is providing any amount of
oversight you know in existing uh
landfills you know I think you know is
um you know uh being silly on our part
and the last thing I I'll I'll notice
and I haven't read them in depth but
I've seen you know a lot of complaints
or uh go to Dees regarding issues um
with Bethlehem I think it is you know up
in the north country and and the process
to get any of those complaints you know
recognized and through the system I mean
it just seems like one complaint is
piled up on another complaint if the
city if the state owns the land and the
operator is not doing its job we can
fire them if it's privately owned we
can't so I mean I think we need and
coming from nashwa We Bought you know
the best thing our city ever did was buy
the land in 1964 for the landfill it
operates well uh we have no issues with
it every once in a while I mean whenever
there's an issue it's addressed
immediately okay because it's the city
it's the people in the city and it's the
voters in the city okay that own the
landfill and elect the people to run it
so I mean from my perspective I think
it's a win-win to go uh with state-owned
land privately
Run Okay um we're we're pushing here at
noon and um I'll have Kelly and then uh
I'd like to break for lunch but I'm I'm
wondering if the committee would be
considering um continuing a a work
session and have further discussion on
these two bills at another date so um I
think we we've got a lot of things that
we need to kind of air out and uh I
think it's constructive to at least talk
about it and see where we uh where we
want to go with them represent
Penza so BAS upon the knowledge that I
have um Dees currently only has like one
person that is that is out whether it be
you know inspecting um like going on
site to whether it be a landfill or a
transfer station I don't I don't believe
that this bill is looking to to um put
additional staff or any of that I think
it actually operates the exact same way
that it currently is operating the only
change is in a sense we own the
property that's my end my that's my idea
of skin in the game and so so there is
there's that level of oversight just
because we have that ownership the other
piece is we don't need we're we're
talking about like one landfill in The
Next
Century so you know based upon this
we're we're acting like you know we're
going to we're gonna you know there's
going to be landfills that are going to
crop up every five years or that's not
going to happen so this bill passing
would maybe mean the state owns property
for a landfill two of them in in the
next hundred years that the other thing
is I think this changes the landscape
right because where's the necessity if
we know what the need is and the state
knows what the need is Dees knows what
the need is then we don't need to to
have all of these private landfills
cropping up all over New Hampshire so
it's truly it's a needs-based type of
thing that's how I think of this so my
two cents
okay all right I'm going to um close out
this work session and I think that we
will um continue discussions about these
two bills um in at a future date um and
um I hope you have a good
lunch thank you we get to talk about
kangaroos oh yes
kangaroos oh we've got a kangaroo
bill
okay members please take their
seats
good afternoon and welcome to
environment and
agriculture
today excuse me I'm sorry um we are
going to begin this afternoon uh with
hearing on HB
1351 prohibiting the sale and use of
adhesive based rodent
traps uh here to introduce the bill is
representative Jerry
Cannon and I would like to we um we've
got a number of pink cards on this today
um I would like it if uh something has
already been said please don't repeat it
if you have something new to offer the
committee in in uh terms of your
testimony we'd be happy to hear it um
but we do have limited time
so um with that welcome representative
Canon and uh we look forward to your
comments thank you madam chair parison
and fellow Le
legislators
um I had one of one of our speakers
contact me and asked me if they would if
I would introduce this bill um and I
thought about it I said how many times
have I walked into my kitchen and I see
little mice turds all over the place and
the Panic sets in what did they get into
um see what was torn apart or where they
were and then try and figure out where
they came from
um and um I've had I've had wraps as
well that caused tremendous amount of
damage in my home last year and I got a
new kitchen out of
it yeah but anyways
um mice are a member of our food
chain um you know other animals eat them
and those and other animals eat those
and somewhere along the line we may eat
something that was ultimately where a
mice a mouse was part of their their
diet
uh we for many of us especially uh those
of us that have old homes we we usually
experience some form of mice mouse or
whatever running around the house and if
you don't have a
cat they continue to run around and you
the the anxiety of okay I need to find a
way to capture or kill this thing uh
because I don't want it in my house it's
invading my
space in reality they're just hunting
for
food uh and um and they're looking for
food pieces things of that that we
normally eat and they're just trying to
find them and they're rather destructive
in their way of trying to find
them one method of cap capturing these
mice has has been glue
traps it's a very cruel way um to
capture and kill um a rodent they get
stuck in this thing
and they starve they don't have any
water uh some of the animals even chew
their legs
off uh it can be pretty
gross
uh for about a year and a half I worked
for Community Action Partnership in do
um all of straford County and we had a
number of buildings and I was constantly
uh looking for uh mice and rodents
because we did have kitchens we fed kids
and uh so we had to make sure that the
rodent population was minimal especially
when inspectors came
around I I had one building that was
especially bad it was an old home that
had been converted into
classrooms and
I don't forget when they first had me go
downstairs course was really creepy um
and
um there were these traps set all over
the place a pesticide company had come
in and and put them in and um and so we
called them and um they hadn't been out
there in a while so they said well they
wouldn't come and pick them up I was
responsible for picking them up and
taking care of
them and I found about 20 of
them in in some really odd spots too and
some of them had like one mouse or two
and the number of
skeletons um there were a number
of insects a lot of dirt and
dust and um and it was it was just
disgusting to have to pick these things
up and and get rid of
them
um we got another pesticide company come
in to take a look at um ways to take
care of them and um uh so they did a
number of things and tried and catch it
catch them and including
ultrasonic um devices that they plugged
in but they also put down
more glue
tabs and they never came to check on
them or pick them up or anything it was
our responsibility to take care of
them
um it was very difficult for especially
someone who really cares about animals
to to see these small creatures um stuck
in these
traps
um although I'll tell you I've put a
couple in my house and I was always
worried at the time whether one one of
my my dogs would find one and get stuck
to it and then I was going to have to
clean it off luckily I
didn't and and all I got for the traps
that I put there was was dust and
dirt um I ended up putting uh the high
frequency devices in my home that took
care of many of them and then I put down
these plastic boxes with u with
chemicals inside and that took care of a
few um
and then I uh I had a rat problem I
ended up with electronic traps and and
have a heart trap and I got rid of those
that
way in
um in investigating uh this problem I
found that there were uh a number of
countries and many corporations who
banned the use of these in their
facilities and and
um probably just for many of the same
reasons as is that they had to have
someone continually monitor them and
capture them and get rid of the the
creatures um and I uh I did find out
there's a number of states that um are
considering Banning these devices
already um and but I also I also thought
about um uh the people who sell these
too I work for Home
Depot and we sell them and when I asked
about um how much it was going to cost
the company for uh if we stop selling
them and is it
insignificant you we're on the Shelf
along with everything else and we didn't
sell a tremendous amount but so the cost
for the company would be
minimal so you're going to hear a lot
more about these
traps and um the challenges that people
face with them in different places and
what damage they
cause and and um I'm going to urge you
to vote ought to ought to pass this bill
um so we ban them in the state for sale
and and ultimately ban the use of
them thank you and I'm open to questions
and I'll answer them if I can but we are
going to have
experts any questions from the
committee seeing none thank you for
introducing this bill to us i' like to
call Joel
gon
[Music]
good afternoon Representatives uh my
name is Joel gon I drove here from
Hillsboro to speak before you today in
support of House Bill
1351 um from my experience glue traps
are extremely inhumane and and must be
banned immediately uh there's absolutely
no
justification for forcing animals to
endure that much pain and suffering
especially when there are so many more
Humane and effective Alternatives
available to us um last month my
landlord handed me some glue traps to
address the presence of mice in my
building I declined to use them and
instead suggested he consider more
Humane options um animal caught in go
traps experience painful deaths uh if
you've never personally seen uh what go
traps do to animals uh I urge you to
look at photos or watch a video of an
animal caught in one um if you do you'll
see a terrified animal being killed
slowly in one of the most horrible and
violent ways
imaginable um mice and rats who are most
frequently the victims of glue traps uh
they're intelligent sensitive and
affectionate animals they may be small
but they're capable of feeling Joy
excitement pain fear just like the dogs
and cats we call family we have an
obligation to treat them humanely um
whether the animal caught in the glue
trap is a mouse a bird a lizard a
squirrel that happens too no living
being should ever be killed in such a
cruel and barbaric way um I fully
support ban on glue traps I hope that
after hearing everyone's testimony today
the committee will support it as well
thank you thank you any questions from
the
committee seeing none thank you for your
testimony I'll call Jean
slian thank you and um my colleague
Jacob is going to distribute some
written materials to you because it's a
little difficult for me to balance with
the written materials
but good afternoon good afternoon um my
name is eug jeene slepian I live in
Stoddard in chesher
County um and I uh I first became aware
of the problems with glue traps several
years ago when I started following some
of the Facebook posts of some of the
Wildlife Rehabilitation
hospitals and honestly I could not
believe that these traps could possibly
be legal because they were so extremely
cruel um so I'm very very grateful to
representative Canon for bringing this
issue to the
legislature and if I could I'd also like
to take a moment to say how grateful I
am to the people in the legislative
Services office this year because I know
they've been working night and day with
the number of bills that they have and
they did a very careful um and very
thorough job with this bill and I'm very
very very
appreciative um so I I'll try to be very
concise
um the US Centers for Disease Control
and prevention says on their website do
not use glue traps the reason for this
is that as the animals die slowly on the
traps they will continue to excrete
bodily substances including blood
because they often try to chew their
limbs off and this can be a source of
disease transmission um bacteria and
viral infections hirus Le sporos
salmonella and this is especially
dangerous if there are uh young children
or or companion animals in the
household also the New Hampshire Fish
and Game department in their wild lines
publication which is a beautiful
publication of their non-game
program um from the summer of
2021 in that issue they said avoid the
use of glue traps it's at the New
Hampshire Fish and Game department avoid
the use of glute traps because of the
non-target animals that are often caught
and
suffer Snakes song birds frogs toads
Turtles even even kittens puppies um
they so the New Hampshire fishing game
department has said avoid the use of
glue traps the US fish and wildlife
service in its publication for
professional Wildlife Control operators
um that are dealing with bat populations
the US fish and wildlife service has
said sticky traps are not
acceptable to use in controlling bat
populations um so we we really can't
have people purchasing sticky traps to
control bats and throwing them into the
attic or the barn or the garage um New
Hampshire Fish and Game department says
that there are eight species of bats in
New Hampshire and they are they're all
of conservation concern so bats are a
big issue in the use of sticky traps um
the American Veterinary Medical
Association has stated in its guidelines
for youth in Asia which it defines as
the intentional death of an animal that
when F when lethal traps must be used
the mo the most Humane option must be
chosen and that trapping a conscious
animal in a sticky trap
does not meet their definition does not
meet their acceptable standards for
youth in Asia the Canadian Medical
Association J uh the Canadian Veterinary
Medical Association is opposed to the
use of glue traps um and I did a survey
and the results of the survey are are in
your packets there so I hope you'll have
an opportunity to take a look at them
between August and October of two 202 23
I did a survey of 20 professional
wildlife control operator companies in
New Hampshire um I got the names of
these companies from looking at some of
the national
organizations and out of the 20
companies 15 companies told me
absolutely they do not use glut traps
and if you look at some of the comments
that they've made they're really quite
emphatic about the cruelty of glue traps
so 15 of the companies said they do not
use glue traps 19 of the companies
advertise on their websites Humane and
ethical methods of wildlife
control so I think that we can
say
confidently that eliminating the use of
glue traps especially because our bill
gives them a year to come up to to to to
fix this problem I think we can say
confidently that this will not impact
professional Wildlife Control operators
adversely now two of the companies that
I contacted and this information is also
in the packet two of the companies said
that they use small sticky traps for
monitoring insect infestations and
insect problems but our bill HP 1351 is
is not about insects it specifically
addresses the ISS issue of traps that
are intended for
rodents um so we're we're not talking
about the very small traps or the fly
paper that that would help with the the
in insect problems um and and lastly um
when when we passed the interstate
Wildlife violators
compact in
2013 we said
we we agreed we agreed that
Wildlife is held in trust is managed in
trust for the benefit of all of the
citizens of the state and all visitors
which means that the state as Trustee of
Wildlife Resources has a statutory and
an ethical obligation to protect
Wildlife um from hazards and I would
compare this to the prohibition on the
use of lead fishing jigs and
sinkers um and that bill was passed in
1998 and the intent of that
bill was to prevent the death of water
fowl who were affected by the lead
fishing J Jigs and sinkers uh especially
loons they found a huge
problem with the death of loons from
lead poisoning and the sponsor of that
bill was Senator Jeb Bradley when he was
in the House of
Representatives
so I think there are also many many many
options and I think some of the other
people here are going to discuss some of
the other options there are snap traps
electric traps Catch and Release traps
there are natural repellants like
peppermint um cayenne pepper uh cloes
there are a wide variety of commercial
products that can be used for repellants
there's
um plug plugging up the the uh the
places where the medicine rats are
getting into the house there's covering
food uh removing food sources covering
garbage cans and then my favorite option
to go to the local animal shelter and
adopt a couple of
cats um so uh I'd be happy to answer any
questions and I thank you for your
attention any questions from the
committee seeing none thank you for your
testimony I call BJ
wall I don't want to bump into you here
oh no
you're hi my name is spej while I'm live
in Sullivan which is also in Chester
County near Kean um I've come often to
conquer to speak on various bills most
of them having to do with being kind to
animals or being kinder to animals as
this one is and they're always it every
single one never one anything and I just
really hope that maybe this time you
guys will listen and please pass this
bill because the use of glue traps is
totally unnecessary I actually BR a trap
we use these in our house cuz even
though we have five cats we have a Mouse
a mouse inest basement that um and these
are great because you catch them and you
just take them somewhere and release
them at least that gives them a fighting
chance for
survival um but lots of people
apparently do use gluc caps and I really
can't understand why they would but it
often has the unintended consequence as
Jean said of catching song birds which
has a declining population at the moment
Chipmunks kittens they had to euthanize
a cat because it got caught in more than
one glue trap and it's really hard to
get them off of a glue trap it's it's
nearly impossible their skin gets ripped
they themselves try
to GW off their own
limbs
um but even if it only caught mice I
feel it still should be outlawed it's
just so cruel and there is a similar
bill in the US House at the moment I'm
hoping that passes but I don't think
that the state of New Hampshire should
wait for the US House to pass this bill
I think we should be leaders in this and
uh I hope you do the right thing and
support this bill thanks any questions
from the
committee see none thank you Maria Colby
believe is it correct Colby no thank
you
shamman Aaron and members of the
committee my name is Maria kobby and I
am a wildlife rehabilitator located in
Haner New Hampshire I provide care for
approximately
1,500 injured and orphaned animals a
year today I am speaking in support of
House Bill 1351 and act to be an
adhesive base rodent traps in New
Hampshire thank
you adhesive based rodent traps also
known as glue traps are cruel and
indiscriminate and probably responsible
for more suffering than any other
Wildlife Control product on the market
said Dr James Jens for president of the
Democrats for the protection of animals
any
animal be it the intended target of a
beloved family pet
can be caught in the Trap and suffer a
slow death by S starvation or
Suffocation in
20123 I removed four mice three phoebes
and four sparrows from glue traps the
animals suffered broken bones dislocated
joints loss of feathers or fur because
these animals were attempting to free
themselves from the glue
traps so far this here I removed a bat
from a glue trap these animals were
brought to me by individuals that
purchased them um to use the glue
trap these individuals saw the animal
struggling in the glue trap and realized
that it was a cruel and inhumane way for
the animal to die this is what these
people said to me I know it's here say
okay but you know
um as as far as I'm concerned they're
right it was cruel and
inhumane they reached out to save the
animal from such a cruel death
unfortunately there were too much damage
that was caused due to the animal
struggling to be free most of these
animals had I had to euthanize
them Humane Alternatives exist animal
cruelty laws do exist in New Hampshire
it's time that New Hampshire legislation
prohibits a sale in use of glue traps to
stop this cruelty if house bills 1231
passes New Hampshire retailers
Distributors exterminators manufacturers
and retailers have until January
20206 to comply with this
law I thank you for your time and
attention Okay are there any questions
from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much for coming today thank you um Eric
ORF good afternoon welcome to
environment and
agriculture thank you madam chair thank
you committee my name is Eric ORF I have
been a wildlife biologist in New
Hampshire for a half a century I am here
today representing as a volunteer in New
Hampshire ottobon I'd like to read their
their testimony and make a couple
comments so thank you for the
opportunity for uh providing testimony
on House Bill 1351 on behalf of the
Hampshire otar we are a Statewide
conservation organization dedicated to
protecting the Hampshire's environment
for wildlife and for
people HB 1351 bans for sale the use of
adhesive based rodent traps in New
Hampshire incl including by licensed
exterminators we encourage the committee
to consider a number of factors in their
deliberations on this bill rodent C
rodents can cause significant property
damage and risk to Public Health when
present in homes and businesses rudant
control options include three widely
used live traps kill traps poisoning
indoor cats and indoor cats provide an
additional
alternative adhesive base traps are in
the kill traps category when used
Outdoors can kill non- tarret species
that get stuck in the Trap however the
effective of the kill trap are limited
to the animals that die in the Trap
itself consequently when limited to
indoor use adhesive B based trap seld
affect non-target species while adhesive
base traps do provide a Hu a do not
provide a human Humane death they only
affect individuals caught directly in
contrast poisoning affects both the
target rodents and other wild life
including individuals from Far Far From
The Bait site poison poison rodents
leave the bait site and then can be
captured by predators that consume the
Poison by consuming the prey second
generation anti-coagulant pesticides in
particular are now widely documented in
Native mammals such as Fisher foxes
Bobcats and have caused mortality in
Eagles Hawks and owls the Hampshire
ottobon supports policy that limits or
avoids the death of non-target wildlife
we urge the committee to understand the
effects and consequences of available
rodent control strategies and take
comprehensive approach to addressing
this issue rather than to legislate only
single approaches in the El in the
isolation from the big picture well
appreciate the U the committee and as I
mentioned I've been a wildlife biologist
in New Hampshire and I have good news
you know we when I I was the first bear
biologist beginning in the 70s and uh
there were a thousand Bears when I first
determined in the 80s and now we have
over 6,000 Bears over 109 bald eagle
pears more deer than you can imagine and
most of our fishing wfe in New Hampshire
has thrived during my 50-year career and
it's been such a wonderful thing to
watch the you know from no Eagles to 100
pairs of eagles and Ospreys for but less
than 10 to 200 pairs today what has been
affected the most the last several
decades it's our reptiles and amphibians
and passing Birds the birds we love to
see so these traps are you non-
selective they you know where does a a
frog or a snake want to hide out in the
in the recesses where these glue traps
are placed for rodents so they were a
double whammy and when you eliminate the
snakes around your property you're
eliminating the patrol who's out there
taking care of these rodents the natural
way so these traps are very
non-selective and that is why New
Hampshire aabon is here to support this
bill today thank you very much thank you
sir and thank you for your your work in
this very important area of um helping
our Wildlife any other questions from
the committee representative Bixby yeah
so um you said that uh that that there
needs to be a sort of a more uh
comprehensive approach are you
suggesting that this bill needs to be
amended in some way or is this would is
this bill good as it is and then uh uh
further further refinements could be
done with other legislation well
certainly uh based on my testimony there
are certainly probably some options that
could be looked at uh what those are I
can't tell you that I'm an exper expert
in rodent control uh I can catch bears
but uh I'm not as good at catching rats
and mice I guess havn't had to do that
and you wouldn't use a glue trap for a
bear I I do
not and if I did I would call
[Laughter]
you any other questions seeing none
thank you so much for joining us today
and I call Dr William trenle and again
please I remind people if we've heard um
a point being brought up
before then um uh please do not repeat
it um we do have limited time for
hearing today so go ahead welcome years
ago um walking around in my
backyard uh they're deer flies and they
start attacking your face and they're a
nuisance and one day I I went to a store
and I saw a uh deerfly tap tape which is
a variation of these glue traps and and
so I tried it you affix it to the back
of your hat and then the there's an
adhesive side that these deer flies are
attracted to and they they can stick to
it but they don't come to your face
which is the good thing and
um at the end of the day walking around
in my yard I'd come back take my ball
cap off put it down and you'd see about
six of these flies affixed to that
trapped in in the glue and um I would
just put it on the side and leave it
there and then the next day go out again
and put the Hat on of course these
animals would be just sitting there and
uh they they would die
eventually um and over time I I I I
started learning a little bit more about
how we treat animals and um I became a
little concerned about this and I I
looked at it and I said something's not
right about that and I even found myself
trying to free them from the tape I
would pluck them off of there and many
of them actually survived I don't know
how much trauma they had but they would
fly off
um and um but eventually I just gave it
up all together and I I said you know
what I'm going to try something
different here I I got a piece of duct
tape and I taped that to the back of my
hat instead and so magically when I was
walking around in the backyard the deer
flies were attracted to that tape but
there's no adhesive on on it because
it's not a you know the adhesive side is
a fix to the hat but they didn't come
into my face and uh so I thought that
was pretty neat and I even experimented
and I um I tried a hat walking in in the
yard without the tape without the duct
tape on there and sure enough they were
back in my face again but um the bottom
line is what I'm trying to get at here
is I'm just trying to say that there
there is
um there's usually an
alternative and and a Kinder
alternative if we care and and that's
all I wanted to say um so thank you for
your time thank you questions from the
committee seeing none uh call Jacob
Shaw
good afternoon Madam chair and members
of the committee my name is Jacob Shaw
and I'm here on behalf of people for the
ethical treatment of animals and our
more than 31,000 members and supporters
in New Hampshire to express our strong
support for HP
1351 as you've heard today glue traps
are indiscriminate killing devices that
permanently disable injure and kill
countless small animals every single
year you I will skip over some of this
because you know you've heard it from
other people but to just put some
numbers behind some of what we've talked
about with other species of wildlife
being caught in glue traps um our
submitted testimony includes a letter
from Edward Clark who oversees the wild
one database which collects and verifies
patient admission information from
Wildlife Care centers around the country
and as you'll see in the letter and the
data set
attached um more than or 180 species of
wildlife including dozens of species of
birds bats Chipmunks lizards mice AP
possums rabbits salamanders snakes
Turtles and even flying squirrels have
been caught in glue traps and were
brought to animal hospitals in need of
life-saving care and you know in
addition to Maria a number of other
wildlife rehabilitators in the State uh
including Deb go Franny Greenberg Joyce
beamus and Susan Smith have all
indicated their support for this bill
because you know they see and treat
animals who are cotton glue traps
they've seen this up close and they know
the consequences of the use of glue
traps um but it's worth noting that all
of these numbers only represent the
animals who are actually brought to
Wildlife Care Centers what's most
horrifying about glut traps is that the
vast majority of animals who are caught
in them are never even taken to an
animal hospital or a wildlife
rehabilitator they are left to suffer
excruciatingly painful deaths and after
their paws Tails snouts and beaks get
stuck to the glue many animals suffer
for days and they die slowly and
painfully from starvation dehy hydration
blood loss and asphixiation their eyes
and their mouths can become glued shut
and as they struggle to escape from the
traps they just become even more insens
snared and the glue tears off chunks of
their fur feathers or
skin the manufacturers of these traps
actually instruct users to throw the
traps in the garbage even if the animal
caught on the Trap is still alive and
when people are confronted with an
animal caught to a glue trap thrashing
in pain or crying in agony they panic
because they don't know what to do with
a trapped animal you know some people
may try to help the terrified animal but
others have reported drowning trapped
animals or even bludgeoning them to
death and I apologize for you know the
graphic detail but it's just part of the
nature of what's being discussed
obviously um you know for more than 20
years Peta has operated a 24-hour
emergency response hotline across the
country and every single year we receive
dozens of frantic reports of animals ens
snared in these traps and many of our
callers actually set the traps
themselves not knowing what to expect
and after seeing the horrors of what
glue traps do to animals they tell us
that they will never use these traps
again no animal regardless of their
species should ever be forced to endure
the kind of suffering that glue traps
inflict HB 1351 which is a bipartisan
bill will measurably reduce animal
suffering and will help spare the lives
of countless gentle animals we urge you
to support this Bill thank you so much
for your time and for your
consideration thank you any questions
from the
committee see none uh thank you I call
Yen Yan Osborne sorry if I mispronounced
the
name and what town are you from please
let us know Auburn y okay Welcome to our
committee thank you
i' would like to start out by saying
mice rats other rodents are pests they
constantly destroying property eating
the crops in my garden ruining my walls
so I have absolutely no quals with
trapping or killing said
creatures if a rodent or a pest is
trespassing on my property destroy my
belonging
my garden which provides a vast amount
of what I
eat why should
I why should it be allowed to get away
with such an offense why should I not be
allowed to take measures to protect my
property from those who wish to destroy
it I oppose this bill not just because
of that reason but also because I don't
believe the government has any right to
regulate what kind of mouse traps we do
or do not sell thank you thank
you any questions from the committee
represented ktoa thank you madam chair
could you spell your first name please
it's e o w
YN thank you yep thank you very much all
right appreciate your testimony thanks
for coming this afternoon Joan
O'Brien
this will be fast thank you thank you
chair
members um I'm Joan O'Brien uh
representing New Hampshire animal rights
League um on behalf of the Hampshire
animal rights league and our members we
respectfully request that the committee
support House Bill 1351 to prohibit the
sale and use of adhesive back traps as
we've heard and we'll hear
more uh these traps are one of the
cruestv on the market and have many
other problems associated with them so
in 2022 our group enhan animal rights we
made the cruelty of Goo traps one of the
topics at our exhibit at the annual New
Hampshire Fish game discover wild New
Hampshire day during this event we
talked to hundreds of people about how
they deal with mice we were pleasantly
surprised that the majority of the
people said they do not use glue
traps
um it seems there's a widespread
acknowledgement that these traps are
cruel children especially recognize the
cruelty of glue traps we invited
children to send postcards to Walmart
which is one of the holdout stores that
still sells and uses these traps many
other as Target and I might be wrong
about Target Walgreens CVS have um sworn
them off and on the backside of the
sheet are four of our favorite Postcards
From the children uh given that these
traps are widely recognized as cruel as
well as a threat to non-target animals
we hope the committee will support 1351
thank you thank
you so I do have a question for you as
you've cited a number of uh retailers
who have decided upon themselves not to
sell these
traps and through education and Outreach
you're educating people um reasons why
they shouldn't use these traps and you
are hearing from a good number of the
public uh that they wouldn't use these
traps um it would seem to me that um
through public education
that
probably they're not you know the they
stores are not really selling many of
these um why then would we put into
statute that they would be prohibited
from being sold if the majority of
people are not using them thank you for
your question so our our organization
you know our goal is to reduce the
amount of suffering that animals endure
and as we heard animals are suffering
today in these apps if we take that
approach and just wait for all the
stores to come on board think of all the
the death and suffering that's going to
be happening in the meantime we owe it
to the animals to take action if it were
children or puppies or kittens we
wouldn't be suggesting that we just let
you know things take their
course okay any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you for your
testimony today and I call um Kurt
urg from the human
Society good afternoon Mr
aronberg good afternoon chairman Aaron
and members of the committee I'm Kurt
arenburg state director of the Humane
Society of the United States and uh for
all the reasons you've heard already um
we do support this legislation these
traps are unnecessary and
cruel um and I would just say that there
is federal legislation uh it's probably
doesn't have much of a chance just
because of the nature of the federal
Congress these days getting things done
um so it as many issues in the country
now comes to you as elected legislators
that actually are in a body that can get
something done on the old adage of build
a better mouse trap in the world would
beat a path to your door you
know pass the first Humane mous trp law
and other states will beat a path to
that law and so let's do this thank you
thank you any questions from Mr
aronberg seeing none I call um
commissioner John Sean Jasper from the
Department of
Agriculture welcome and good
afternoon good afternoon Madam chairman
members of the committee uh I do rise in
opposition to the to the bill you'll
know qu that the section of law that is
proposed to be Amendment here actually
does come under the jurisdiction of the
Department of
Agriculture and we've heard a lot of
testimony that really tugs at your
heartstrings and youve heard about
Wildlife this is about rodents I would
agree people should not be putting glue
strips out into the area where birds and
wildlife
are apt to be caught up in them so
perhaps a simple amendment to make sure
that it shall be illegal to Pro to put
glue strips in areas that are easily
accessible to Wildlife and birds unless
um they are um done in a in a way that
prevents easy exposure to that such as a
a box with a hole in it that allows only
rats or mice to go into it and these are
rodents they're defined as pests in New
Hampshire statute for a reason they
spread disease they cause damage they
can burn down people's houses when they
get into the into your house and chew on
wires killing animals is not an easy
thing to do killing rodents is not an
easy thing to do sometimes it is
necessary you know I I going to admit
this to you and everybody's going to
think I'm probably a horrible person but
I think you need to look at the
reality I often catch rodents and a have
a heart
trap I caught three my mother's 91 and I
caught three in her house they were
running around her house and this is
this year what am I going to do with
them this time of the year you're going
to take an something out and turn it
loose to miles away no unfortunately I
had to drown them I hate doing that but
what else am I going to do there and if
you don't check those traps just like if
you don't check a glue strip often
enough they're going to starve to death
in a have a heart trap it's but they're
they're things that are doing damage
they're certainly causing damage to
Farmers around the state glue strips are
in our program as part of the integrated
Pest Management um program I will tell
you that people say oh there are other
ways to do it and I I tell you
unfortunately because people thought it
was terrible to um make these rodents
leave a house to seek water a well-known
company took that formula
out um I can't use that anymore there is
nothing worse than a dead animal rotting
in your wall and still have that happen
it's awful it's not
healthy so I've you know used
um Regular traps spring traps that's
terrible as well it doesn't always
instantly kill the animal either I got a
squirrel in my attic one time got his
tail in
it and it's flopping around in the Attic
which was not a a walk out attic it's a
you know just under the
eaves dealing with that was not not
pleasant either but we have to allow our
farmers and homeowners to be able to
effectively manage it even with the
havahart traps or the spring
traps I have a failure rate of probably
greater than
50% they get the bait off the Trap
they're able to get in and out and we
still have these pests these r running
around in our houses we have them in
Barns on farms where they're eating
through grain bags and the grain
supplies you have to give us the
option but you're what you were hearing
about was Wildlife I absolutely agree
there is no way these glue strips should
be put where their wildlife and birds
can get to them that is irresponsible
I'm sure that's against most of the
recommended um uses of them and maybe we
could tighten that up we heard about you
know fishing games talking about not
using them I think there were probably
and I didn't have time to go but I would
encourage you to look or talk to
somebody from fishing game I think again
they were talking about using those
outside I don't think fishing game has
made a recommendation on the use of
these
inside none of this is fun none of this
is easy there's no easy way to get rid
of rodents
um but we need to be able to protect
public health and get rid of
rodents thank you thank you um
so I imagine that um people
use various
non-chemical intervention in uh
capturing capturing or eliminating um
rodents pests that kind of thing and
especially I would imagine that um these
kinds of glue traps are used in Orchards
where there's food so the farmers don't
want to use chemicals there or in food
preparation areas um so if we were
to
um say prohibit the use of these traps
in areas where there's other L wildli
such like uh such as like in Orchards
How would how would
then uh these glue traps be used uh so
as not to entrap or Target uh unintended
species thank you um I will tell you
that years years ago when we were in the
poultry business one of the things that
my father did to deal with rodents in
the hen houses long before there were
glue strips was he built plywood boxes
put tar paper over over the top of them
they were indoors but there were other
reasons for the tar paper and cut very
small holes in the ends so that only
rats and mice could get in um nothing a
chicken couldn't get in you could do the
exact same thing where if you're
concerned about a larger animal that
they could not get in and just if you're
looking to eliminate rats mice moles
things of that nature um they could be
that's why I said um something to the
effect that uh they couldn't be used
outside except where uh Wildlife is um
prevented from being able to uh enter
the area where they're in use and that
would be through a that type of box I'm
sure there are I know now that some of
the glue strips already come in in
certain containers where nothing else
can get into them uh I do use have to
use them in a self storage facility um
because the mice get in cont constantly
if they use poison they're going to die
in somebody's unit um having the traps
out there even if I put the boxes over
them the problem is they are not
terribly effective and in the meantime
they're chewing into somebody else's
property and so it's the most effective
way to rid the buildings of them
unfortunately I don't like it I wish I
didn't have to do it but they have to be
eliminated from places they don't belong
representative ktoy you had a question I
did thank you madam chair and thank you
commissioner for being
here
so we have heard um bills in this
committee before about
rodents and the rodent population has
been on the rise in New Hampshire and
especially on farms um we're now seeing
large rats uh where we haven't seen them
before and
um I agree that the glue trap should be
used inside or in a contained space
because obviously but the other thing
that we're not talking about is yes they
are a public health policy but they're
they leave their feces
everywhere and that is a huge issue and
very debilitating to People's Health in
this state um would you say that by
eliminating the use of these traps uh we
would see um more health issues that we
could see more health issues certainly
has the potential unfortunately because
I live in a old farmhouse with rubble
Foundation I've had to now hire um a
company to come in on a regular basis
because I just gave up whatever method I
was using and they use a multiple they
use multiple methods because my wife was
really Disturbed opening up a drawer of
utensils finding mice droppings in the
in the the draws um certainly not a
healthy situation
and whether those animals suffer those
rodents suffer during the process of
dying I feel bad about that but not as
bad as I feel about M mice droppings in
my kitchen
draws represent
ger thank you madam chair and thank you
commissioner for taking my question when
we looked at rodenticide issues last
time probably remember that well one of
the discussions we had especially with
some of the pest control folks who came
to talk to us was that that is a really
important tool right particular in a
number of scenarios right we're talking
about under structures Etc so I think
there was broad agreement that that was
an extremely important tool uh what I'm
trying to get at is kind of how
important this particular tool is and
the larger regime of of rodent control
if this bill were to pass is this going
to to make make it inordinately more
difficult uh for us to control rad and
populations I mean exactly how large of
an impact are we talking about are there
enough other Alternatives that uh
removing this as an option is not going
to have an enormous impact that's a very
um difficult thing for me to to judge I
wish there were people here from pest
control companies that could tell you
how many they catch on on on glue traps
versus not I can tell you that you know
for me
personally um it would have an impact
because the other me methods are not as
effective as I say a regular failure
rate of being able to catch them either
in have a heart or in uh snap
traps and um you know it it's a tool in
the toolbox that I think is absolutely
important as you've heard you know
there's there are more rats now than
there there have been and I'll tell you
that we have two old farmhouses that are
Apartments we have no animals around for
the first
time and even when we were in the
poultry business I don't remember rats
running around we had rats in those
houses that was very very expensive to
get an exterminator and to deal I
couldn't believe that we actually had
rats no no reason um and so you know I
would urge you not to take a tool out of
the toolbx to protect but to protect the
wildlife thank you thank you any other
questions representative
Penza it seems like it was decades ago
um we had a we had an um a pest control
company come cuz we purchased a house in
conquered and it had some mice
and in the house and the basement they
had used glue traps um but they didn't
work and do people really use these
outside like I just I'd never even
really heard of that
so until I was here today and heard the
testimony I had no idea that anybody
would use a glue trap outside apparently
from the testimony of of others they do
I certainly have never used a glue trap
any place except inside nor would
I follow up
follow so is there a way to um amend
this bill to make it so you know stating
that it's illegal to use glue traps you
know in a in a place where it can hurt
other
Wildlife well I certainly think you
could and I would incourage you to do so
representative Bixby so do you happen to
know what section of the the code that
of the rsa's such Amendment would have
to happen to go into well this this bill
amends uh 40
43041 and creates a new section A and I
think you could probably do that in in
that area because that is the section of
law dealing with rodent control pest
actually Pest Control including rodents
thank you thank you any other questions
from the committee represent
Duty thank you madam chair okay this is
a little off base but um you know we've
heard about this problem for a long time
so is the integrated Pest Management
program or anything going on at UNH to
consider um birth control for these
animals I mean any any exploration any
scientific it seems to me if the
population is growing that I mean if we
if we put food out that had some kind of
a formula in it so that they couldn't
reproduce or couldn't reproduce as
quickly that maybe that is an area of
exploration do you know of any I am not
aware of any research going on on p on
this type of pest control at all any
other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you
commissioner for coming to testify this
afternoon um Adam K Karachi right
okay good
afternoon good afternoon Madam chair
Representatives my name is Adam I'm the
owner of pest end uh but I'm here today
as a representative for New England Pest
Management we've heard a lot about how
this impacts the rodent population and I
do understand that this whole bill is
based on rodents but in the bill itself
it does say any adhesive device which
really leads it to a very broad spectrum
of what that
means we have been fighting for the last
15 years and by we I mean a nation to
limit pesticide use we instituted IPM
integrated Pest Management the whole
point of IPM is to monitor figure out
what pest you're dealing with catch it
early make sanitation changes structural
changes to help eliminate that problem
without using as many
pesticides removing adhesive traps will
drastically impact how that works we use
those representative Canon said it
earlier when they were in the basement
she cut in insects on them we use them
as insect monitors most of the
restaurants you walk into somewhere
you're going to see a nice little light
on the wall that illuminates probably a
blue color those are fly traps they have
glue boards inside of them that's what
the biggest impact to us would be and
you can say well that's not where
rodents are going to get caught we've
all been listening today about how some
of these glue traps are not being used
properly there's no reason to have glue
boards
outside they will freeze with within a
matter of minutes maybe hours they're
going to flip over and get dusty and
dirty and become ineffective and useless
so there is no one no reputable company
that provides pest control that is
putting these outside there's no
reputable company that is putting them
to be used for wildlife control that is
not what we do we do need these for
roading control from time to time
there's a a place that we service that
in 6 weeks we pulled out over 400 mice
if we did that with snap traps or some
other type it would have taken forever
and we would have never gained control
being able to put these out for a mass
trapping as we call it is helping the
public health it's helping our food
sources this can't be removed from what
we're doing so that's one side of the
rodent part of it but again the other
side with our insect monitors the
restaurants you go to unfortunately from
time to time they get
roaches it's far easier for us to catch
that when there's one or two in this
corner as opposed to waiting until
there's one or two hundred that have now
gotten into the restaurant and we can
finally find them so I don't see how
there's a way to ban adhesive traps
without negatively impacting every other
type of pest control that we're trying
to do you can might make adjustments or
Law changes that say well don't use it
outside don't use it here people who
aren't reading the recommendations still
aren't going to read the recommendations
so what you're going to eventually do is
hurt the people that need to use it the
right way to protect our food sources
and our public health so that's why I
and New England Pest Management oppose
this bill and don't think that there is
a
reasonable adjustment that can be made
to make this
work thank you representative Murray
thank you madam chair and thank you for
the question I did have a question with
regard to um things that are more geared
towards like flies or spotted Lantern
fly for example in other states and we
know that that that's sort of a species
that is working its way north um so I'm
curious to know whether or not um the
glues are different in maybe like the
hanging papers that are designed to
attract flies or other types of things
versus the the the papers that are super
super uh adhesive for like a mouse so
the the hanging fly tape that's also
another thing our industry doesn't use
that's more of a general consumer we
don't recommend them most health
departments actually ban them from being
used in any kitchens or anything like
that so I'm going to kind of exclude
that when it comes to the flyboards or
insect monitors there's a standard that
they're all pretty much the same you can
buy ones that have a thicker glue if
you're trying to catch a rat if you're
trying to catch a rat you need a thicker
glue as opposed to a mouse so yes there
are varying levels of glue but 95% are
all pretty much the same
adhesive okay thank you and so in this
bill um it the first in the first
section it
defines adhesive based traps means any
device that is designed or is capable of
being used to capture a rodent by means
of an adhesive substance including
devices commonly known as glue traps
glue boards or any similar rodent
trap and further down in the bill it
does say just adhesive based traps so I
can see where there may be some
confusion as you know we're banning all
adhesive based traps um but based on
what the definition is it just points to
rodents I
um I just wanted to clarify that for um
for purposes of just everybody and but
would you agree I mean I think you did
say that the these kinds of adhesive
base traps should not be used Outdoors
correct I mean although I have heard
that people who own apple orchards Peach
Orchards fruit bearing trees whatever
that they you they may use these as a
means of not uh being able not using
chemicals chemical-based
um um traps and
so would you agree that then that they
should then still be prohibited from
using those traps and those
venues I don't see there being a need
for it I hate prohibiting anything
because removing a tool from that
toolbox is always a problem I wasn't I
was here not too long ago where there's
also rodenticides that are trying to be
pulled so if you pull the rodenticides
from them and you pull the glue boards
from them what are they going to do um
so it's it's tough again to me as an
applicator I don't see the need need to
put that out there because we have other
options but at the same time I'm not a
farmer I don't know what they go through
I don't know what they're dealing with
on a day-to-day basis so to pull that it
could cause a bigger problem and even
putting them in some of these locked
traps that we have we're going to run
into the same concerns that we already
have because if the hole is big enough
for a rat it's big enough for most of
the things that the people here are
concerned about so while I don't use
them and I don't see a need for them and
our industry doesn't see a need for them
to be used outdoors I don't want to
speak on behalf of farmers and and
people who are trying to put food on our
tables thank you representa
dsy thank you madam chair so we've been
using pesticides for 50 670 years and
our rodent population continues to
increase so my question to you is what
is your industry doing to come up with
other Humane ways to control these
populations because it really appears
that what we've been doing for the last
70 years and the increase in pesticides
is not the
answer so yes we've been using them for
that long but for the last 10 years
we're slowly losing things we're slowly
losing different types of baits and
dusts and traps that we can use
additionally our country is growing so
where rodents had places to live now
they're coming closer to us so that's a
lot of what we're seeing we have a lot
of Sanitation issues within our country
whether it's restaurants supermarkets
convenience stores they're not doing
what they're supposed to do which is
helping that population quickly
reproduce what we as an industry are
doing we are very focused on exclusion
as an industry we want to seal your
house up we want to make sure they can't
get back in but we still have to get rid
of the ones that are inside of your
house so if they're outside and they're
not trying to get in for the most part
we're okay with it even when we're using
the baits that's up against your house
we're protecting your house I don't care
about what's living in the woods that's
where they're supposed to be let it work
but our whole thing is exclusion it is
trapping there's smart devices now where
they're letting you know when something
is caught so we can get there quicker uh
there's electrocution devices there's a
lot of different avenues that we're
trying and I believe you're the one that
asked about the birth control devices
there's been one out on the market for
probably about 10 years
now it's not working the acceptance
level is horrible on rodents that would
be an easy way to do it that would be
very simple but they haven't come up
with that formula yet that works I can
tell you our industry this is what we're
talking about constantly we need to
figure out what's the next best thing
what can we do cuz we see what's going
on we see how the trend is exclusion and
trapping is the best part of what we can
do but it doesn't work on everything we
have videos of rats taking their tail
and hitting snap traps to set them off
so they can get the bait some of them
will get caught in a snap trap some of
them will get caught in a glue board
some of them will eat bait they're smart
they know what to do so every time we
lose something the rodent population
increases so that that's a a big concern
for us to make sure that we have what we
can to try and keep everything safe
representative Bixby yeah so um what is
the effectiveness of the glue traps
relative to the effectiveness of snap
traps and electrocution
traps so I'm going to say they're all
relatively similar um again the biggest
thing as I was just
saying they will generationally learn
what to avoid so if we have an account
that we're constantly using snap traps
on and that's all we use there will come
a time when we will not catch anything
because they will teach each other stay
away from those devices so if you're
always using the same thing over and
over and over again
that's where you come into the problem
so having multiple options out there is
what's going to help the most now again
as I said glueboards by themselves we
don't typically use them all that often
they get dirty very quickly as soon as
they're covered in dust a mouse can walk
right over it so you have to have them
in traps or you have to have other
options there but the downside to a snap
trap you catch one and until you're back
it's useless so when the account that I
brought up where there was four 00 mice
that we
removed if we just had snap
traps it it just it never would have
worked and that's where we we run into
those problems so the effectiveness is
very similar but it's just really based
on the
situation represent NAB thank you madam
chair thank you for taking my question
um one of the things we talked about
with the second generation
anti-coagulants was um making it so that
they could not be used for home use that
they were used by licensed applicators
do you see any mechanism for doing that
here are these more used by individuals
than they are by license applicators or
press control I think they're misused
more by consumers um but yeah I think
for the most part if you took out how we
use them for insect monitors and and fly
lights and all of that yeah I think our
our industry isn't using glue boards as
much as the general consumer for roading
control are they used absolutely are
there some companies that use them more
than others yes um but there are many
options that as an industry we are
looking
in or looking at to to resolve rodent
problems any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you so much
Mr karach for coming um and U may I have
the blue sheet from from the table up
there please are there any is there
anybody else who wishes to speak on this
bill this afternoon seeing
none um I will say that uh for our
online um portal which uh
has the where you can put in uh your
support or
opposition we
had 141 people signed in in support of
this bill nine in opposition and on our
blue sheet we had one in favor and one
against against this bill and with that
representative nap can I ask one
question sure um would it be possible to
ask the farm bureau if they have taken a
stance or have a position on this yes
absolutely we can uh we can reach out to
them and and see what they had thank you
with that I'm going to close the hearing
on HB
1351 I thank everybody who came this
afternoon to speak uh in opposition or
in support of HB 1351
with that I am going to open up the
hearing on HB
1325 relative to allowing private
ownership of small-tailed monkeys
raccoons foxes otter skunks and
Kangaroos and I believe we have with us
this afternoon representative Manion to
introduce this bill good afternoon
representative all right thank you madam
chair members of the committee for the
record my name is Tom Manny representing
Hillsboro 1 the town of pelum HB 1325
seeks to allow private ownership of
monkeys raccoons foxes otter skunks and
most contentiously red tailed
kangaroos this bill began its life as a
Twitter request for pet monkeys and
rapidly expanded into a wish list of
cute furry friends uh my girlfriend was
especially accept uh especially happy to
find out that raccoons made the list as
we've had a running joke in my house
that our dog and my campaign manager
Skittles would befriend one someday and
become a mischievous Duo uh some quick
stats on the number of states where it's
legal to own the animals on the list uh
monkeys 31 uh raccoons 16 otter and fox
are both 15 skunks 14 and finally
kangaroos three without a permit in 10
with I do not like to see other states
outdoing New Hampshire we've been ranked
the number one freest state in the
nation for many years running
but as evidenced here there's always
room to
expand I've heard concerns about rabies
which I found odd because any mammal can
get rabies it's not unique to raccoons
and skunks and any competent animal
owner will vaccinate their pets against
it as with all things personal
responsibility is the pathway to keeping
your pets and family safe and healthy
and with that I'm happy to take any
questions okay uh let's see see all
hands at once uh representative kulon
and we'll work our way down thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question representative Manion I don't
have any science on this and it could
just be a rumor but I did hear that
kangaroos are actually deer that have
been the prison so do you think there
could be a uh you know a conflict of
interest by bringing in these animals
that could have you know a
could have a advantage over our native
animals I I also not a scientist I don't
know if there would be competition in
that same
field
representative
Howard would um would rabies vaccines
for for pets that we already have work
on the animals that you're talking about
or would they have to develop um
vaccines for each animal I would have to
I'd have to defer to a immunologist I
wouldn't think I mean do we humans take
the same ra rabies vaccine if we get bit
I would assume not the same no I mean
mammals could be different per
species represent
Penza so is there a constituent or you
know an entity here that wants one of
these creatures yeah uh so the Twitter
thread I verified that everybody who
asked for something there was a longer
list but the people that I verified
actually live in New Hampshire were the
only ones who made the cut if you want
good representation you got to move here
follow up follow
up so I watched a a video of a skunk
that was deskunked and it was like it
was this great like pet or whatever so
is that that's I mean they do do that
right yes yeah and the same thing with
raccoons like raccoons are pretty
friendly I've watched like that's where
this whole joke came with my uh
girlfriend she loves raccoon videos and
watching them be raised like
cats okay represent Murray uh thank you
Madam chair um thank you to the uh
sponsor for taking my question I did
have one question around some of the
animals that you named I know that in
various sorts of um whether it's
Wildlife settings or Rehabilitation
settings not only do the animals
themselves have to be um vaccinated for
rabies but um are you aware that there
also the handlers who might be handling
these animals also have to be
prophylactically um vaccinated because
of the high instance for example with
monkey for
example that that I'm not aware of I'm
not but as with as I said like
everything comes down to personal
responsibility if you want to own like
an exotic animal of some type you should
take all the precautions necessary as an
owner for yourself your family and
neighbors any other questions from the
committee representative
Gera thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my question I I I think in
particular I have a question about
kangaroos in in the sense that I'm just
wondering what type of Veterinary
expertise exists in the state and I
understand of course if if we were to to
pass this
bill there's a market right people could
move here to become kangaroo vets uh but
it in the meantime or in parts of the
state which will not benefit from the
service of kangaroo vets um do you have
any concern that even the the most
well-intentioned
owner is going to be very limited in
their ability to provide adequate
medical care for kangaroos it's a risk
like so if you're going to take on a pet
you need to understand the risk of any
kind of animal and I agree that exactly
what you just described is what I think
if there is a there's currently no
market for that type of Veterinary Care
in the state because you can't own these
things unless you're an exhibitor so
right now it's limited to exhibitors but
if they became an open market where
people are allowed to own these I
believe it would it would bring in new
types of Veterinary Care thank
you represent Bixby so I was uh doing a
little bit of reading online and I found
a website of a uh a place in British
Columbia that Farms Kangaroos and they
one of the things they commented was
that uh when the kangaroos are very
small when they're joies uh they're it's
okay to have them in the house but once
they get older it is absolutely
impossible to house train them they are
they are highly destructive and they
leave their um droppings all over the
place and I'm wondering if you have had
any reports from people who have had
tried to have kangaroos as pets and
whether there has been a problem with
that sort of help
Hazard the entire reason the kangaroo
made it the list because I verified that
the guy who asked for the kangaroos
lived in New Hampshire I'm not aware of
anybody who has these as pets I've seen
a lot of exotic footage of people owning
things like uh links and snow tigers and
things like that like even crazier in my
opinion pets and people seem to do
pretty well with those uh I would not
suggest leaving a kangaroo in your home
but like people ALS some people uh raise
you know farm animals and things like
that you're not gonna I mean most people
aren't going to allow their like cows to
walk around in their home they'll have
somewhere for them to to
bed um I you know I did uh discuss this
bill with my own
veterinarian um and she was saying how
the majority of the animals listed here
well all of them small tail monkeys
raccoons foxes otter maybe not skunks
but kangaroos that um they require
certain habitats in order to live a
healthy and um I guess animal rewarding
life would you not find that um keeping
these animals in a home or maybe in a
habitat that's not you know uh that
something that these animals belong in
do you find that that would be um kind
of of cruel to them it could be uh like
I would say that all this goes back to
what I said about personal
responsibility if you want to raise your
animal to be as happy as possible you
want to give them enough room like if
you own a Husky and you don't and you
like live in a small apartment that's
not going to be great for the Husky the
Husky wants to run it's a running breed
so even in current animals that we own
now you want to make sure that when you
pick your pet for your family that you
have the space to accommodate the animal
that you want I would say that applies
to all of these as well representative
ktoa thank you madam chair and thank you
repres for taking my question uh first
off can you email uh your testimony yes
yep okay thank you may I you may um
would you believe that um just down the
street from us uh for several years uh
they're no longer there but we used to
have a
camel uh that uh someone had brought
over they worked with the state
department um and was able to bring
their camel over that they had as um
when they lived overseas and it actually
thrived uh and had quite a great life
that's great I mean I I would believe
that that's great and so and I also have
a question with regard to you know how
we have
um licenses for certain animals dogs
cats ferrets and they have to get rabies
shots and so and so forth how how would
you see this also U working into that
scenario would you think that these
animals should be um monitored or
tracked by the state
to should we uh keep track of people who
breed these animals um I I am not a fan
of any kind of government list for any
people being on them whether it be
animals or otherwise I I would be
opposed to that but you know if that's
how what's required to get this out of
the committee I suppose that's something
I'd be amenable to I'm willing to
compromise representative Howard
so this seems a little bit frivilous to
me and I'm just wondering do you think
that these people that you contacted
through Twitter would be asking for
these pets if you hadn't put that out
there as sort of a they asked first they
asked first yes so you heard from them
on Twitter yes they they they know that
I'm you know uh willing to put things in
for people sometimes people don't have
good representation where they live and
when they reach out to their
representatives they don't answer they
don't reply and I think I'm trying to
bridge the gap there and try to be as
accessible as
possible any other questions
representative Murray um thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question and um if if you can't answer
this maybe somebody after you can can
answer this do you have any concern
about potential um illegal trade or
illegal sourcing of animals that might
um come about as a result of a peace
policy like
this not really I mean in what what do
you mean like like smuggling
kangaroos
good second followup or yeah yeah I'm
sorry just clarify so so yeah with
regard to a myriad of types of animals
that we already know make it into our
ports of entry in various different ways
that are not suitable for environments
here in the United States do you have
any indication of whether or not this
may increase
that I don't have any indication on that
I'm not sure if this would affect it I
don't know anybody who's smuggling
kangaroos in and if they were legalized
I don't think it increase or decrease
one way or the other representative
ktoa thank you madam chair and thank you
again for taking my question you
mentioned that several States uh allowed
um these animals have you looked into
seeing what the requirements were for uh
letting the animals there uh in a lot of
these cases it's as simple as there's
just no uh ban on them so it's like uh
with the way that our fishing game is
currently set up is they have this big
spreadsheet and that's how I found all
this out and uh they basically list
everything that isn't like a fet or you
know a dog a cat Etc as you need a a
special license to be an exhibitor most
of like a lot of these states on the
list don't have something like that it's
just not banned not prohibited not
required a
license so you were saying then that um
people can own these animals like if
they have a zoo or um in the state or or
a some kind of animal um Education
Center or something correct so it's like
they call it it's classification number
five under the fishing game here it's uh
says specifically an exe an exhibitor sh
be permit Carri category five and that
was basically every animal on this list
qualifies under that as an exhibitor
okay thank you represent
Penza I'm trying to remember the name of
the company there was a company that
used to come around um it was from the
time my kids were little and they would
bring exotic animals uh reptiles and
snakes uh
Bobcat um I don't think there was a
kangaroo but um but in any case
so they already have to have some sort
of Licensing right or are you kind of
trying to wipe that out I'm basic I
wanted a private ownership like so you
don't have to be an exhibitor if you if
you'd like to own some of these animals
you don't have to be in like a own a zoo
or traveling whatever followup
followup so when we went to Kentucky
they had um there was a I don't I call
them I wouldn't call it a zoo but they
had um kangaroos my daughters got to Pat
the kangaroos they had a couple other
exotic animals but they still would have
to go through that process they had a
nice outdoor oops um area for them um
you know an enclosure when it got cold
so so but you're still there would be
nobody checking on that to know if
they're actually treating these animals
okay it based upon your bill basically
that's what the bill says like I I don't
want any harm to come to animals but
like even animals that we don't check on
now like dogs like it we don't have it's
not where we go door to door and make
sure that people aren't abusing their
dogs either representing Bixby so it
would seem that this that part of the
issue here is the question of private
ownership yes and uh I'm wondering if
there's anything different between the
private ownership of say a Tesla versus
a live animal a Tesla yeah or a you know
a Subaru or like you know a car and
what's the difference between owning a a
non-an animate object like a car and
being responsible for it versus uh an
animal to me very little I I don't see
any distinction like if you you own one
thing you own another thing thank
you okay any other
questions thank you for your testim
today and I'll call Kurt aronburg in
Humane
Society
good afternoon again appreciate the
time uh I'm Kurt aronberg I'm the uh
state director of the Humane Society of
the United States on behalf of the
Humane Society of the United States and
our New Hampshire members we
respectfully request that members of the
New Hampshire House of Representatives
oppose House Bill
1325 which would allow private ownership
of small Tale monkeys raccoons foxes
otter skunks and
kangaroos house build 1325 would allow
individuals to keep wild animals as pets
specifically small-tailed monkeys Etc we
share the concerns of the association of
zoos and Aquariums that wild animals
should not be kept as pets because the
practice is inhumane for the animal
dangerous to people and supports a cruel
industry similarly
the National Association of state public
health veterinarians does not recommend
ownership of non-domesticated animals by
the general public quote because of the
potential for human injury or disease as
well Humane considerations for the
animals individuals who lack the
expertise and resources to provide
proper care often buy exotic pets on a
whim at exotic pet stores and at Expos
from out of state online dealers and at
cruel Exotic Animal Auctions when these
still wild animals inevitably become too
complex to care for too difficult to
handle or simply too smelly noisy
destructive or aggressive owners abandon
exotic pets turn them loose where they
will either perish or threaten native
ecosystems or lock them in a cage where
they suffer from NE neglect wild animals
kept as pets frequently suffer from a
poor quality of Life they are typically
kept in a Barren environment that
deprives them of the ability to express
National Express natural natural
behaviors and where they suffer from
insufficient exercise poor nutrition
inadequate Veterinary Care boredom and
improper social
[Music]
groupings besides the physical dangers
of bites and scratches the species
listed in this bill present present
serious Zo notic diseases disease risks
and I won't get into those because I
know we have time uh
issues um some wild animals are
subjected to painful surgical
mutilations such as declawing tooth
extraction and scent gland removal just
to make it easier for people to handle
them and this is true of skunks sprad
for their pet
trade uh kangaroos let's just talk about
kangaroos for a second so kangaroos are
growing in popularity in the Exotic PEC
trade so this is very
dangerous and the problems associated
with keeping them particularly escapes
nearly half of the 46 kangaroo WABE and
waloo escapes documented by my
organization since
2018 involved animals who were
apparently kept as pets these animals
may never be found or are sometimes
found dead it is also not unusual for
the local police Animal Control to
expend countless resources attempting to
locate and capture escaped
kangaroos for example in 2020 an
8-month-old kangaroo purchased as a pet
a day earlier from a breeder in
Washington escaped from a van he was
being kept in after a 7-hour search that
included using a drone and going door
too police found the kangaroo in what
they described as pretty bad shape in a
neighbor's carport and transported the
kangaroo to an animal hospital with
their long muscular tail powerful hind
legs and Dagger like toenails that can
inflict Serious injury to people
kangaroos can be quite dangerous in 2017
a little girl visiting an Alabama
petting zoo learned how dangerous
kangaroos can be when one grabbed her
through the fence and started biting her
head causing lacerations that required
14 stitches in another a visitor went to
an urgent care center to receive a
tetanus toxoid vaccine after being
bitten while petting a young kangaroo
and an Ohio man was hospitalized
following a 15minute attack by his 6
foot tall 200 pound
kangaroo I mean I could go on I know
again for time otter are among the C
among the captive animals in the US that
have been infected with covid-19
as a result the US Department of
Agriculture has advised licensed
facilities such as zoos to discontinue
public contact with
otters they are noisy I skipped a bunch
they are noisy
aggressive otter used for public
handling at exotic animal petting zoos
have injured at least 19 people between
2019 and 2022
alone and destructive animals who smear
feces to mark their territory they have
also been reports of otters dying from
the stress of transport and handling by
people um monkeys monkeys primates fall
under five categories great apes lesser
apes old world Monkeys new world monkeys
and pro pro marians it is unclear what
is meant by small-tailed monkeys in this
bill in HB
1325 but primatologists agree that no
species of primate is suitable suitable
for for keeping as a
pet primates are proportionately much
stronger than people and as a result
even smaller species can inflict Serious
injury primates can also spread
life-threatening disease in fact more
than a 100 zuntic diseases have been
identified in primates primates
including small monkeys are incredibly
strong and become aggressive dangerous
and unpredictable when they reach sexual
maturity extracting their teth as many
pet owners do is cruel but is no
Safeguard against
injury
um you know there are other more sort of
nice reasons mother infant relationships
are essential to the healthy physical
and psychological development of the
primate species if we care about uh the
subjects we're talking about at all but
I I mean I think I'll just sum that up
in light of the over overwhelmingly
public health and safety and animal
welfare concerns associated with keeping
wild animals as pets we urge you to
oppose HB 1325 thank you thank you Mr
aronburg
any questions from the committee
representative ktoa thank you madam
chair could you uh could we have your
testimony please I think I I think it
got to you by via email but I'll make
sure you do get it thank you thanks yeah
I um I have a friend of mine in uh in
the town that I live who uh knew about
this bill and uh got in touch with me he
said that when he was living or
stationed in Malaysia they had a
short-tailed monkey as a pet and um he
said that they were
virtually angry aggressive and vicious
two-year-olds that would never they
acted that way um that that you could
never ever really train or control would
you agree with that
[Laughter]
sure thank you for your testimony this
afternoon Mr arenburg and Eric ORF I
call you to speak with
us
good afternoon again Madam
chairman committee appreciate your time
this afternoon thank
you as before I am here my name is Eric
ORF I live in Epsom I'm here as a
volunteer representing New Hampshire
ottomon today and I would like to read
their statement thank you for the
opportunity to testify on House Bill
1325 on behalf of the Hampshire aabon
House Bill 1325 would allow private
individuals to own native and exotic
species of wildlife as companion animals
without permits there are many reasons
why this would be a public bad public
policy in the interest of bvy I will
highlight a few the public trust doer
which debates back to the Roman civil
law provides the basis for wildlife
management in the United States and
Canada the doctrine asserts that
government that governments hold Fish
and Wildlife and waterways in trust for
uh for the benefit of the resources in
the public in New Hampshire RSA 207
colon 58 provides that is the best
interest of the state and its citizens
to regulate protect restore and conserve
the Wildlife Resources of the State
under a uniform scheme of management
through the fishing gain Department the
New Hampshire fishing gain Department
Department's authority to to require
permits for activities involving native
fish and wildlife rest on the This legal
framework the the requirement for a
permit to keep wildlife and capity
enables a wildlife professional to
inspect the facility where the animals
are are kept and to ensure that they are
adequate to provide for the needs of
animals which can be complex and to
protect human health and safety while
they carry numerous viral and bacterial
diseases many of these can be
transmitted to humans through bites
scratches contact with the feces or
inhaling
polluted air polluted by the by the
infected animals foxes otter raccoons
and skunks all can carry rabies these
species also transmit leptospirosis
leria hepatitis tmia monkeys can carry
measles herpes hemorrhagic Fe fevers
such as Ebola
seelos shalis yellow fever and
tuberculosis raccoon uh kangaroos can
carry
toxoplasmosis salmonelosis and Q fever
safe cohabitation with any of these
species will require many more
immunizations that are not necessary for
dogs or
cats hb1 325 includes no requirement for
such
immunizations wild animals are not
domestic animals are not adapted to live
in close proximity to humans wildli
Wildlife are unlikely to thrive in
captivity where they are deprived of
their natural foods and and behavior
behavioral patterns their Natural
Instincts are are to see people as a
threat and to become aggressive when
threatened safely handling wild animals
in captivia requires training and
experience a bite or a scratch can can
have serious consequences for humans and
an owner would be legally responsible
for anyy enemy any injuries by their by
their their animals
caused as I had mentioned before I uh
was a wildlife biologist in New
Hampshire for over three decades and
dealt with some of these issues uh hey
orph we got a rattlesnake for you to
take care of
so staff doesn't have experience to
Monitor and take care of things that are
exotic such as kangaro and some of those
that are listed here and hopefully all
of us in this room believe that raccoons
and skunks and Otter foxes they're wild
animals they belong in the wild not as
someone's pets
uh I guess to use a common used
statement this kind of opens a can of
worms that I think you New Hampshire is
lucky and I'll tell you when I visit
other states as a wildlife biologist
they think New Hampshire is doing the
right thing by prohibiting the uh
importation of exotic pets as you see in
some other states so I would uh ask that
this committee not monkey wrong and find
this bill inexpedient to
legislate thank you Mr horf and uh
representative Murray thank you madam
chair you listed a a whole host of
disease zoonotic diseases that um
potentially could be of risk to the PO
public population um one thing that I
was curious about um was whether or not
uh you had any concerns around the
proper quarantine of set animals should
this practice increase that people are
um bringing these types of animals into
their home environments whether or not
that would be something that would be
adhered
to well we know how people
are it is some of these illegal animals
are brought into the state and
confiscated and Maria Colby just
mentioned to me she has some pet skunks
that were recently uh confiscated by the
fishing game department so it it does
happen uh you know I know the law
enforcement division certainly seeks to
find out about the illegal importation
of pets in non-domestic animals and uh
take appropriate
action any other questions questions
seeing none thank you Mr ORF thank you
and I call uh commissioner Sean Jasper
to come and speak on HB 1325 with some
concerns thank you madam chairman me
members of the
committee uh I do have concerns with
this bill and I have to say while this
is a policy matter for you that I would
say that passing this bill as written
would be
irresponsible
um let me start off with where does this
intersect with the Department of of
Agriculture uh with
U colon one domestic animal means all
animals um that are kept as household
pets and that's essentially what you're
allowing here
yet the bill doesn't make them domestic
animals because that would bring in a
whole lot of other things what it does
and I'm not sure if this was intentional
or not but it's a great concern should
be a great concern to all of you it
makes these bylaw companion
animals and there's no clear definition
of companion animals that I can find in
statute but what it would do is make all
of these um animals eligible in the case
of an emergency to go with their owner
into an emergency
shelter may remember some of you that
that was just recently passed allowing
companion animals to go into shelters
now these you would be making companion
animals also of perhaps even more
concerned would be that in statute 161
uh uh F colon
31 elderly housing people in elderly
housing can if 10 or more petition there
can be a vote for 50% or more to allow
that housing unit to have companion
animals in it and I would suggest that
people would probably do that not
thinking of monkeys raccoons foxes
zoders skunks and
Kangaroos and so
they could vote people thinking oh you
know you're going to have a companion
animal as we traditionally think of it
and suddenly here's what comes in and
yes there are probably ways to deal with
that but think of how disruptive to the
lives of those elderly people that could
be during that
process
um companion animals are are mentioned
in the population control statute
437a one um not clear what that means
because we spec specifically speaks
speak to dogs and cats but somebody uh
would should look at
that um troubling too is that what towns
are what bylaws towns are allowed to
make under 31 uh colon 39 a town May
regulate domestic animals you have to
have a dog on a leash you have certain
things by doing this
not calling them domestic animals towns
couldn't regulate it you could take your
kangaroo out for a walk and wouldn't
have to be on a leash and nothing you
could do about
it um for me as commissioner uh one of
the more concerning things is the issue
which has been brought up and that's of
of
rabies um that if these are going to
be TR domesticated animals in fact
without using that term but they
wouldn't then have to have rabies shots
and I think we all know how uh prevalent
rabies is in raccoons foxes and skunks
in the state of New Hampshire what this
bill allows to do is people could go out
um it would appear to me and just pick
one up out of the wild and bring it home
more troubling is often that people see
a sick animal and want to bring it home
to care for it not realizing in fact
that animal may be dying from rabies or
some other disease um and and of course
this really again we have a chapter 436
on diseases to domestic animals and this
really just leaves that all out no
Health certificates you can Port it we
would not know it's here um so as I said
I believe this bill as written it would
be irresponsible to to pass
it okay any questions from the
committee thank you very much you
certainly have brought up some valid
concerns thank you uh I do not have any
other pink cards for this particular
bill um may I have the blue sheet
please
uh from the online
portal from the online portal we had 81
persons opposed to this legislation and
three in
support 81 opposed and three in
support and on the blue
sheet which M representative kulan is
now deliv delivering I'm sorry no
worries thank
you we have three people in
support and three people oh no this is
1505 I'm
sorry
wrong come
[Music]
on thank you we have sorry three people
uh opposed and one person in
favor and with that I'm going to close
out the hearing for hb1
1325 and I am going to open up the
hearing first of all I wanted to ask
does anybody need a
break just a quick F just a quick five
minute break please
okay
I'd like our committee members to start
taking their seats
please can I say I don't want to
no I'm tired I'm
done
[Music]
verbal okay we all set everybody get to
their
seats
uh all
right I'm going to open up the hearing
on
hp55 establishing an animal abuse
offender registry and here to introduce
the bill is representative PRM O'Brien
good afternoon
good afternoon it's been quite a day I I
have another hearing committee that I'm
in and they're exing and I'm so I'm I'm
trying to get over there as well um you
you can't get a replacement when you're
in the building that's right yeah so
it's been a day okay uh so this
bill came to my attention by my daughter
who is an animal control officer in
Salem and I thought about it for for a
number of months thinking about whether
or not it was
necessary and I I decided that it was so
that's why I filed this
legislation um animal abuse is
currently hard to um hard to punishment
is difficult I and I think that the the
speakers coming after me will explain
explain that some more
um and it one thing that really stood
out to me is how much of a precursor it
is to human
abuse I was um interviewed at one point
in my life on a murder case uh
and one of the things that the
detectives asked me was about animal
abuse
and it wasn't really exactly connected
to the case but it definitely was a part
of this person's character and it was
something I
witnessed
and that's not the only time I've
experience something like that I also um
I also spoke to uh a lot of uh sex
offenders convicted sex offenders in
this state with a program that I was
with where
um sex abuse survivors would speak to um
convicted sex offenders and this was
often part of that I know it's not
comfortable to think about about
but
um I don't really want to be overly
punitive and I know all of you probably
feel the same way I I really am careful
about that these people would not be on
the list for the rest of their lives
they'd only be on the list for a short
period of time if convicted for these
for animal abuse as defined in 6 RSA
6448 and it would be it would be a shock
I know that it would be a shock to them
and to the people that know them but it
would be an opportunity to address the
problem before it gets worse or before
it merely continues on um and so that
was a that was a big uh reason for why I
decided to to go ahead and file this
legislation it's it's something that's
modeled after what is being used in uh
Tennessee right now and I spoke to some
legislators in Tennessee about this
there aren't a lot of people on these
lists it's it's not I didn't consider it
to be too much work for our uh
Department of Safety to maintain they
already do this for the sex offender
lists that people in our in our state
use all the time to um find out more
about how to keep their own families
safe and their you know their children
in their
care there there may even be times when
there's nobody on the list I can I I can
foresee that happening I I foresee that
this will be a small amount of people um
but it's a tool and I think it's a
needed tool
so with that any questions I will try to
answer as best I can representative
Howard if um the oh thank you madam
chair and um I was just wondering if if
the progression from abusing animals to
murder of a human being is um
Progressive why would you keep these
people on for a short
time thank you that's a good
question there really isn't a lot of
interest in keeping people on for a very
long time just the fact that if this
were to pass and this were to um be
established as as as is in this bill
that to be honest with you I think that
would be that would be amazing um
there's a lot of resistance to it some
people find it to be too punitive it's
you know they maybe they think it's just
animals okay
well Jeff dmer started with Just Animals
I'm sure you I've heard some of
that representative NAB yeah thank you
madam chair um thank you for being here
and you don't have much time um what do
you see the purpose of this registry
what do you see it serving I mean do you
see it as like a shelter breeder
wouldn't adopt to what such a person do
you see it as like what do you see as
the end goal of having this well it
could it could stop the abuse of animals
by alerting people in the community that
do adopt out animals or sell animals
they would know know that these people
have that problem and that would solve
that issue where in one Community they
may be um they may be have found to have
abused animals but that information
wouldn't be getting to another community
in our state that would be hard to
communicate would be very difficult for
say the southern part of the state the
nor the northern part of the state the
Sea Coast the western part of the state
Sullivan
County this would help that tremendously
representative
ktoa thank you madam chairman thank you
for taking my
question I appreciate the intent of this
however uh in
our over several years what we have
learned uh is that a majority of animal
abusers have mental health uh illnesses
and I am not sure that putting them on a
registry would be in the best interest
of their Mental Health
and also uh in current Statute in our
animal cruelty laws if you are
convicted of animal abuse you cannot own
an animal for 5
years so I are you aware of that well
thank you for telling me more of the
Nuance of of that I appreciate that I
think this would not
be I think that this would be fine this
would be ACC comp that would this would
be complimentary to those same efforts
uh and I I I would like to go back and
and I know that many of the people may
have some mental health issues and
that's unfortunate and I of course don't
want to make those worse but you could
absolutely make that that argument about
sex offenders and and I'm sure it was
when before that that uh registry was
created a lot of people didn't want to
make things worse for them well there
are innocent creatures who have no voice
here just as children had no voice when
you know the sex offender registry was
was created they didn't have a voice
that helped to give them
one any other questions from the
committee represent Murray thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question I did have a question sort of
around
um levels of offense and I don't see
anything enumerated in here that would
talk about it's just an offense as an
offense regardless of whether it's one
animal multiple animals types
of harm against an animal so we just
curious if that is something you
had it yes and I have and it would be as
it applies to
6448 and that definition
um I'm not the best person in the whole
wide world you know I'm not a bad person
of I think of myself but I think I have
to do a lot to to get on this list um
there are some days I'm I'm a little
late feeding the dog that kind of thing
um but you have to do things to get on
this list I you have to do some negative
things okay so I don't think that
innocent people will completely innocent
people who are just you know forgetting
to feed their dog a little bit I don't
think those people are going to get
caught up in this and and from what I
hear from law enforcement is that
education is is the first thing they try
to do and it takes a lot before they
they press charges um I see there's
another question so yeah represent Bixby
yeah so um just so you're aware in uh
6448 there are two different categories
of animal abuse uh there are there's
misdemeanor abuse which is
primarily uh a results from
negligence and that can that's one which
is often uh stemming from mental illness
someone thinks they're doing a lot of
thinks they're rescuing animals but
they're bringing into bringing them into
a situation where they can't take care
of them yeah the other level is the um
is uh felony abuse which is purposive
and intended to be cruel uh and uh
without this bill making a
differentiation between them I think
there that that's opening up um a a
significant area of problems the other
thing is that the
negligence uh category is by far the
most dominant in terms of what people
are found to be doing thank you for that
question negligence is a is a problem
and you can you can think that that
there's less intent to int to to hurt
the less active intent to hurt the
animal you could say the same thing
about neglect of children children
there's less active intent to hurt
children but they still get taken from
their home for those reasons they still
go hungry for those reasons they still
don't have a safe place to sleep for
those reasons so animals are in the same
category and and it is unfortunate that
when it's someone who's not actively
trying to harm the
animal they get caught up in this but if
it does help keep that person
from from collecting more animals that
they can't reasonably care for this is
good for the animals I'm I I think it's
unfortunate yes that these people would
be on that registry but it does help to
educate other people that that give
animals that that adopt out animals or
sell animals they would they would be
given a tool that would help to inform
them of how they can keep such cases
from from uh continuing and I think what
you're specifically talking about might
be Animal Hoarding and that is a problem
and
um it's a very difficult problem to
address I've had to address it with
someone um that I knew and it was very
difficult to get that help it was the
most miserable thing I think I've ever
experienced in my life having to try to
address that and that was a different
state but um it was really hard it was
really hard represent Duty uh thank you
madam chair I'm curious um the cruelty
statutes come under the Department of
Agriculture so why is the uh Department
of Safety listed uh twice in here as
having responsibility is there thank you
something I'm not aware of yes thank you
that's a good question because it's
modeled after the sex offender registry
and since there's already that program
in place it was not difficult for
Tennessee to do it in that same manner
and it's just a small amount of
redundancy of what they already do so I
I was just thinking that would be the
easiest way to go about it just as
Tennessee
did okay I'm I'm still I'm still unsure
about why you believe we need a registry
at all I mean what's the purpose for
having this list let me go back to is
this so that people won't employ them is
it so people will um stay away from them
it's it I mean I I just I don't
understand what this list would be for
well you could say the same thing about
the sex ofender registry and I was
running um a certain kind of business
where it didn't really matter all that
much of a person you know there were no
children there maybe
a um manufacturing facility or something
like that no children no problem with
them ever interacting with
children then employing them wouldn't be
an issue here would this keep them from
being is such people being from being
employed maybe in the animal care
business yes um is that a problem I hope
that you can agree that that is not a
problem I think that's that's good
judgment but if
they were trying to uh change their ways
and be
rehabilitated um wouldn't we want them
to be interacting with animals and
learning how to do that in a healthy way
I suppose that might be a good thing um
it depends on your level of how much you
believe people change how much you
forgive them how much risk you want to
take with Innocent creatures who
can't defend
themselves um I with the with the
experience that I had the personal
experience I had with the Animal
Hoarding situation and trying to solve
that
problem
if if that person
kept trying to adopt animals I would
consider that to be just a continuation
of a traumatic experience that I would
have to continue to live over over and
over again to just have no power in
helping these
animals represent
Penza so comparing um this list to a sex
offender registry I just think is
there's no comparison your your apples
and oranges here so in creating a
surveillance state for someone that
makes a a mistake on you know with with
a with a pet or or with caring for an
animal is one thing this is just a
complete slippery slope so how I don't
understand what the I don't see where
there is any benefit in doing this
because people that are already felons
that have committed heinous acts the
Animal Control Officers and the police
would already know about who these
people are isn't that enough I wish that
was enough in the situation that I
experienced but it absolutely wasn't
until the mother kitten was trapped and
was eating her young because she was
trapped and and also uh a major
infestation of of um insects from that
fleas and I had to deal with all of that
I had to deal with all of that and and I
I was
overwhelmed um I don't want to revisit
even thinking about this please this was
really difficult situation for me to
have
um to this was an elderly person and and
I would say that the person another
person that was in the situation was um
very irresponsible and abusive and if
that person never owned animals again
that's great that's fine I have no
problem with that I can sleep at night
with
that okay any other questions from the
committee thank you representative prom
okay o'ri thank you I call Mary
bonel or banilla I'm sorry I can't read
it
pardon my slaughtering your name is it
panila Bania Bia okay good afterno mno
and committee um I represent the New
Hampshire State Police under the
department of safety I've been on for
over 20 years now um we are very neutral
in this in this matter other than we are
looking at some of the things that are
written in the legislation that causes
us a little bit of concern of how it's
written um with the booking photo coming
in if there's no booking photo taken at
that time of arrest whose responsibility
is it in order to obtain that photo or
is it going to be okay for that person
not to be on there um I know we referen
the sex offender registry a lot they all
get their photos taken at the time
they're registering to be a sex offender
when they're coming out so it's a little
bit different than that um it's also
written in here that the registry shall
remain on the department's website for
as such time as determined by the
commissioner that's kind of a is there a
minimum time frame the commissioner has
to keep keep this website up um we're
not sure on that um and then the last
when the individual's name is added to
the registry the department shall notify
them if they want to have their name
expunged we think that's something that
should fall on the individual not on the
department in order to provide that
notification um to the individual they
should just be made aware at the time
during the law that if they wish to have
their name expunged and also what does
that expungement look like we don't have
any guidelines set up there in order to
say if you're coming off the registry
prior to your two years or how long
you're on what does that look like um
there's also going to be a cost for us
in order to do this because we would
have to hire somebody um we don't know
the extent of how much this is going to
take of time so a program assistant to
right now would be 136,000 a year up to
150 when you go for the next four years
as it increases and we also need a
minimum payment in order to provide a
data base if we're going to be doing
this thing it we don't we have people
that work for us under um other
companies but but it would we're
roughing it education guest probably
100,000 in order to create this type of
database okay thank you representative
NAB thank you madam chair thank you for
being here and taking my question um do
you as a representative of the
Department of Safety and the state
police view this as something that would
be useful to
you to us particularly um some of us do
work in smaller towns that aren't
covered um not just in the highways in
the North Country um some may find it
useful I don't know that everybody would
find this
useful any other questions from the
committee representative Murray thank
you around the concept of the DAT data
management and and that sort of um
portion of things um when the photos
would be taken or if they would be
implemented in that photo how would all
of that be expunged I mean how does that
work the
whole the whole record or like I guess
that's my question would it be just be
for I I guess that's my question sorry
thank you for your question the way it's
written I assume that the photo and
everything on there would be expunged at
that time just the way this is written
here but again we don't really have any
guidelines for that
expungement any other questions
representative Duty thank you madam
chair um from the uh Bill sponsored um
it's assumed that there's not going to
be a lot of names on on this list and I
mean it seems to me like it could almost
be on like an ex spreadsheet so where do
we get
$150,000 for uh Staffing and I think
another
$100,000 for the database I mean I mean
let's assume our wildest we have 50
names on it the wildest I mean a
database of 50 would cost like $100,000
and take one full person for well it's
in order to create the database and
right now we can't quantify how many
people are going to be on that database
so we have to air on the side of caution
when when we're doing numbers because we
may need someone in order to um watch
this and take off the registry it's all
depends on how it set up but it has to
be set up in order for it to be utilized
so the amount it takes to um set up that
database to be created because it's a
little bit
different representative Murray thank
you madam chair I do have another
question with regard to the judicial
system and the trial um we know that um
courts are currently backed up and so if
a person is is going through trial and
is found um guilty or not guilty um do
you see there being any delay in the
addition or removal of anybody on or off
of that database I can't speak for the
court side I know they get delayed but
there is sometimes a way to set up it
that if there's something checked off in
that box that maybe it comes over to the
criminal records but that's something we
have to explore when we look at the
program okay any other
questions thank you very much for your
testimony this afternoon we appreciate
you coming over thank you uh Joyce
ARA good afternoon members my name is
Joyce Arabella I live in New Boston
I've been pretty active in legislation
for animals for several years
now and in 2012 we had a very similar
Bill to
this there's only a couple things that I
want to
say our animals may be our children but
they're not
children they are owned by us but we do
treat them like
children so so
um just to let you know Tennessee is the
only state in this Union that has an
animal abuse
registry several other states have
declined including
California so I don't understand the
reason for this this is
um at the
time years ago I think the bill was
withdrawn because there was so much
opposition to it and I understand that
there are evil people out there that do
abuse
animals and I don't know how we
distinguish them from somebody's
mistake or do we just you know you're
plus you're pitting neighbor against
neighbor oh I saw them smack the dog
well maybe the dog was doing something
they really shouldn't have been
doing so th that's another delery slope
and that's about all I wanted to
say thank you any questions from the
committee um do you feel yeah do you
feel that uh people who may end up on
this list would be targeted somehow yes
I absolutely do and in what way well
there are a lot of animal rights
people that look for these
things and then they go after abusers or
people that they feel are
abusers I've also seen other animal
abuse Registries
that animal activists set up and names
never come off them
never once you're on one of those lists
you're on it for good you could be died
you know you could have died but your
name remains because nobody follows up
on them there's
no
there's nobody watching that kind of
stuff and for the state one of another
big reason
why
um New Hampshire was against it then and
still is is the cost it's going to cost
a lot of money couple of the handouts
that I put here is some of the
costs $22,000 and this this is something
that I presented in 2012
so you know that those costs are at
least double now probably
quadrupled because that was a long time
ago and that at that time the suggestion
was that uh the department of
a make the registry and stay on top of
it and they simply don't have the
manpower to do it so I find it
interesting that it has been
suggested to go to the Department of
Safety
now somebody thinks they have the time
to do it and the money I don't know I
don't think it's money well spent for us
this is the live freia die State even
California said
no any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you for your
testimony did you have a question oh I'm
sorry go ahead I was delinquent of
raising my hand but thank you anyway and
thank you for taking my question I I was
just uh wanted to to see I understand
the concern about people uh who have
make mistakes right or or in someone
else's perception make mistakes
but what do you think about the fact
that that for this proposed Bill we're
talking about people who have been
convicted right so the the idea that
somebody might get caught up in the
system for disciplining in a dog in a
way someone else finds inappropriate I
mean does that apply in this case or
does does it help you at all does it
make a difference to you that these
people would have already been convicted
of animal abuse based on current law so
my question to you is how many people in
the state have been convicted of animal
abuse in the past 10
years I I I don't know but by my
question response was that is is that
just in terms of
people being accused and put on this
list even though they have done
something that does not rise to the
level of a criminal
offense I'm sorry can you repeat
that I I apologize I'm obviously not
asking it very well but just does it
make a difference that we are not
talking about people who have done
something that doesn't rise to the level
of a criminal offense they have done
something by Judgment of law that is
Criminal by Nature okay I think I
understand what you're saying so the one
person that I know that was convicted of
animal
abuse it was so sensationalized that
nobody's ever going to forget that this
happened okay so I don't know really of
any other people that have been
convicted I'm sure there have been but I
think that the the
numbers don't warrant us spending the
money for a
registry okay thank you for taking my
question I appreciate
it Kelly yeah just real quick so based
upon your knowledge there's only um this
bill in a sense would put one person on
the registry that's what it seems like
to me m okay well considering that's the
one person that's been convicted that I
am aware of thank you very
much okay any other questions nope thank
you and I call BNA
O'Brien
good afternoon good afternoon and thank
you Miss chairman and committee members
for allowing me to speak today it's
interesting there's a a quote by Winston
Churchill that really spoke to me in
this moment something that I memorized
in my math class when I was in like
ninth grade and it went that for every
individual there's a moment in their
life that they come to that they were
unaware that they were preparing for and
it's a Pity if that moment comes and
finds them unprepared or unqualified for
that which could have been their finest
Hour as strong a statement as it may
seem to you I feel like this is that
moment for me as long as I can remember
animals have been my
calling I'm the Animal control officer
proudly serving the Salem New Hampshire
Police Department in this role it's it's
both my duty and honor to safeguard the
welfare of animals and community members
in Salem New Hampshire working as an
animal control officer is often
considered a calling it demands
unwavering dedication and resilience as
we confront physical challenges mental
strain and the profound emotional toll
of our work from making tough decisions
like euthanizing injured animals due to
a lack of financial resources to forming
attachments with pets who we know are
bound to return to less than ideal
living conditions the risk of burnout
and compassion fatigue is a constant
companion despite these challenges the
New Hampshire Animal Control Officers
consistently show up day in and day out
to Aid those in need and pursue Justice
in cases of animal cruelty however the
reality is strongly disheartening few
Cru cruelty cases make it to court and
even fewer result in convictions
moreover convicted offenders often face
minimal consequences and can easily
obtain new animals or continue operating
in animal related businesses due to the
absence of a centralized public
registry animal cruelty isn't just a
matter of harming animals it's often
reflects deeper psychological distress
and may signal a propensity for violence
against humans as well research in
Psychology sociology and criminology
consistently highlight the correlation
between animal cruelty and subsequent
violent Behavior recognizing this
establishing a registry of individuals
convicted of animal cruelty is crucial
for identifying potential threats to
both animal and humans House Bill 1505
proposes the creation of an animal
cruelty registry to address these issues
such a registry would serve multiple
purposes firstly it would protect
domestic animals in New Hampshire by
providing accessible information about
convicted abusers this empowers pet
owners shelters and rescue organizations
to make informed decisions ultimately
preventing animals from being placed in
harmful environments secondly it would
hold individuals accountable for their
actions and deter future instances of
Cruelty by publicly listing the names of
convicted abusers the registry acts as a
deterrent sending a clear message that
animal abuse will not be tolerated in
the state of New Hampshire moreover a
centralized registry of animal abusers
streamlines the process for law
enforcement agencies to gain details on
individuals with a history of animal
cruelty by convictions to interrupt my
own speech as it currently stands unless
you show up in our local the majority of
Animal Control Officers in the state do
not have any access to that information
meaning
that I would not know if you commit
committed animal cruelty a town over if
you are not currently showing up in the
local in my
town by providing easy access to
pertinent information the registry
facilitates investigations into new
cases of animal abuse and enables Animal
Control Officers and other law
enforcement officers to investigate
promptly when necessary this in turn
helps ensure Swift Justice For Animals
additionally the registry would identify
individuals involved in illegal animal
fighting and puppy mills further
safeguarding an Animal Welfare
ultimately Beyond preventing future
cruelty the registry promotes positive
behavioral change and contributes to the
wellbeing of both animals and New
Hampshire communities it's a proactive
step towards building a safer and more
compassionate Society for all beings
thank you and I would love to answer any
of your
questions questions from uh represent
comto thank you madam chair uh just a
quick question are you representing the
town of Salem or yourself I'm
representing my own views I can't speak
specifically for my department okay
thank
you okay question for you from
representative ger thank you madam chair
and thank you officer O'Brien for taking
my question so I I just want to follow
up on as kind of Madame chair referred
earlier to someone who's convicted of an
animal cruelty offense for example can't
own a pet for five years if I remember
correct correctly so if you could could
you explain kind of how that works
because as you're saying if it's not uh
if you don't have that information in
your town it was committed to town over
so could could you explain to us how
current um law Works in terms of
preventing someone who's convicted from
getting a pet thank you so much for that
question I appreciate it I like to
describe our current legislation
regarding that so RSA 644 Section 8 as a
Civ there's a lot of loopholes and if
you're using it as a bucket to hold
water it's useless so as it stands if
you commit a crime and it would be a
miracle on itself if the judge decides
that they want to remove that animal for
one to five years it is not a shall
statement that judge has the discretion
thereof to make the decision as to
whether or not they're going to charge
you in a position in which you can no
longer have pets or be around pets so on
so forth that very very rarely happens
in fact in many cases in which I finally
get to court with an animal cruelty
conviction case the charge is deferred
for a number of years pending the fact
that they not do anything that could be
considered animal cruelty in that time
period so the likelihood that you
actually earn and I say it strongly earn
the status of an offender in animal
cruelty is extremely rare not because it
doesn't happen but because most towns
don't want to take it to court our
prosecutors don't always know how to
prosecute it so they won't thankfully
mine does two
you're very unlikely to actually get
sentenced because a lot of those are
deferred sentences and three you're very
very unlikely to have your animals taken
away and if that does happen unless you
show up in the local systems in the town
that the Animal control officer Works in
they're not going to know that you have
that held against you so you could show
up with a dog in sail in New Hampshire
having been convicted in Windam unless I
have information on you in our local I
don't know that you can't have a dog and
I'm going to work on Education First as
I always do I always give Ben people the
benefit of the doubt to begin with so
that person's going to continue to be
treated by myself and any other law
enforcement officer in my town like they
haven't done anything wrong by
forgetting to feed the dog for a couple
days asle yes thank you very much
Duty thank you madam chair um I
understand what you're saying and um
commissioner Jasper has been here many
times talking about the to
that animal cruelty cases take on his
employees um but uh and I and I see what
you want to do here except that in order
to get on the registry you have to be
convicted and I and I hear what you're
saying is getting a conviction is very
hard commissioner Jasper has told us
getting convictions are very hard uh
primarily due to the finances if a town
takes somebody to court then they have
to take possession of the animals and
you know while the court case is going
on and towns don't want to take on a
financial responsibility so I don't
understand if you have to be convicted
to get on the list and convictions are
few and far between how is the spill
going to really help the situation that
needs to be addressed I agree no thank
you I appreciate that question and I
appreciate you giving me the opportunity
to clarify so it isn't about necessarily
being punitive or punishing somebody who
has been convicted of animal cruelty
it's about having a record in the
knowledge that that has happened um as I
mentioned before a lot of our Animal
Control Officers are not provided the
opportunity to go to the part-time
Academy and become certified officers
meaning the only information they have
if any is something called the local
which is a small computerized system
within each department that gives
information about the people who live in
the town sometimes we'll have
information about people outside of the
town for example you got a speeding
ticket in our town I know your name and
phone number now that's excellent it
doesn't tell me whether or not you can
own a dog or whether or not you've hurt
an animal in the past this bill would
allow me to then look that person up in
a different system an open
system giving me the information I need
to know how I'm going to move forward
with that specific case on a daily basis
I investigate animal cruelty that's most
of what I do and I go into people's
homes with a two-page booklet with about
75 different questions on it and I check
each box and each box is a different
statement as to whether or not I feel
that this animal has everything it needs
to be in a safe and healthy environment
I'm going to be a lot more lenient with
someone who I don't believe has any
history of animal cruelty than I would
be with someone who I know does simply
because I would be looking for different
indicators different things this would
give me that
ability representative
Penza I think I want to piggy back on
representative Duty's question how many
convictions since you've been working in
the department have how many how many um
convictions the only conviction I've
gotten to see was deferred they the
judge at the time told me that they
wanted to see this person have more
education brought to them which was
surprising to me because we had already
done our best to educate him by the time
he got there um they didn't even have a
system for how that education's done
because it's so un precedented they
don't know how to handle it when animal
cruelty happens so I had to invent a
brand new class for this person to take
so that they could learn how to better
handle their animals I would like to
State without specific information about
that case that this person was there for
leaving their dogs in a hot environment
on multiple occasions in our town alone
let alone what I learned later which is
that he done it in multiple other towns
as well without having been brought to
court he brought his dogs to court that
day and left them in the car so these
kind of things continue to build and
continue to happen follow up though
follow up but this is one but this
person wasn't convicted or they were it
was it was um deferred so they weren't
convicted at that time meaning that I
don't have any currently happening
however I've only been in Salem
specifically for a year so that is a
very small amount of time that said it
just goes to show how rarely this
conviction actually happens so we're not
going to have people who don't I guess
you could say deserve to be on that list
end up there
that's why but this bill wouldn't help
you though because this how the Bill's
written is not going to provide you the
information that you'd like it I mean
you're you're amazing by the way I just
have to say that just your testimony and
your presence it's it's wonderful and
you can tell that you love what you do
but this bill is not going to give you
that information that you're looking for
May I respond before we jump to the next
thank you I'm so sorry I don't want to
cut you off again um and thank you for
your com compliment as far as what I'm
looking for from this and where many
people behind me are also looking for
because I got the original idea for this
by being asked on multiple occasions by
different shelters where the registry
list was and I had to inform them it
didn't exist I've also been asked by
multiple acos when this was going to
happen but it doesn't exist so the
information we're looking for is not
only going to potentially help for now
but help for moving forward when our
laws are in a position or when we have
enough of a a knowledge based to convict
people I want to see this already in
place to build upon because right now
there could be more cruelty cases out
there that there are convictions on but
I just don't know and I have no way of
getting that information your question
is an excellent one I wish I could
answer it it simply isn't available
because the state Bas doesn't exist
yet representative comto thank you madam
chair and again thank you for being here
and thank you uh for taking my question
you mentioned in your
testimony that the rsaa says
may um and I'm looking here it says upon
a person's conviction of cruelty to
animals the court shall dispose of the
confiscated animal um so they must of
the confiscated animal yes however that
doesn't mean that the animal that wasn't
abused that's in their home has to be
removed so let's say you've got two dogs
fluffy and Spike and you abused fluffy
Spike doesn't necessarily have to be
moved representative com tomor thank you
and I appreciate what you're saying but
you under convictions and under the
cruelty laws It also says it will
prohibit you from future ownership of
animals for up to five years for up to
five years but that's a desp for a
minimum of 5 years not up to for a
minimum of five years so even though
they may have another animal in the home
they are forbidden from owning that
animal it doesn't however prevent their
roommate spouse anyone else who has Co
ownership Potential from owning the
animal which can be easily switched over
um that said even so reviewing that law
I can't quote it precisely I'm going to
be honest I have most of them memorized
that one I don't have word for word
memorized um for my understanding and
how it's been actually acted out in
court the judge has the ability to say
whether or not they're going to actually
do
that representative H Haskins thank you
madam chair I want to Second what um
representative put T said you do a very
difficult job and you present yourself
amazingly well I'm curious to how you
get call to a given household how does
that happen can you elaborate a little
bit on what type of call looking at yeah
how do you check in on a animal that
might be abused how do you get to go to
that residence what is it that
necessitates you getting a call in your
official duties so that is an excellent
question with a very broad answer I'm
going to try to to shorten it as best I
can there are a thousand different ways
that call can happen I can get a call
from the sheriff's department and
Michaela who covers Salem could call me
up and say she might have seen something
kind of sketchy at a home but that
doesn't allow me to the entry to that
home so for me to finally get entry to
see if neglect is happening I have to
have a search warrant in order to get a
search warrant I have up to year two
years worth of Investigation to do so by
the time I even get in there to see if
the animals neglected there's been a ton
of back work done I then have to bring
it to court for that I need my executed
search warrant to bring a ton of
information to light that I can use as
justification to my prosecutor as to why
we're going to bring that to court once
it's to court I have to convince a judge
who may or may not have any knowledge of
Animal Care cruelty or the statutes at
all whatsoever that this is important
and this person needs to be convicted
so it's not just a matter of I forgot to
feed my dog for a couple days it's a
matter of I worked up to five years to
get into this home to help this Animal
by the time they're
convicted their name needs to be
somewhere so that I can find out or
other acos can find out what happened
and how that should be treated moving
forward thank you represent ktoa thank
you madam chair and thank you again um
now it is my understanding uh you're an
Animal control officer but if the
sheriff decided that he wanted to get
into that home or a police officer they
would be able to get in there more
readily because they have the
enforcement behind them whereas you
don't is that correct uh that is
incorrect I work for the Salem New
Hampshire Police Department I am very
grateful to find that I have the backing
of a number of fine individuals there so
when I find information out I'm able to
then transfer that information to a
patrol officer who signs off off on my
search warrant well didn't sign off they
sign off on my warrant affidavit which
then goes to get signed off by JP so
they would follow the same steps that I
do the only difference being that I go
to a patrol officer first with my Warren
affidavit and tell them what happened
and they sign off on it and then they
follow the same steps if it were them
they would grab the warrant affidavit
and follow the same steps without having
to get a second
signature any other
questions thank you for coming and
speaking today thank you appreciate it
uh call Nancy
Holmes
afraid
yeah
yeah sorry it takes a minute to maneuver
around my name is Nancy Holmes I'm here
today from New Boston New Hampshire and
I'm here
because every time I see this bill come
up I find I like it less and less and
that has to do with in part you know of
course life experience the more you have
the more you're apt to find something
that you you uh get Consolidated on um I
have a big background in animals I've
done rescue I've been a breeder I've
done showing and training and behavior
modification and so I and I own both
dogs and cats um I was an online pet
expert for six years so now you got an
idea that I at least might know
something um because I'm interested in
animals I follow the local animals for
sale
advertising um the rescue and adoption
that Network information and of course
animal news um yeah while I've always
carefully screened new homes for pet
pets that I might place with them that
doesn't always happen I'm speaking in
opposition because among other things
the internet is a dangerous
place unlike the laws for registering
sex offenders where the intent is to
protect the community at large by making
information available for informed
decision making by parents to help their
children avoid stranger danger the
animal abuse registry Bill serves no
particular purpose for protecting
members of the public instead it seems
to fly in the face of our perception of
the justice system that one can pay
one's debt to society and move on with
life from what I can see of the average
pet owner who is placing a litter an
individual animal the dog they inherited
from their mother-in-law whatever they
don't do health certificates which are
required by law they don't do even
minimal checking of a person other than
if they've got money um I can't see any
of them using a database like this um
and that's just you know people don't do
it if work is involved I put a couple
examples at the end of my testimony um
of people who are looking for animals
that they placed wondering what happened
because they lost their phone they lost
their contact with the person that they
placed the animal with um that that
happens all the time I just put a couple
in so you can see it um
and for me the bill really seems to
promote cyber bullying rather than the
reduction of incidents of animal
abuse um people are quirky they look out
there they look at um animal abuse
offenders and think that they are evil
horrible nasty people when maybe they're
just a little old lady who was a had
become a hoarder and could really do
with a lot more social interaction to
change that
behavior um the bill as it stands as you
pointed out earlier makes even
misdemeanor animal cruelty uh a
long-term sentence to public scrutiny um
ridicule and
censure horrible things can happen to
people who are on a list like this um
there's a um
I put a link in the bottom of this that
hopefully you'll get the online version
where you where there was a story up in
recent story up in Canada of what
happened to somebody who was accused of
animal cruelty it was all a fake thing
with somebody trying to get back at them
and this person was really maligned all
over the Internet so it's it's the kind
of thing where this can happen to people
um even if they have been convicted of
animal cruelty they were animal cruelty
will this help them get past it what
does this this do to help stop this from
happening again I don't see anything
that it does um you know the thing that
I do see is
that we could use some money put into
intervention to maybe monitor those
people who are convicted to make sure
that they are abiding by whatever the
court has said that somebody accused of
hoarding and convicted of hoarding could
get the mental health uh that they need
um I know some people with a situation
where the the particular like livestock
where it's gone to animal cruelty the
people just had no money they had no
couldn't figure out what to do with the
animals they had no money to feed them
okay um so I just can't see the people
who have been in a bad situation or have
a mental health issue or whatever I
can't see them put out there to be a
target for anybody who decides they want
to handle them um you know I think you
know just making sure like somebody like
aorta gets the social services they need
somebody with an anger issue gets the um
Anger Management training they need and
I suppose you know with this bill it
depends on your goals whether you feel
that public shaming or help with
Rehabilitation is the best choice for
working on this problem I personally
think trying for rehabilitation and
monitoring is a better deal um and I
hope you find this bill in expedient to
legislate just as it's happened every
other the time it has come up that I've
seen um I'd be happy to answer any
questions representative
kulan thank you madam chair and thank
you for your testimony today I just had
one question for you it's do you think
that a program or registry like this
could have the potential to be
weaponized against people that might not
be guilty of animal cruelty well as
hopefully the people who would be onor
are only people who have been judged
Guilty by a court system I would say yes
it has a strong potential to be
weaponized against people whose
circumstances we don't know we don't
know why they ended up getting convicted
we don't know what has happened in their
lives we don't know if anything could be
changed to make it different for them
but I absolutely believe that putting
people on a registry like this and
having it open to everybody to view is
putting a Target on those people's backs
and I for one would find it really hard
to find that somebody's house had been
burned down or their kids have been
attacked or whatever because they had
this conviction if you really are
worried about what other people have
been doing you probably should open up
let me see if I can find the correct
name for it um
the it's the New Hampshire criminals
records unit maintains information on
offenders and if you're really worried
about what everybody else is doing and
that everybody should know about it then
maybe we should just open up that which
is already in place and say okay you can
look up anybody and find out if they've
ever done a crime you know been a drunk
driver hey your neighbors are going to
know I I don't I don't see that as being
any different than what you're saying
for the for the animal abuse I really
believe that this is a a way to down the
road see terrible things happen to
people who whether or not they deserve
it shouldn't have it happen to
them representative German thank you M
chair and thank you very much for taking
my question uh I think there are
definitely uh some good arguments to be
made as to why it's not ideal to have
this just an open you know I think
perhaps the comparison with the sex
offender registry is getting us off in a
direction we shouldn't be going in but C
can you
envision a a tool for law enforcemen
like officer O'Brien that would help
them do their work something which is
not as is outward facing because it does
seem to me again based on the officer's
testimony that often we're talking about
people who are are known to local law
enforcement and who have had you know a
number of incidents and that that's
important for officers to have when
they're investigating so could you see
the usefulness of a tool which is
specific to law enforcement well they've
got one they've got a um a Crim a
criminal I'm sorry I can't remember that
darn name the criminal records unit and
you can access that you have to pay a
fee to access it if you're not a law
enforcement member but I believe a law
enforcement member can access it to look
somebody up to see what their what their
record is um now whether that's open to
civilian Animal Control offices I do not
know um but this this is the thing um
you know I I just can't see number one
the numbers on this database are
probably low number two as was St ated
the people who the courts have been
lenient with and say okay we're going to
defer these charges as long as you go
five years without having any more
charges brought those won't be on a
database anywhere the the charges are
deferred and those are the people that
you would probably want to be keeping
track of um so it just I don't see any
real utility to this and in my
experience the animal shelters keep a
list of people they don't adopt
to um I can't say it's still happening I
can't still say it's still always that
way and that every shelter has it but I
know that the shelters have been keeping
individual lists of no no adoption
to okay thank you sure any other
questions thank you oh representative D
just want to make um you you know you
made a comment that this could be uh
cyber bullying but you know I haven't
seen it in a long time because I don't
think they do it in the newspapers they
probably do it online but you know in
the newspapers there always used to be a
police report and who was picked up on
DWI and who was picked up on you know
some sex offense and everything so so
this is nothing new this has always been
it's always been public information it
it's not that it's not public
information it's the reach whereas
before you maybe only saw that
information if you read your local
newspaper or read your local police logs
and not everybody seems to publish those
but now anybody somebody in Minnesota
can decide that this person here abused
a Husky and therefore they are going to
come and kill them for that because they
like huskys you just don't know it's
it's the reach you know it's one thing
for your neighbors to find out and shun
you and give you a hard time it's
another thing that you cannot control
who was viewing this information and
what they decide to do about it and I
think that's a pretty scary
situation any other
questions thank you for your testimony
this afternoon M thank you for having
me
I'm next call Kurt aronberg to
speak I could speak
got yeah I'll get out of your way one
second one second
take no everyone my my only choice is
slow so you just got to put up
with I'm still Kurt aronburg from the
Humane Society of the United States and
I'll be brief
um you know I I do think that the uh the
great work that's done by the Animal
Control Officers in this state there
aren't enough of them that there's not
enough support for them we need a better
system in this state to make sure that
when there is a cruelty case it's
addressed and addressed by law
enforcement swiftly I think this uh bill
is a good bill it it establishes an a
way for people like I'll say officer but
is there a higher is an officer O'Brien
yeah officer people like officer O'Brien
to do their jobs uh have the tools they
need to identify abusers in the state
um so that would be my testimony and
support of
this okay any
questions thank you and uh my one last
pink card is Aubrey
fredman
uh Madame chair committee members Aubrey
Friedman I live in Bridgewater private
citizen I've owned dogs and cats um
don't have any pets right now I speak in
opposition to this bill
um I did a little re my my first gut
feeling when I saw this bill is I don't
think this is a great idea but let's see
what the research out there has to say
and um I found actually the ASPCA who I
got my last cat from and they actually
came out against the animal uh
Registries animal abuse Registries which
I was kind of surprised cuz you would
think they'd be for it and they had and
I have back up here I S I only made one
copy but when it comes around you can
just take a picture of the link it has a
great article about five or six pages
and at lists about I don't know 10
different reasons why they didn't think
the animal regist animal abuse registry
was a good idea um they said it was
well-meaning
but um it's not going to accomplish much
actually and all the some of the things
could actually be
counterproductive I just picked out a
couple now but as I say when it comes
around just take a picture of the link
and you can read the full article but I
do have it attached here but just one
copy so um they say things that could be
done in the lawn right now now which are
well- enforced no contact orders that
would be one thing neither it's existing
law these things that could help also
mandated psychological assessment and
also including pets in orders of
protection usually it's a you know
domestic abuse but so why not include
pets too because if this is somebody who
might beat his wife he might take it out
on animals too so include pets in there
so these are improvements things could
help with the existing laws without
taking on a new law that's not going to
accomplish that much um also things that
have been mentioned already
um cities and towns have their own
registry and counties excuse me but uh
and in fact I looked at one it was at
some city in Florida and it had about 10
mug shots and they all look like
criminals and scary people there were
only about 10 on there and so it is a
like as been mentioned it's a very
limited number of names on it so it's
not going to give you that much and
again a person could be if you got your
mug shot on it maybe you want to move
out of state so the person in the next
state might not have that so what good
is it you're going to need the whole
United States to really be useful so
that's one thing there is they're
they're limited and the number of names
on them are limited too um also was
mentioned in the
article um so right now it's a felony
you know that in the law and but plea
bargaining is a big part of our system
and in order to avoid getting your mug
shot on a registry somebody might plead
down to a misdemeanor instead of a
felony and they miss out some of the
things that go along with uh a felony
like U long-term probation and
psychological you know treatment that
might actually help somebody who's got a
problem so somebody who might get the
treatment uh under the current law to
avoid the registry might plead down and
not get the treatment that they need so
that's something to consider also cost
I'm surprised there was no fiscal note
mentioned in here but some of the like
Virginia they said it's like a million
dollar California was $2
million so and as the one of somebody
mentioned earlier there is definitely a
cost to keeping up this kind of registry
for a very small number of names they do
actually charge the offenders fees to
keep their names on the list it's you
have to pay but the number of fees is so
small there's no way it's going to cover
it and it ends up being a t a a cost to
the taxpayers to keep this up and uh
let's see if there was anything else
here um also most a lot of people are
getting their animals not from like
puppy mills you know uh uh
shelters and or pet stores they're
getting it from people they know so
you're not actually going to be covering
where a lot of people get their animals
from and also by the way the bill only
mentions dogs and cats what about
livestock Birds there other uh you know
uh Wildlife whatever you call it U that
are could also be abused and that's not
covered in the why is it just dogs and
cats so you're missing a lot so all in
all I just don't think this it's
well-meaning but I don't think it would
actually do much to to a cost to the
taxpayers and might even be
counterproductive as was mentioned some
people might actually come after you uh
if they see your you know mug shot in
there so forth so I don't think it's a
good bill and that's why oppose it thank
you any other questions from the
committee seeing
none thank you for your testimony today
is there anyone else who wishes to speak
on this
bill and oh and I we need your testimony
can I have the blue sheet
please thank
you
okay uh for the record here we had um
three people in favor of this bill and
four people uh I'm sorry three people
against from the blue sheet we had three
people in favor of this bill online and
11 in
opposition and with that I'm going to
close the hearing for
hp55 thank you everyone for um
participating today I would remind the
folks from our exec session this
morning um we need um committee
reports um and I guess I'm going to need
some from representative Bixby and
representative Murray and representative
brulard I'm going to need one from a for
HB 1132 on the brownfields bill and uh
representative germ as well so if you
can get them to me tonight or bursting
tomorrow morning I'd appreciate
it uh yeah three support 11 and I guess
um we are done for today I thank
everybody for their time and attention
and we'll see you
tomorrow